Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
So du hast Werte, was sind sie dir wert?
Ja, haben Werte einen Preis, ich bin mir unsicher.
Ja, wir sind direkt beim Interesse.
Dann sind wir beim Interesse.
In der intrinsischen Motivation, die Welt zu verändern und mehr Geld zu verdienen.
Wir werden heute ja einen Roman besprechen, wo das tatsächlich der Fall ist, dass es da um Geld geht und um Werte und kann man sich Werte erkaufen und welchen Preis hat das dann? Vielleicht auch den Preis eines Menschenlebens.
Ja, da sind wir ja schon in dieser Außenpolitik.
Genau, das sind nämlich die Entscheidungen, die eigentlich außenpolitisch die ganze Zeit gefällt werden, dass man sagt, ja.
Was kostet die Welt?
Das wäre jetzt eigentlich gut, wenn wir dieses Abkommen schließen, bedeutet aber für ganz viele Leute das absolute Elend. Da sind wir noch gar nicht bei Waffenlieferungen, sondern generell bei Handelsbeziehungen. Und jetzt haben wir hier mit Richard David Precht jemanden, der sich geopolitisch in den vergangenen Jahren mehrmals geäußert hat. Er hat sehr viel Kritik, ein heimes Muster dafür. Aber jetzt sagt er sich, ich lege ein Buch vor, das ein Angebot macht, wie eigentlich Außenpolitik sein sollte und wie wir Geopolitik gestalten sollte, also wie ein Miteinander möglich ist. Also das ist bei ihm, sagen wir, das Ziel, dass wir also nicht ein Gegeneinander, nicht ein Wir-und-die-anderen Schema haben, das wir momentan vorfinden, sondern es geht darum, doch eigentlich zu verstehen, dass wir als Menschen im Ganzen doch immer angesprochen werden sollten. Es sind aber da die Staaten, die in irgendeiner Weise anders miteinander umgehen sollten, könnten. Darüber reden wir dann heute.
So, wir steigen mal ganz vorne ein und ich will wörtlich lesen, weil hier werden mit Unterscheidungen gespielt, die ich ganz interessant finde. Also, dieser Essay betrachtet, und das steht jetzt noch vor dem Inhaltsverzeichnis oder so, wie ich das verstehe. Dieser Essay betrachtet, welche großen Herausforderungen auf die Staaten der Welt im 21. Jahrhundert zukommen.
Nee, das ist Kapitel 1.
Okay, das ist Kapitel 1. Gut. Und er fragt, wie ein halbwegs friedliches Miteinander möglich sein könnte und wie es sich vermeiden lässt, dauerhaft in alte Muster der Feindschaft und Konfrontation zurückzufallen. Also, das friedliche Miteinander, das konkrete, echte, friedliche Miteinander, der Zukunft, wird hier konfrontiert mit alten Denkgewohnheiten. Ja, also wir haben nicht nur Gerede und Gewalt, sondern auch Zukunft und Vergangenheit. Und dann schreibt er, und das ist jetzt eine Unterscheidung, also bis hierhin sage ich, das ist eine sehr wichtige so gesetzte Unterscheidung, damit kann man operieren, das strukturiert ein Buch ganz gut. Dann kommt er aber und sagt, es ist eine philosophische Perspektive, die er anbietet. Und das finde ich interessant, weil unausgesprochen ist ja, dass sein Buch thematisch, ganz pragmatisch, eine realistische, andere Außenpolitik für einen echten Frieden haben will. Und ich finde es ein bisschen zu zurückhaltend, hier einfach zu sagen, ich mache nur eine philosophische Perspektive. Sondern da will man doch jetzt eine konkrete Handlungsanweisung.
Es wird ja konkret werden dann. Also er sagt ja schon, wie es eigentlich sein sollte. Die Frage ist, was ist hier mit philosophisch gemeint? Also er sagt ja dann, dass wir es hier nicht mit einem Problem zu tun haben. Also es gibt ein Problem und das muss man lösen. Wir haben es aber hier nicht mit einem Problem, das man lösen kann, zu tun, sondern man muss nur, und das ist eine philosophische Haltung, einen Umgang damit finden. Also wie findet man einen Umgang damit, dass wir in einer Welt leben, in der es konfligierende Interessen gibt? Wie findet man einen Umgang damit, dass die einen sehr, sehr viel die Umwelt verpesten, die anderen vor allem darunter leiden? Das sind also Probleme nicht, sondern das sind eigentlich die Dilemma, mit denen man einen anderen Umgang pflegen muss, als es jetzt der Fall ist.
Wie überzeugend findest du das, das so zu unterscheiden? Also wortwörtlich sagt er ja, es gibt Mathematik und Informatik. Dort formulierte Probleme haben Lösungen. Die kann man noch nicht gefunden haben, aber es gibt sie. Mit Aufwand findet man sie. Dann ist das Problem gelöst und damit aus der Welt. Anders als in diesem politischen Felde, wo er sagt, wir haben hier keine Probleme, die auf Lösungen zu steuern, sondern wir haben es ja mit Herausforderungen und Krisen zu tun, die jetzt gar nicht diese eine Lösung oder die Lösung bringt so viel Nebeneffekte mit und so weiter, dass wir eigentlich immer nur von einer Herausforderung und Krise in die nächste stolpern.
Das finde ich sehr sinnvoll, denn ich bin ja ein Gegner dieser Leute, die einfach rufen, oder listen to the signs. Das ist ja auch nichts anderes, dass man sagt, wir brauchen nur genügend Experten und die sagen uns dann, wohin es geht. Das mag zwar stimmen in einer Welt, in der es keine Politik gibt, aber in der Welt gibt es nun immer Politik und Politik meint, Interessen meint, dass Macht eine Rolle spielt. Deswegen müssen wir in irgendeiner Weise damit umgehen. Es ist keine Frage von lösen. Wie löse ich das Problem AfD? Da kann ich nicht eine Rechnung machen. 2 plus 2 ist 4 und dann habe ich ein Problem gelöst, ein mathematisches Ja. Das Problem AfD ist ein anderes. Dann muss ich sagen, wie geht man mit manchen Dingen um. Deswegen halte ich diese Unterscheidung, die da gemacht wird, erst einmal für absolut richtig.
Dem will ich noch mal nicht widersprechen, denn das wäre törig, wie ich ausgebildet wurde. Aber man muss es 2024 noch mal kurz ansprechen, dass in einem Paradigma, das er hier aufmacht, jetzt eine andere Realität vorherrscht. Also er nimmt diese Unterscheidung. Wir haben Probleme mit berechenbaren Lösungen und wir haben Herausforderungen und Krisen mit trial and error. Wir gucken mal, wir hoffen, uns kommt auch darauf an, dass alle ein bisschen mitdenken. Einfach nur aus sich überzeugend wird eine Lösung nicht sein, sondern das ist politischer Weltstreit. Und jetzt schließt er ja an mit der Beobachtung, im Gegensatz zur Sphäre, in der Probleme erkannt und gelöst werden, wo wir also einen Computer in den Taschen rechnen, den wir auch immer benutzen können, haben wir große gesellschaftliche Fragen, für die es keine Experten gibt, sondern allenfalls Expertise, die aber nicht zu einer Lösung führt, sondern, wie er sagt, wenn überhaupt nur zu einer möglichst vorurteilsfreien Beobachtung in Umsicht und Weitsicht. Jetzt würde ich sagen, ja, das ist die sehr altertümliche Unterscheidung, die uns die letzten 300.000 Jahre geprägt hat. Also wir haben es mit einer Welt der Dinge zu tun, die sich berechenbar in der Welt der Physik, der Biologie, wie auch immer, verhält. Manchmal wird es komplizierter, aber nur weil der Rechenweg kompliziert ist, heißt es noch nicht, dass da ein Paratigma nicht greift. Und wir haben soziale Probleme. Und auch der KS Computer Club als diejenigen, die einem wirklich viel Spaß am Gerät wünschen, sagen die ganze Zeit, es gibt keine technischen Lösungen für soziale Probleme. Und ich würde sagen, stimmt bis hier hin. Denn wenn wir Prechts Vorträge ernst nehmen, in denen er die KI abfeiert und davor warnt und wir das noch mal mit Hararis denken, wir haben jetzt einen Akteur, der selbstständig entscheidet, der aber kein Mensch ist, das ist das allererste Mal, dass das passiert. Wir können noch froh sein, dass es eine Technologie ist, die über uns hereinbricht, die wir selbst geschaffen haben, also die wir eingeschaltet haben. Wir könnten sie ja auch wieder ausschalten, aber mehr ist nicht. Wenn sie einmal eingeschaltet ist, ist sie eingeschaltet. So und jetzt schreibt er ja am Ende und ich ziehe jetzt einen Textteil vor, der sozusagen, das ist ja hier Präampel gewesen, Paradigma-Setzung. Jetzt hole ich so ein bisschen aus dem Fazit oder nach dem Fazit noch seinen Epilog. Einen Anlass zur Hoffnung gibt es immer, was derzeit kaum vorstellbar scheint, kann schon bald realistisch sein. Jeder Menschheitsfortschritt beginnt mit utopischem Denken und wird stets von vermeintlichen Realisten belächelt. Doch am Ende erscheinen oft die Utopisten als die Realisten. Die Geschichte des Fortschritts in den westlichen Industrieländern von autokratischen Systemen zu liberalen Demokratien gibt davon berätes Zeugnis. Und ich würde sagen, wir haben jetzt, wenn wir beobachten, wir haben Probleme, für die wir nur Expertise, aber keine Lösung haben. Wir brauchen eine vorurteilsfreie Betrachtung in Umsicht und Weitsicht. Die Möglichkeiten, soziale Probleme in einer Umsichtigkeit zu beobachten, wie wir das vorher nicht hatten. Durch die Möglichkeit, dass wir einen relativ neutralen, auf jeden Fall sehr objektiven Beobachter haben, bei dem es drauf ankommt, mit was wir ihn füttern. Und wir haben ihn mit allem gefüttert, was wir weltweit an Wissen zur Verfügung haben. Alles transkribiertes Wissen steht jetzt zur Verfügung. Und das ist eine neue Dimension. Die gab es vorher so nicht. Und er blendet das hier aber aus. Ich würde sagen, das muss hier eingeblendet werden.
Stefan, du hattest gestern einen bunten Tag im Büro. Es ist ja nicht nur gestern. Ich merke es, dass du jetzt ganz KI-gehypt wieder bist. Und er leugnet ja nicht, dass es diese Beobachtung geben kann. Er geht jetzt zwar hier nicht auf die KI-Beobachtung ein, durch die Beobachtung durch KI. Er sagt aber, wozu es überhaupt kommen könnte, wäre eine vorurteilsfreie Betrachtung in Umsicht und Weitsicht. Und das strebt er auch an mit diesem Essay. Dann würde ich sagen, diese vorurteilsfreie Betrachtung ist ihm gelungen in diesem Essay. Ob wir jetzt diese Schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen können, die er daraus zieht, das können wir diskutieren. Nur diese Beobachtungen, die kann man sogar ohne KI an den Tag legen. Jetzt kann man sagen, mit der KI kann ich die genauer an den Tag legen. Nur es bleibt dabei, dass es eine Beobachtung ist, aus der nicht eine Lösung direkt abzuleiten ist. Und das ist etwas anderes wie bei einer mathematischen Formel. Und das führt uns nämlich dazu, dass wir erkennen müssen, wir können ganz viele Dinge genau beobachten. Und die KI könnte uns ausrechnen, wie viel CO2 eigentlich gespart werden müsste, um dies und das zu erreichen. Nur sind es dann politische Akteure, die entscheiden, ob es stattfindet oder nicht, die von Macht besessen sind, die irgendwelche anderen Interessen noch verfolgen. Und dann gibt es noch die Irrationalität des Menschen. Ich verweise hier auf den wunderbaren Text von Dostoyevsky aus dem Kellerloch, Aufzeichnung aus dem Kellerloch, wo Dostoyevsky ganz deutlich macht, selbst wenn der Mensch berechenbar würde, dann würde er alles dagegen tun, um weiterhin berechenbar zu sein. Und wenn er Amok läuft oder so etwas tut. Das heißt, wir sind in dem politischen Terrain, also nicht in einer Sphäre, wo es nur um genügend Akkumulation von Wissen geht, sondern wir sind in einer Sphäre, wo es um Interessen geht und auch Weltanschauungen, Moral oder Werte. Und damit sind wir ja in einem Terrain, dass man immer nur austarieren kann, was man aber nicht in dem Sinne lösen kann, dass man sagen kann, jetzt ist es fertig. Wenn ich jetzt ein Problem habe mit einer Software, dann kann ich dich bitten, da mal drauf zu blicken und dann sagst du mir, so funktioniert das Schnittprogramm eigentlich, dann ist das Problem für mich gelöst. Aber hier ist ja eine Konstellation grundsätzlich eine Heikle. Und er versucht ja jetzt über Institutionalisierung auf einer internationalen Ebene etwas zu skizzieren, das beispielsweise Kriege wie den gerade in der Ukraine verhindert.
Ja, gut, ich will nur das Paradig mal noch mal beschreiben. Also du hast mit allem Recht und es ist auch ganz wichtig, das so zu beobachten. Ich will nur sozusagen ergänzend jetzt, wir haben verschiedene Strategien in der Gesellschaft, um Meinung, auch wenn ich sie nicht teile, Konsequenz durchzuziehen. Das härteste sind Gerichtsurteile. Also Donald Trump mag das gar nicht, was der Richter da gesagt hat oder die Öffentlichkeit, aber er ist nun mal verurteilt worden. Das bedeutet, wenn ein Strafmaß kommt, gilt das für ihn, ob er will oder nicht. Wir haben in der Wissenschaft ganz viele solche Prinzipien, denn auch beim Klimawandel, es sind nicht 100 Prozent der Wissenschaftler, sondern nur so 99 Prozent. Also eine inhaltliche Überzeugung muss schon sein und die findet dann aber auch statt. Also wir haben peer-reviewed Aufarbeitungen, wo stringent argumentiert wird und die meisten Menschen verstehen das dann. Und es ist gar nicht so der große Unterschied, ob man jetzt Gott vertraut oder den Wissenschaftlern glaubt. Richtig nachvollziehen kann man es nicht. Es gibt so ein Prinzip, man ist indifferenz in der Sache oder es widerstrebt einem eigentlich, aber dann stellt man fest, ach nee, jetzt verstehe ich, mit meinen 100 Jahren, die Flüge nach Palermo und die Oper, waren doch nicht richtig, auch wenn es nicht meine Meinung ist. Also wir haben jetzt da so Zugkräftigkeit für politische Diskussionen. Und jetzt mal ein Modell, ich habe es letztes Mal schon so ein bisschen umrissen und ich werde es immer häufiger machen, weil ich es wirklich auch wahnsinnig interessant finde. Angenommen, wir haben politische Fragestellung, Bürgergeldhöhe, Mindestlohn, Einwanderung, der ganze Kram, wo wir immer sagen, das ist so streitbar, das muss ausgetragen werden. Weil wir können nicht einfach 20% der AfD-Wähler sagen, naja, wurde die bestimmt. Wir müssen euch nie, uns nie wieder damit befassen. Also es bleibt immer ein gährendes Thema. So und jetzt haben wir aber die Möglichkeit, alle politischen Fragestellungen immer auf die erste pragmatische und dann auch mathematisch brechenbare Ebene runterzuziehen, ganz schnell. Also wir brauchen gar nicht mehr Aladin El-Mafalani, der uns in so einem Comedy-Bit noch mal eine Viertelstunde erzählen, was es bedeutet, Migration zu Ende zu denken. Sondern wir können das jetzt selber machen. Und zwar jeder für sich rasend schnell, ohne den Aufwand eigener kognitiven Kapazität. Wir lassen uns nämlich einfach, also wir brauchen nur die Frage. Also die AfD möchte 24 Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland rausschmeißen. Wir fragen einfach, ja was bedeutet das denn? Volkswirtschaftliches Minus, von wie viel? Wir kriegen darauf eine Antwort. Ob das dann, es könnten 10 Prozent mehr oder weniger sein, aber die Dimensionen sind so hoch, wir haben den Mindestlohn so ausgerechnet im letzten Podcast. Also wir haben ganz viele politische Diskussionen, bei der wir einfach sofort auf diese mathematische Ebene, und wenn dann jemand kommt mit zu viele Leute bei Bürgergeld, wir müssen da sparen, dann fragen wir einfach, wie viel könnten wir denn realistisch sparen, wenn wir alle Verweigerer, und wir wissen, wie viele Totalverweigerer es gibt, und dann würden wir einfach innerhalb einer laufenden Diskussion, also eines Wortwechsels in einer Fernsehdiskussion, könnten wir einfach den Faktencheck sofort einblenden und sagen, aufgrund der vom Statistischen Bundesamt erhobenen Anzahl Totalverweigerer und wie wir sie zuletzt unterstützen, wie viele Sanktionen wir aussprachen, können wir, und dann kommt einfach die Zahl raus, 17 Millionen Euro sparen. So, und damit hat man sofort zum CDU-Anliegen ausgekontert, dass die damit 10 Milliarden noch füllen wollen. Ja, also diese erste pragmatische, auf Zahlenebene runtergedrückte Ebene ist jetzt einfach bespielbar. Das war sie vorher nicht.
Jetzt sprichst du ja von einem Assistenzsystem in diesem Falle. Und da finde ich es auch absolut richtig. Es kann einem sofort die passenden Argumente liefern, aber es folgt daraus nicht unbedingt ein Schluss. Also ich kann zum Beispiel, um jetzt das ganz extreme Beispiel, was du jetzt angesprochen hast, zu nehmen, mir von der KI sagen lassen, was ein AfD-Remigrationsprogramm wirtschaftlich für Deutschland bedeutet. Und kann dann sagen, ja, das ist ein verdammt hoher Preis, aber ich will einfach keine Ausländer hier haben. Und deswegen bin ich dafür.
Aber wir wüssten dann den Preis.
Wir wüssten dann den Preis, genau. Ich würde nur sagen, die Entscheidung ist immer noch eine, die man treffen muss. Jetzt sind wir als vernunftbegabte Menschen, die sehr gerne auch ökonomisch denken, nah daran, natürlich uns das ausrechnen zu lassen, um nochmal unsere Grundlage zu haben für die Argumentation, weil wir ohnehin gegen eine Anti-Migrationspolitik sind. Aber man kann auch das anders ausrechnen. Manchmal kommt man mit Zahlen nicht weiter, wo die Ideologie so stark ist. Ich würde jetzt sagen, das ist ja auch ein Verdienst dieses Buchs von Precht jetzt, dass er uns eigentlich zeigt, dass wir gewisse Konstellationen momentan in der Welt haben. Wir haben aber auch Institutionen, die eigentlich mal dazu geschaffen waren, dass diese Art der Konfrontation, wie wir sie heute erleben, nicht mehr so stattfindet. Und da ist irgendetwas im Argen, da ist eine Kluft. Und jetzt sagen die Realisten, diese internationalen Institutionen haben keine Zähne. Während jetzt jemand, den wir auch gehört haben, Manfred Nowak, der dabei Precht saß, der von der UNO kommt, sagt, doch, es könnte sich möglicherweise ein Fenster öffnen, dann müsste aber die USA das Veto-Recht aufgeben und dann könnte man anders das global gestalten. Und das ist ja erstmal so eine Überlegung, die es also gibt. Und dann will doch eigentlich Precht uns zeigen, wir haben momentan Schablonen in den Medien, in der Politik, die uns zum Beispiel deutlich machen, ihr müsst wieder in wir und die anderen denken. Und wir, das sind die liberalen Demokratien, auf der anderen Seite sind die Autokratien. Dann stellt sich aber gleich die Frage, und da sind wir ja noch ganz auf empirischer Ebene, wie kann es denn sein, dass wir so viele autokratische Partner haben? Saudi-Arabien, Aserbaidschan, warum hauen wir denen nicht auf die Finger, wenn es doch eigentlich Demokratie versus Autokratie hier darum geht? Und da kommt ja Precht erst mal mit einer Kritik, die sagen wir, jeder, der jetzt nicht völlig verblendet ist, teilen würde und sagt, naja, also das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen. Er stellt sich dann die Frage, sind also diese Werte sowieso unsinnig? Brauchen wir dann gar nicht mehr darüber reden? Dann sagt er, nein, nein, also der Universalismus ist schon wichtig, nur der Universalismus muss auch wirklich universell eingesetzt werden.
Genau, lass uns da beginnen. Ich mache einen Bogenschlag von unserer Diskussion jetzt zum Buch. Denn er nennt hier ganz am Ende dieses utopische Denken, das am Ende sich immer als das Realistische herausgestellt hat. Er kommt mit diesen Unterscheidungen, Mathematik, Informatik hier, soziale Probleme da. Und er sagt eben, es gibt ja Expertise für diese sozialen Probleme in Universitäten und Forschungseinrichtungen, also wir haben sie, aber nur selten wird das in die politischen und medialen Debatten verlagert. Zitat, Umsicht, Vorurteilsfreiheit und Abstand sind das nützlichste Kapital der Wahrheitsfindung, aber es ist eins, dass sich medial und politisch nur selten verzinst. Das ist ein interessanter Begriff, verzinst, weil hier wird sozusagen eine ökonomische, nebenhandelnde Tausch-Bild aufgemacht, das ja völlig richtig ist. Denn er sagt, der Motor, der die Politik, wie auch die Massenmedien vorantreibt, ist zumeist der Effekt. Also nicht die wissensgetriebene Findung von neuen Wahrheiten.
Ja, wir können das ja daran sehen, dass man es schafft, innerhalb von zwei Jahren einen solchen Schiff hinzulegen, dass jeder Fan der NATO ist. Und selbst so eine Kooperation wie die von Borussia Dortmund mit Rheinmetall nur noch ein paar linken Kreisen auf Kritik stößt, aber eigentlich stört sich schon niemand mehr daran. Und Campino würde wahrscheinlich auch im Kampfanzug mitspielen. Das heißt, wir haben also es mit ganz vielen Leuten zu tun. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch nochmal anknüpfend an das Buch von Precht und Welser, das sie gemeinsam geschrieben haben, die, wenn es sich verzinsen lässt, also wenn es ökonomisch sich auszahlt, und zwar aufmerksamkeitsökonomisch wie tatsächlich finanziellökonomisch, bereit sind, ihre Meinung anzupassen an das, was jetzt gerade gewünscht ist. Und das ist ja etwas, was so interessant ist, dass wir in dieser ganzen Kriegsdematte kaum Leute haben, die von einem Standpunkt aus argumentieren, den sie schon lange vertreten. Bei Leuten wie Teveleit oder so kannst du das finden. Und die meisten haben sich ja einfach so angepasst und haben bis eben noch von toxischer Männlichkeit geredet und die problematisiert und haben aber jetzt gesagt, ja also der heroische Mann auf dem Feld, das muss schon noch sein.
Und diese Logik dahinter, die uns da zurückhält, von der ich jetzt sage, ich hatte mir am Anfang noch mal ein utopisches Bild davon, dass wir jetzt Experten-Systeme haben, die wirklich anderes, also andere Zugkraft in Diskussionen reinbringen können. Er schreibt, die Belohnungskultur der handelnden Protagonisten. Und mit handelnden Protagonisten meint der Politiker und Medienleute gleichermaßen. Und in Medienleute, also Politiker und Medienleute nennt er, aber ich würde jetzt sagen, es ist jetzt unstrittig, dass er unter Medienleute auch die Experten, die aus dem Wissenschaftsbetrieb in die Medien schwammen, meint. Einmal deutlich ausgesprochen.
Ja, wir kennen sie alle.
Genau, also die Belohnungskultur der handelnden Protagonisten sind Schlagzeilen und Zustimmungswerte, mithin Markt, Macht und Karrierechancen. Das ist soziologisch 1a für ein allgemeines Publikum runtergebrochen. Genau so ist es und ich möchte noch mal kurz nur ausformulieren. Es besteht wirklich die Gefahr, dass Experten bei Anhörungen im Bundestag, Lehrer vor Schulklassen, Dozenten im Seminar ausgekontert werden von Menschen, die ein Gefühl dafür haben, wie sie richtig mit Claude kommunizieren. Das wäre ja gut. Die einfach im Moment der Situation Rückfragen stellen, die Experten Schachmats setzen, die auf eine Art und Weise Hausaufgaben erledigen, dass den Lehrern die Kinnlade runterfällt und die ein Seminar mit gezielten Rückfragen, die nicht irre sind, sondern die sie inspirativ aus einem kleinen Chat mit Claude während des Seminars läuft, gewonnen haben, indem sie ein Seminar wirklich sprengen, also in seinen Fundamenten Argumentationen aushebeln, dass der Dozent nicht weiterweist. Mit dem, was er im Kopf hat.
Ich will das völlig unterstützen, was du sagst. Also nicht, dass wir uns so falsch verstehen, dass ich jetzt wieder so tue, als wären die KI-Systeme gar nicht so gut oder was ich glaube dir, dass die sehr viel besser sind, auch das, was du uns da heute noch vorführen wirst. Was ich auch nochmal hier deutlich machen will, wir haben das, wir machen das im Prinzip gerade händisch. Also ich habe im letzten Podcast diese Frage aufgeworfen, ist das realistisch, dass Putin bald vor Berlin steht. Und dann haben wir zwei Clips gespielt, einmal von Mörscheimer und einmal von Weigelin-Schwitschrig, die beide sich die Truppenstärke angesehen haben von Putin und dann das mal vergleichen mit anderen Truppenstärken und Eroberungsfeldzügen und sagen, wie soll denn das gehen? Und das ist genau die Antwort, die also eine gute KI vielleicht auch geben könnte, dass die sagt, ich habe mir das mal angeguckt, man kann nicht mit 300.000 Leuten ganz Europa besetzen. Vielen Dank für die Antwort. Und damit ist dann, wenn wir das Talkshow-Beispiel nehmen, Strackzimmermann außer Gefecht gesetzt.
Genau. Oder umso deutlicher markiert, dass sie ab jetzt in Denkschablonen denkt, die mit der Realität nichts zu tun haben. Und das ist ja Anliegen dieses Buches, auf diese Denkschablonen zu sprechen zu kommen und sie zu explizieren. Sie da also zu hinterfragen. Also, die Frage ist nun, ob unser oft kurzsichtig und kurzfristig verstandenes Interesse auch tatsächlich unser wirklich langfristiges Interesse ist. Das ist ja interessant. Also, wenn man jetzt sagt, nö, da klopfen irgendwelche Leute so ihren Egoismus durch, fragt er einfach. Aber wenn wir den Egoismus mal kurz reflektieren und wir dürfen gerne im Egoismus bleiben, kämen wir dann nicht zu anderen Schlüssen. Also, die Karrierechance von Strack Zimmermann hat ja, ist ja sozusagen ein, die folgt ja einem persönlichen Überlebensinstinkt im Felder der Politik. Haben wir nicht alle ein Überlebensinstinkt auf diesem Planeten? Also, haben wir nicht eigentlich ein Interesse, aus denselben Gründen wie Strack Zimmermann, ihr politisches Engagement, das uns alle in die falsche Richtung führt, mal kurz zu begrenzen und zu sagen, ne, wir sollten jetzt mehr mal das Klima schützen und das Klima schützt man vor allem, indem man keine Panzer mehr baut, die für 100 Kilometer 5 Tonnen Benzin verbrauchen. Und so, also selbst auf der Ebene kriegt man sie schon eingefangen. Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, dass er hier an sehr viele Ideen anknüpft, langsames Denken, schnelles Denken zum Beispiel von Kahnemann oder auch, er nennt es dann die zwei Arten von Eigennutz. Wir haben einen affektiven und dann einen wohlverstandenen. Und wir haben zu viel affektiven Eigennutz im Sinne dieser Markt-, Macht- und Karrierechancen.
Und das koppelt sich dann mit dem, was man Wishful Thinking nennt, dass man sagt, ich habe dieses Eigeninteresse. Jetzt habe ich mir auch noch aus meinen Erfahrungen, wie Ernst Kassirer sagen würde, eine Welt zusammengebastelt und baue mir daraus wiederum eine Schablone, die ist eigentlich Interesse geleitet. Nämlich es geht um meine Karriere, um mein Fortkommen, um all das. Aber ich lade diese Schablone mit so etwas auf, wie das sind Autokraten, die uns beherrschen wollen, wir müssen gegen sie kämpfen.
Genau, wenn man an dieser Textstelle, wenn er jetzt mit unserem Leserlebnis aus den bisherigen Salon-Texten, also Long Term Missen und so weiter angehen würde, habe ich mir dann aufgeschrieben, im Grunde diagnostiziert er ja eine kollektive Impulskontrollstörung und begründen könnte er ja gegen einen affektiven Egoismus, den er unterstellt, einen effektiven Egoismus. Also das Buch so Effektiver Egoismus. Im Sinne von diesem da, wo immer effektiver Alterismus kommt, Accelerismus und so weiter. Das wäre eigentlich witzig gewesen, dann wäre es ein richtig modernes Buch. So im Sinne der großen, wir denken jetzt mal über Sachen nach. Erstes Thema, das er aufwirft, die Herausforderung unseres Jahrhunderts und damit eine Herausforderung, die eben nicht mehr thematisch runterbrechenbar ist. Oder wie ich sagen würde, doch, man kann die Diskussion immer auf die erste Ebene des Pragmatischen drüber erst mal durchrechnen und dann darüber reden, Klima. Alltägliche Aufregung, kleine Kinkerlitzchen und Skandale werden hochgejest. Die ganz großen, oder Verstöße gegen die Correctness werden thematisiert. Aber die ganz großen Fragen bleiben dann doch unausgesprochen und nicht behandelt. Wir zwängen alle unsere Themen in so ein Parade, der erste Weltprobleme rein. Das ist der Vordergrund. Die wirklichen Weltprobleme werden ausgeblendet. Das ist eine Diagnose, an die schließen wir jetzt an, weil wir auch deren Meinung sind. Wir haben eine Blase der Klein- und Scheinprobleme. Und die schwillt, das ist eine gute Beobachtung, umso stärker an, je verheerender der Lebensstil der Bewohner dieser Blase zur Zerstörung der Welt beiträgt. Da könnte man auch sagen, Wokeness ist eine Ausprägung schlechter Gewissens. Man will nicht die echten Probleme lösen, also fantasiert man irgendwelche herbei. Und dann kommen die Rechten und sagen die ganze Zeit, aber das Gendern ist doch so blöd. Oder was halt Linke so die ganze Zeit blabbern. Ist eigentlich ganz witzig. Hätte man ruhig noch ein bisschen stärker.
Man sollte vielleicht auch hier sagen, es ist ja ein Buch, das einen postkolonialistischen Blick einnimmt, ohne dass hier postkoloniale Autoren groß zitiert werden. Ein, zwei kommen vielleicht mal vor. Aber es ist ein Buch, das sich auch in seinem Stil sicherlich an ein sehr deutsches Publikum, wenn ich das mal so rahmend darf, wendet, das aber genau diese postkoloniale Perspektive eigentlich einnimmt. Also dieser Vorwurf, der da manchmal so bei Twitter Precht gemacht wird, ja, das ist der alte weiße Mann, der jetzt nochmal die Welt erklärt, genau so ist es eigentlich nicht. Also er hatte eigentlich diese postkoloniale Lektion gelernt und geht ja dann von da aus dorthin, dass er sagt, wir können nicht so einfach behaupten, wir sind die Guten und wir sind die Wichtigsten, zumal wir ja auch erst mal erkennen müssen, dass ja wir erst vor kurzer Zeit das, was Demokratie genannt wird, bekommen haben in Deutschland.
Und zwar nicht aus eigener Kraft.
Und nicht aus eigener Kraft, also wir gehen jetzt durch die Welt und tun so, als wäre die seit 1000 Jahren bei uns die Demokratie und deswegen verteidigen wir sie so stark. Nein, in Wahrheit ist das eine sehr neue Errungenschaft bzw. ein Geschenk, das wir erhalten haben. Und jetzt tun wir aber so, als hätten wir es immer schon besessen und andere sollten es uns nachtun. Und er schreibt dann, und ich glaube, da sind meine Probleme, die sich mit dem Buch ergeben, folgendes. Das Länder sich außenpolitisch an ihren nationalen Interessen orientieren, ist weder befremdlich noch verwerflich. Bedrückend ist etwas anderes, nämlich, dass diese verständlichen nationalen Interessen nicht im Kontext des Großen Ganzen gesehen werden. Wirtschaftsfragen erscheinen seltsam dekontextualisiert von ökologischen, sozialen und politischen Folgeschäden, die am Ende heftig auf uns zurückstarken. Und die Vorstellung, dass unsere nationalen Interessen ihre moralische Legitimität daraus ziehen, dass wir ja schließlich die Guten sind, ist ein eklatanter Selbstbetrug. Dem ist erst mal zuzustimmen, nur glaube ich, dass das Buch da immer ein bisschen im Dunkeln herumtappt, wo ein bisschen zu eng gemacht wird, dass es ein nationalstaatliches Interesse gibt, also derer, die den Nationalstaat leiten und jener, die in diesem Nationalstaat leben. Also diese Trennung, die wir eigentlich machen, diese Bevölkerung und Regierung, die wird hier häufig nicht so klargezogen. Denn man muss natürlich sagen, sobald ein Staat im nationalen Interesse handelt, tut er das in der Hoffnung, etwas Besseres rauszubekommen als die anderen. Also ein Gewinn für alle ist eigentlich nicht herrschbar. Das ist so wie, wir machen die Olympischen Spiele, aber es wird keine Verlierer geben. Und ein bisschen wird hier immer suggeriert, dass es das eigentlich aber gäbe. Und ich glaube, darüber kann man reden, aber dann müsste man wirklich auf einer Ebene der Weltgesellschaft handeln. Denn so würde ich schon sagen, kann ich diesem Blick der strukturellen Realisten etwas abgewinnen. Nicht, weil ich diesen Fatalismus auch so toll finde und mich daran labe, tun die ja auch gar nicht mitunter. Sondern weil ich sagen würde, ja, das ist im Moment gerade die Welt so, wie sie ist. Und ich sehe noch nicht so, oder man macht einfach ein Wunschkonzert, wie man aus dieser Situation herauskommt, dass Nationalstaaten nationalstaatliche Interessen haben. Manchmal mag das auch ein bisschen kurz gedacht sein oder so. Aber grundsätzlich ist das etwas, was Konflikte hervorbringt.
Also das kann ich jetzt auch nur sagen, weil ich danach Sahebi lese. Aber dieses, okay, wir dekontextualisieren, also vor allem ökonomische Fragen vor ökologischen. Wir halten uns immer für die Guten. Das sind so die Argumentationslinien der Mächtigen im Medien- und Politikbetrieb. Und die Bevölkerung wird dann so mitgeschleift. Also die muss diese Idee einfach so mitnehmen. Weshalb wir uns ablenken, davon Schicksalsgemeinschaft zu sein, und zwar global. Also wir haben keine weltweite Klimabewegung. Wir haben nationalistische Kriegsstreben heute, was ja vor allem die Budgetfragen angeht.
Ich bilde mir ja ein, dass ich Richard David Precht beeinflusst habe. Ich habe nämlich gestern noch mal ganz kurz reingeschaut, als ich ihn interviewte bei der Palastrevolution. Da hatten wir ja ein Gespräch zusammen zum Thema Geopolitik. Eine meiner letzten Fragen an ihn war, ob nicht durch die Klimakatastrophe, die vor der Tür steht, so etwas entstehen könnte wie einen Gemeinschaftssinn, dass man sich also als Weltgesellschaft versteht. Interessanterweise geht er gar nicht näher darauf ein, sondern sagt, er glaubt dann eher, dann wird das Hauen und Stechen noch schlimmer, so sinngemäß, und führt dann andere Dinge aus. Das ist manchmal aber auch, muss man jetzt zugestehen, weil man noch unbedingt zwei Punkte loswerden will und dann geht man auf die Frage vielleicht gar nicht mehr so ein. Jetzt ist aber eigentlich das Buch geradezu davon getränkt, darüber nachzudenken, was es eigentlich bedeutet, dass wir angesichts des Klimawandels unserer fragilen Existenz uns mehr denn je bewusst sind, wie also eine Gesellschaft der Menschen, die alle betroffen sind vom Klimawandel bilden. Und daraus müsste doch eigentlich folgen, dass man sich nicht konfliktreich gegenübersteht, sondern dass man gemeinsam versucht, dieses Problem nicht zu lösen, aber anzugehen.
Ja, das ist interessant, weil hier ist ein kleiner blinder Fleck, denn die ganze Welt versteht die Klimafrage. Nur man löst sie nicht kooperativ, sondern konfrontativ. Also in Amerika importiert man nicht chinesische Autos, die das Klima besser schützen als andere Autos, also E-Autos, sondern man möchte die eigenen Fabriken dafür. Und die kriegt man aber nur konfrontativ. Man muss da eine Zeugschranke machen und dann muss man aufpassen, dass man diesen konfrontativen Weg zu mehr Klimaschutz in beiden Ländern nicht eskaliert zu einer schießenden Auseinandersetzung von der Adam 2s wieder warnt, der Ökonom. Das fällt mir aber auch nur auf, dass das hier im Buch ein bisschen locker und unausgesprochen bleibt, weil bei Sahebi wird völlig klar, warum wir Volk, Nation, Kultur, Rasse immer weiter schleppen. Wir tauschen nur die Semantik aus, aber im strukturellen Handeln und Denken ist es immer dasselbe.
Denn eigentlich ist es egal, woher das Auto kommt, es ist egal, wie wir das Klima...
Der Fahrer weiß es ja auch nicht. Man sitzt ja in seinem Auto und man sitzt in seiner Wohnung und dann heißt es, jetzt ist irgendein Stress und dann guckt man erstmal in den eigenen Unterlagen nach, ob ich eigentlich eine Ölheizung oder eine Gasheizung habe. So, dass man keine Kohlen schippt, das hat man noch in Erinnerung. Aber den Rest weiß man einfach nicht. Wo kommt das eigene Auto her? Keine Ahnung. Yamaha, ist das Südkorea, ist das Japan, ist das China, ist das Amerika? Man weiß es halt nicht.
Ich will hier nicht wie so ein unverbesserlicher orthodoxer Marxist wirken, aber was, glaube ich, in dem Buch fehlt mitunter ist, aber wir müssen jetzt erstmal richtig reingehen, ist, dass Friedrich Engels den Staat den ideellen Gesamtkapitalisten nennt. Und das ist ein großes Wort und meint aber eigentlich, dass der Staat am Ende auch wie ein Unternehmen zu verstehen ist, dass mit anderen Staaten in Konkurrenz steht, die auch quasi wie Unternehmen angesehen werden. Precht hat das ein paar Mal so in Nebensätzen fallen lassen, nur daraus ergibt sich, dass aus dieser Konstellation heraus nicht eine Weltgesellschaft entstehen kann, sondern dass man dann wiederum Partikularinteressen bedient, und zwar die der einzelnen Staaten. Und das wird dann noch gekoppelt mit nationalistischer Ideologie, moralischer Hybris und all dem. Und ich glaube, dass diese Sache einem klar sein muss, um jetzt zum Beispiel auch zu verstehen, was beiden da macht. Der muss doch verstanden haben, dass der Klimawandel uns alle betrifft, und dann ist das doch hilfreich, wenn das aus China kommt. Ja, aber das nationale Interesse wird dann doch vorangestellt. Und eigentlich ist das ein Buch, das eine zwar nicht Staatskritik übt, und ich glaube, das hätte man dezidiert besser machen sollen, aber eigentlich ein Buch, das sagt, die Nationalstaaten müssen sich sehr zurücknehmen, denn es gibt Interessen, die über dem Interesse der Nation stehen. Und momentan erleben wir überall eine Politik, die erst die Nation setzt. Also Trumps America First war, wenn man so will, das ehrlichste, was in den letzten Jahrzehnten in der Politik gesagt wurde. Denn genau so wird gehandelt. Und deswegen liefern wir an manche schlimmen Länder Waffen, an andere nicht, weil wir sagen, das ist jetzt aber in unserem nationalen Interesse, dass die und die was bekommen.
Das ist ja eins der Vorzüge dieser strukturellen Realisten, dass sie einfach ganz selbstverständlich vom Nationalstaat und seinem Interesse ausgehen und gar nicht mehr darüber diskutieren wollen oder es auch nur anreflektieren, dass wir unser politisches Handlungsvermögen aus der Begrenzung auf Nationalstaaten gewinnen und auch, dass wir unser aller Denken an dieser großen Stabilität und historischen konstanten Volknation, Rasse, Ethnie, was auch immer, Kultur, Leitkultur, Diskussion, die nimmt man einfach hin wie den Baum im Walde und sagt, reden wir nicht drüber. Und dann machen die einfach strukturelle realistische Anmerkungen, die direkt auf die Politik einwirken könnten, wenn jemand zuhören möchte. Und das finde ich einen Vorteil, denn da ist nochmal zu zerreden. Und eigentlich sollten wir ja die Schicksalsgemeinschaft, Weltgesellschaft, nee, wir sehen uns leider in unserem Selbstbild nicht mit den Menschen aus Ghana an einem Boot, sondern das sind halt unsere Kunden oder unsere Rohstofflieferanten oder was auch immer. Aber dieses große Menschheitsbild überfordert uns.
Das Problem ist ja auch, dass wir eine Unterschiedlichkeit haben von Betroffenheit. Wir haben das bei Corona ja gesehen, da waren wir auch alle von dem Virus betroffen, aber doch in sehr unterschiedlicher Ausprägung. Und ich glaube, wir können das für uns jetzt hier sagen und für alle, die uns zuhören, wir werden vom Klimawandel betroffen sein. Und es ist gut möglich, dass er auch hier mit unter den Tod bringt, wie wir jetzt auch wieder bei dem nächsten Jahrhundert-Hochwasser gesehen haben, was ja immer so klingt, als sei das nur einmal im Jahrhundert. Nee, das kommt jetzt halt sehr häufig.
Es ist das dritte Mal in diesem Jahrhundert, aber auch das dritte Mal in der Geschichtsschreibung mancher Orte dort.
Ja, und wir haben aber damit noch, wenn es auch diese Gefahren gibt, nicht denselben Status, den Leute zum Beispiel in Ghana haben und vom Klimawandel betroffen sind. Das heißt, wenn uns nicht wirklich die ganz große Not trifft und ein Hochwasser oder so uns hinfort schwimmen lässt, dann können wir ja doch sicher sein, dass der Klimawandel für uns nicht tödlich wird. Und das ist schon mal ein sehr, sehr großer Unterschied.
Und in dieser Argumentation versteckt er ja eine, die macht er mündlich noch deutlicher bei Hotel Mazzo oder so. Ist ja da ganz deutlich, bin gespannt, wie weit das noch treibt. Aber wir orientieren unser Handeln und unsere Identität an Nation, Volk, Rasse. Wir kritisieren das aber gleichzeitig, weil wir es ja nicht so gut finden und sagen, das ist rechte, konservative, rechtsradikale, wie auch immer, Politik. Und er sagt jetzt, naja, aber wenn die Gegenseite einfach gesagt, wir orientieren unser Handeln und unsere Identität am Geschlecht, dem Alter oder ethnischen Minderheitenzugehörigkeiten, dann ist das genau dieselbe Art von Reduktion, die uns in Denkschablon einpfercht und den großen Blick versperrt, nur halt mit neueren Ideen, die ihre Gefährlichkeit historisch noch nicht gezeigt haben, aber das gleiche Potenzial in sich birgen. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, Punktlandung. Man hat einfach den Vorteil, dass man noch keinen altersbezogenen Holocaust durchgeführt hat. Aber bei den politischen Diskussionen, wie sie gerade laufen und bei der Herausforderung, wir haben jetzt das erste Mal alte Menschen im, und jetzt könnte man Flut betatbaren, im Übermaß, sie befluten uns ja. Also all diese Bilder, die man vorher so auf Rasse gemünzt hat, die könnte man jetzt auf das Alter einfach beziehen. Auch für Deutschland gilt, innerhalb der Familien und wir allgemein werden die Alten noch hassen lernen, weil sie uns stören, weil sie unglaublich viel Geld kosten, weil sie uns keine Entwicklungschancen bieten und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist, hier droht einiges und deswegen muss man jetzt schon mal davor warnen, das halte ich auch für sehr wichtig, also ich halte es für wichtig, dass Precht es macht. Ich finde aber, er sollte da noch mal ein bisschen Denkstoff reingeben, es muss noch mal raffinierter sein.
Was er ja sagen will, ist, dass es zwei Seiten der Identitätspolitik gibt, eine rechte und eine linke. Und ich würde sagen, dass man mit der linken, also die rechte ist natürlich sehr leicht kritisiert und das ist ja auch eingeübt. Mit der linken haben wir ein Problem, wenn es sich ja mit wünschenswerten emanzipatorischen Anliegen verknüpft. Also wenn man beispielsweise sagt, es soll nicht mehr jemand diskriminiert werden, aufgrund zum Beispiel seiner sexuellen Neigung. Die Sache wird nur da heikel, wo also nicht nur dieses emanzipatorische Versprechen damit verbunden ist, sondern wenn plötzlich die Identität ausschlaggebend ist, für zum Beispiel eine Politik, die sagt, weil er diese Identität hat, hat er auch recht.
Bei der Verteilung von Lebenschancen.
Zum Beispiel bei der Verteilung von Lebenschancen. Und das bedeutet, dass man dann eigentlich einen Tribalismus betreibt, der sonst von rechts betrieben wurde. Und der ist dann auf der linken Seite da. Und das ist ja etwas, was in seinem Universalismus-Buch Omri Böhm sehr ausführlich dechiffriert hat, was es eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man wirklich an die Gleichheit der Menschen glaubt, dann kann man nämlich auch nicht mit einer solchen Identitätspolitik vorangehen. Und das ist natürlich auch überall zu erleben, wie unter dem Deckmantel der Identitätspolitik man jetzt zum Beispiel sehr gut im Fernsehen Karriere machen kann, wenn man da nur bereit ist, seine Identität herauszustellen und das entsprechend sich da zu exponieren. Und dazu zu sagen, man muss also diese beiden Formen der Reduktion des Menschen auf Einzelidentitäten bekämpfen, da hat er sehr recht. Denn nur so kommt man eigentlich zu einer universellen Gleichheit des Menschen, denn die ist Voraussetzung dafür, dass man friedlich zusammenlebt. Denn du hast das jetzt gerade mit so einem Krieg gegen die Alten angedeutet, damit könnte man es machen. Oder man könnte ja auch dann sagen, jetzt sind mal die anderen dran. Also man kann ja aus der kolonialistischen Aufarbeitung den Schluss ziehen, ja, jahrhundertelang haben die Weißen Schandtaten verübt, jetzt unterdrücken wir die Weißen. Das wäre ja auch nichts, was wünschenswert wäre. Das heißt, man muss also auf einen Nenner kommen, wo es also um die absolute Gleichheit der Menschen geht. Und das bedeutet, dass man sich dieser identitätspolitischen Ideologien entledigt und nur Identitätspolitik da zulässt. Und vielleicht trennt man sich dann auch von diesem Begriff, wo man sagt, es muss hier erstmal eine Emanzipation stattfinden, die auf eine Gleichheit hinausführt, aber nicht auf eine neue Sortierung, das jetzt nun eben andere privilegiert sind. Sondern jetzt müssen die Privilegien grundsätzlich abgeschafft werden.
Und hier wird jetzt geopolitisch interessant, denn unsere Identität ist natürlich daran geknüpft, dass wir marktwirtschaftlich und demokratisch sind und die ganze Welt da mit infizieren wollen, weil wir ja überzeugt davon sind, dass das der einzig richtige Weg ist. Jetzt sagen aber die Chinesen, naja, so ein bisschen haben wir auch so ein Ende der Geschichte-Moment wie Fukuyama, also der noch mal den Deckel drauf machte mit jetzt hat genau diese Verknüpfung aus Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft gewonnen. Und er kommt ja dann auch immer wieder darauf zu sprechen, Precht. Also schon vor diesem Buch immer wieder, wenn jemand die Menschen mit den Millennial-Goals aus der Armut geholt hat, dann ist das zu 90 Prozent ein Fortschritt, der in China stattfand. Also diese Verknüpfung aus uns geht es jetzt besser, wir sind fast so neo-Kaiwanistisch, wir sind die Guten, weil es uns gut geht, die verknüpfen es nicht mit Demokratie. Die haben also genau die gleichen Argumente wie wir. Wir argumentieren moralisch, die argumentieren genauso moralisch, die stehen auf der Weltbühne und sagen, also wir haben noch nie ein Land überfallen, anders als der Westen und so. Wir haben nicht überall Flugzeugträger, wir unterjochen hier niemanden, wir haben keine Kolonialgeschichte, wir sind einfach China. Und Precht sagt dann, die Moral arbeitet hier nicht versöhnlich, sondern sie ist nun ein Munitionslager, um die Abgrenzung und Spaltung zu vergrößern. Und da muss man sagen, ja das stimmt. Und das ist eins dieser ganz großen Dramen, die uns im Alltag und in der Geopolitik gleichermaßen überall, wir haben hier wirklich falsche Denkschablonen, dominierende Denkschablonen, die wir einfach hier nicht mobilisiert kriegen. China kriegen wir auf dieser Ebene nicht eingefangen, weil sie uns exakt dasselbe Argument zurückgeben.
Das ist das eine. Dazu kommt, wie du angesprochen hast, der wirtschaftliche Erfolg. Und jetzt kommen wir noch dazu, dass es nicht dabei bleibt. Precht schreibt, verstörend für die politischen und wirtschaftlichen Hegemonialmächte von einst, also damit meint er die westlichen Länder, fordert die Mehrheit der Menschen auf dem Globus nicht nur ihr Recht auf die auf der Erdkugel verfügbaren Ressourcen des Wohlstands, sondern immer stärker auch ihre Beteiligung an weltpolitischen Entscheidungen. Und wir haben jetzt gerade die Debatte über den internationalen Strafgerichtshof, über die UN, dass plötzlich ganz viele westliche Vertreter, die das immer hochgehalten haben, jetzt wo andere auch an Einfluss dort gewinnen und das ganze nutzen, sagen, ja also man muss vielleicht auch mal generell nachdenken, ob das überhaupt so gut ist mit der UN und so.
Oder mit der Weltbank oder mit dem Währungsfonds oder und so weiter und so fort.
Also sobald man damit nicht mehr Herrschaft ausüben kann, wie man es immer tat, werden diese Institutionen plötzlich an sich in Frage gestellt.
Genau, wir hatten ja den chinesischen Ministerpräsidenten voriges Jahr, der dann in Davos auf der Bühne steht und einfach dafür wirbt, jetzt sich diesem Club anzuschließen. Während die Europäer gerade so einen Klimaklub gründen, sagt dann Precht, naja, die größten Freihandelszonen haben mit Amerika und Europa nichts zu tun.
Ja.
Europa sind 500 Millionen Leute, Amerika sind 300 Millionen. Nicht mal zusammen sind die die Hälfte von China, so ungefähr. Und wenn China mit irgendwem Freihandels ankommt, dann ist es immer das größte der Welt. Also es ist einfach grundsätzlich, da kommen wir jetzt in die Hinterhand.
Das heißt also, wir haben ein moralisches Dilemma, wenn uns die eigene Moral zurückgespiegelt wird und wir ratlos davorstehen, wie wir damit umgehen. Man kann also sagen, die hochmoralische Rhetorik greift dann nicht mehr. Beziehungsweise, was ist dann also die Kritik? Und hier würde ich sagen, muss man noch mal vielleicht ein bisschen das sortieren, auf welchen Ebenen wir jetzt hier Kritik sehen, die die Precht artikuliert. Und zwar gibt es einmal die moralisch aufgeladene Rhetorik und das verpufft relativ schnell. Dann gibt es aber ja noch diese andere Ebene, dass also Nationen sich gegenüberstehen im Konflikt, wo Precht dann sagt, angesichts des Klimawandels können wir uns solche Konflikte gar nicht leisten. Wir können gar nicht jetzt anfangen, aufzurüsten immer mehr, sondern wir müssten uns mehr als eine Menschheit begreifen. Und hier sind ja zwei verschiedene Dinge. Die interessengeleiteten Leute wie Mörscheimer würden sagen, ja, das ist ja auch immer nur Bemäntelung. Ich glaube, Mörscheimer spricht immer so von einem liberalen Deckmantel, den man sich anzieht. Aber eigentlich muss man Realist sein und braucht auch diesen Deckmantel nicht. Aber für Precht ist es ja jetzt so, dass dieser rhetorische Deckmantel erst mal abgestreift werden muss. Aber darunter zeigt sich dann nicht einfach nur der harte Realist, sondern wie kommt man jetzt nicht zu einem Deckmantel, sondern zu einem wirklichen Kleid, um jetzt im Bild zu bleiben, aus Werten. Nämlich Werte wie das universelle Menschenrecht der Gleichheit sind ja keine Werte, die man wieder loswerden möchte, sondern die sind ja gültig und zwar überall, wenn gleich sie in so vielen Ländern gar nicht gelebt werden. In Klammern auch der Westen arbeitet da fortwährend mit Doppelstandards. Siehe und er formuliert es ja dann genauso auch den völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg auf den Irak seitens der USA. Also er zeigt natürlich dann damit, dass die Außenperspektive nämlich genau die ist. Also man kann jetzt sagen, oh, das ist aber Relativismus und sonst was. Die Außenperspektive der meisten Länder auf den Westen ist genau das, dass sie sagen, ja Angriffskrieg, völkerrechtswidrig, moment mal, da war doch was.
Mit einer Million Toten im Irak. Also diesen Widerstreit der Nationen, es ist ja ganz interessant. Er markiert also bis hierhin dieses große Thema Klimawandel auf der einen Seite, die Herausforderung, die wir nicht gelöst kriegen mit alten Denkschablonen, wenn wir so im nationalen Kontext und so weiter. Und das ist ja ein interessanter Widerspruch, der auch soziologisch viel größer ist, als man immer glaubt, allein durch diese Beobachtung, dass das Wirtschaftssystem ist, in dem wir uns jetzt geeinigt haben, dass wir das Klima schützen. Also wir brauchen technische Innovation und das E-Auto und das Stahlwerk ohne Kohle und so weiter. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir politische Systeme, die das angeblich steuern. Da könnte man ja auch sagen, ne, das macht der Markt schon alleine. Der Markt in Verknüpfung mit der Wissenschaft sorgt schon dafür, dass die Amerikaner und die Chinesen so ungefähr die gleiche Batterietechnik benutzen, auch wenn ansonsten die Politiker kurz vorm Krieg miteinander sind. Und jetzt macht er diese Beobachtung in diesem Kapitel, warum Gesellschaften scheitern, dass Barbara Tuchmann 1984 schon die richtige Frage stellte, nachdem sie sich an die Politik von Troja bis Vietnam anschaute, warum gibt es auf allen Ebenen einen Fortschritt außer einer Politik? Da müssen wir eigentlich Rückschritte verhindern. Also sozialer Fortschritt, also Fortschritt ist, technischer Fortschritt gibt es nur in eine Richtung. Niemand nimmt eine gute Lösung für ein ernsthaftes Problem und sagt, mache ich nicht mehr, sortiere ich aus, sondern in Verknüpfung mit der Wirtschaft, es ist ja gewinnenversprechend. So, also der technische Fortschritt geht immer in die eine Richtung, der politische Fortschritt, der soziale Fortschritt, nee, das wird alles abgewickelt. Uns droht es, die Demokratie verloren zu gehen. Wir haben ernsthafte Fragen mit dem Sozialstaat. Und sie stellt diese Frage, warum entwickelt sich alles nach vorne außer die Politik? Ja, das finde ich mal sehr gut in den Raum gestellt, denn es ist ja ernsthaft die Frage, können wir Politik überwinden? Und mit Politik meine ich jetzt Demokratie im Sinne von, in Amerika wählen sie alle vier Jahre einen amerikanischen Präsidenten, stellen jetzt aber fest, sie sind die ganze Zeit im Wahlkampf, alles wird im Wahlkampf untergeordnet, auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite. Naja, aber die Politik registriert das ja auch die ganze Zeit und handelt so. Also sie braucht keine Wahl, um dann zu sagen, du hast jetzt die Macht, mach was du willst, sondern nein, das Kanzleramt, das Weiße Haus, die machen eine demoskopische Erhebung, die wollen wissen, in welche Richtung geht denn das Land. Und wenn sich eine Mehrheit herausbildet, dann muss sie nicht erst zur Wahl ohne gehen. Man orientiert die Politik einfach daran. Also wozu eigentlich ein Wahltermin ist, ist so die Frage. Steht ja auch noch im Raum. Die stellt sich natürlich jetzt mit dieser neuen Art der Überwachung, das ist ja am Arbeitsplatz. Das gilt natürlich auch in der Politik für die Wähler. Diese neue Beobachtung von Wählern. Dass Politiker ihre Wähler viel besser kennen, als die Wähler die Politiker. Das war ja mal ganz anders. Früher traf man sich auf dem Marktplatz, da hieß es, Sarah Wagenknecht kommt. Alle wussten, wer Sarah Wagenknecht ist. Und Sarah Wagenknecht so, wer seid ihr eigentlich? So, das ist ja heute genau umgedreht. Man kennt die Politiker nicht. Da sitzen irgendwelche ständigen Vertreter Deutschlands in der Europäischen Kommission und schreiben Beschlussvorlagen für die Ministerräte. Die kennen uns aber alle. Wir sind in 1000 Registern drin und da wird genau nachgeforscht. Also da gibt es so grundlegende Fragen, warum Demokratie eigentlich noch alle vier Jahre geht man an die Wahlurner, wo man es ja auch detailliert steuern kann, wenn es darum geht, eine Mehrheit abzufragen. Da braucht man keinen Wahltermin für.
Tuchmann fragt ja, warum agieren die Inhaber hoher Ämter so oft in einer Weise, die der Vernunft und dem aufgeklärten Eigeninteresse zuwiderläuft? Warum bleiben Einsicht und Verstand so häufig wirkungslos? Fragen, die wir uns in diesem Podcast ohne Hürde stellen. Nur die Sache ist, wenn wir es jetzt auf der nationalstaatlichen Ebene betrachten, muss man ja erkennen, dass es etwas anderes ist als jetzt zum Beispiel der Umgang zwischen uns. Also nehmen wir mal an, wir gehen jetzt so miteinander um in der Hoffnung, dass wir von uns geleitet diesen Podcast machen können und miteinander auskommen. Wenn aber jetzt wir uns hineinversetzen in Staaten, also du bist China, ich bin Amerika, dann müssen wir nach einer anderen Logik funktionieren. Dann ist quasi Existenzbedingungen für mich, dass ich in einer Rivalität zu dir stehe und du mich nicht übertrumpfen kannst. Es sollte eigentlich so ein dauerndes Armdrücken sein, bei dem aber nicht einer plötzlich verliert. Und dies aber entfacht ein ganz anderes Handeln, das dann oft zwei Interesse geleitet ist im Sinne von ich muss meine nationalstaatliche Integrität stärken, aber das unvernünftig ist mit Blick auf eine Perspektive wie was bedeutet das eigentlich für die Menschen im Land oder für die Menschen auf der Welt. Und diese Sache ist vielleicht eine, die sehr, also ich habe sehr viel darüber nachgedacht, weil er ja am Anfang sagte, es ist ein philosophisches Buch und es ist ein philosophisches Buch. Aber ich habe mich gefragt, inwieweit es Grenzen gibt, ein philosophisches Buch über Geopolitik zu schreiben oder auch ein, ich will es mal anders machen. Es gibt ein Zitat von Peter Hux, dem DDR-Schriftsteller, der sagt, die Außenpolitik ist an der Politik das Geistlose. Klingt erst mal, die Außenpolitik ist an der Politik das Geistlose. Und dann erklärt er, dass wenn wir uns mit der Politik innerhalb eines Staats beschäftigen, dann haben wir Arbeitskämpfe, dann gibt es da Reformen. Da gibt es also Spielräume, Möglichkeiten, da kann man überlegen, wie ging es denn besser. Er sagt dann aber, es gibt keine Staatengemeinschaft, also das, was auch Mörschheimer im Prinzip sagen würde. Und Schlussfolger, für eine bessere Gesellschaft geht es zu kämpfen. Können wir sagen, mehr Mindestlohn. Nicht für eine bessere Welt. Weil wir dann diese Konstellation haben, dass die Staaten sich gegenüberstehen, sich kritisch beäugen, gewinnen wollen. Das heißt, wir nehmen jetzt mit Precht, nur um das deutlich zu machen, es ist wirklich kein Vorwurf an Precht, sondern er soll damit die fatale Situation skizziert werden. Wir nehmen mit Precht jetzt die Perspektive von Menschen an, die eigentlich jetzt gerne über die Welt so nachdenken würden wie über ihren Staat. In Wahrheit ist es aber so, dass diese Staaten sich gegenüberstehen und aufgrund dieser Konstellation dazu verleitet werden, dumm zu agieren, schlecht zu agieren für uns. Und das führt uns jetzt zu der Frage, wie kann man dann diese Konstellation durchbrechen? Und was Precht ja will, ist dieses Jahrhundert der Toleranz. Er ist nicht für eine Abschaffung des Nationalstaats oder so, aber was er ja möchte, ist, dass also die internationalen Institutionen so sehr gestärkt sind, dass die particularen nationalen Interesse nicht mehr diese Macht ausüben können, was dann auch vor allem bedeutet, dass zum Beispiel Europa und USA von ihren Veto-Rechten, die sie haben, nicht mehr Gebrauch machen können, dass man also da ein neues Setting schafft. Und da würde ich sagen, das stimmt und das wäre auch wünschenswert. Nur frage ich mich, ist das realistisch? Oder müsste man jetzt sagen, ja, das ist eine tolle Idee, aber die Verhältnisse, wie sie sind, sind so geistlos, wie das Hux diagnostiziert hat?
Das ist ja dieser Themenbereich, wo besonders viele Wünsche entstehen. Können wir nicht einfach den Nationalstaat überwinden, den Kapitalismus abschaffen, den NATO auflösen, alle in so einer Friede vor der Erdkuchenwelt leben? Die strukturellen Realisten blenden das einfach aus. Ich würde jetzt soziologisch sagen, naja, es ist doch interessant, dass wir die ganze Zeit über die Nationalstaaten jammern, gleichzeitig aber darüber vergessen oder eben davon abgelenkt werden, dass ja nur, weil es Nationalstaaten gibt, die so arbeiten, wie sie arbeiten, die Möglichkeit für Unternehmen besteht, sehr erfolgreich für uns alle zu sein. Ja, vielleicht ist das einfach der Preis. Wenn wir unser menschliches Unvermögen, unseren Egoismus in irgendwelche Bahnen zu denken, organisieren müssen. Unternehmen, hunderttausende Mitarbeiter, aber dafür 300 kmh schnelle Mobilität zwischen Köln und Frankfurt, weil dafür braucht man eine Deutsche Bahn. Ohne Deutsche Bahn ist das nicht zu erreichen. Also organisieren wir es auf dieser Ebene. Das ist ein unglaublicher Gewinn für uns alle, auch wenn die Tickets manchmal ein bisschen teuer sind. Und dafür nehmen wir einfach in Kauf, dass oben drüber als Wächter ein Nationalstaat ist, mit dem wir uns die ganze Zeit rumquälen. Quälen wir uns doch mit dem Nationalstaat um, jammern wir doch über Olaf Scholz dafür, dass wir mit 300 kmh nach Köln fahren können. Wir könnten jetzt strukturell, realistisch den Nationalstaat da einfach ausblenden und sagen, er ist halt so. Was wollen wir jetzt darüber reden? Es geht doch jetzt um konkrete Probleme, pragmatische. Wir reden doch nicht von drei Ländern und dann fragen wir die Länder, sondern wir sehen doch ganz genau Joe Biden, Xi und dann Modi oder so. Und dann dieses Bild vom Kindergarten. Sollten wir nicht einfach in die Richtung pragmatisch denken. Und da würde ich sagen, was wir vorhin schon gesagt haben, wenn man jetzt ernsthaft über den Nationalstaat reden möchte, dann begeben wir uns nicht auf die Suche nach irgendwelchen Protagonisten, die angeblich irgendwas falsch machen, weil sie die falschen Intentionen haben, sondern nee, dann brauchen wir jetzt eine echte Forensik, die hier latente Sinnstrukturen, Derivationen und was auch immer untersucht. Was noch lange nicht heißt, dass wir, wenn wir ein bisschen besser verstehen, wie der Nationalstaat funktioniert, so gleich eine bessere Alternative hätten. Genau. Eine der großen Sachen beim Kapitalismus abschaffen. Ja klar, der Kapitalismus ist unangenehm für dich, deswegen willst du ihn abschaffen und dann? Keine Ahnung. Antwort jemals darauf gehabt. Wir haben das nachher auch wieder in diesem Buch zur Sprache des Kapitalismus. Jaja, man kann schon darüber reden, den Kapitalismus abzuschaffen, aber warum?
Die Frage ist nur, wenn wir es dann pragmatisch sehen, und das wäre ja dein Vorschlag und dem kann ich ja sehr viel abgewinnen, wie organisiert man es dann, dass nicht solche Kriege entstehen, dass wir nicht in so eine Aufrüstungsspirale kommen. Precht sagt, wir merken gerade, dass unsere kulturelle Hegemonie flöten geht, also damit unsere Ideologien nicht in aller Welt freudig aufgenommen werden. Und er sagt dann, wenn die Geschichte schon nicht auf unserer Seite ist, dann hilft nur militärische Überlegenheit. Das scheint gerade die Überlegung zu sein. Und wie steuern wir dem entgegen? Eine Möglichkeit wäre also, die internationalen Institutionen zu stärken, was aber bedeutet, dass die Nationalstaaten sich an ein paar entscheidenden Stellen zurücknehmen. Das betrifft dann nicht das Deutsche Bahnnetz, betrifft aber dann gewisse Veto-Rechte, die man nicht mehr hat, die man mal hatte, weil man mal unipolare westliche Weltordnung hatte. Davon muss man Abstand nehmen. Und dann wäre noch eine andere Frage, die jetzt von Precht nicht aufgegriffen wird. Deswegen vertagen wir das mal, inwieweit man also noch mal sagen könnte, das, was du jetzt schon angeteasert hast, dass ja die Konzerne durchaus anders agieren, nämlich die verbauen irgendwie ähnliche Chips, die kooperieren sowieso mit allen zusammen.
Das ist Weltgesellschaft.
Und das ist Weltgesellschaft. Also inwieweit ist eigentlich das, was die ganze Zeit so kritisiert wurde am Neoliberalismus auch was utopisches, dass man sagen kann, alle Menschen hätten gerne eine klimafreundliche Mobilität. Hier sind die Konzerne, die sie ermöglichen, vollkommen egal, ob an der Werkbank ein Chinese oder ein Amerikaner steht, ob der schwul oder heterosexuell ist.
Wenn wir feststellen, dass der Klimawandel, und zwar der Teil, der Menschen verursacht ist, so gigantisch ist, dann müssen wir feststellen, ja, weil wir unsere Menschheit gigantisch organisiert haben, sodass das überhaupt in den Folgen Reichtum kam, weil Tiere, die sich nicht organisieren, schaffen das gar nicht, die ganze Welt anzuzünden. Genauso ist die Feuerwehr, die diesen Brand wieder löscht, genauso groß nur denkbar. Jetzt einfach zu sagen, dann überwinden wir mal die alten Institutionen, schaffen die Organisationen ab und den Nationalstaat gleich mit und auch den Kapitalismus, ja, dann wird gar nichts gerettet. Dann haben wir einfach gar keine Handlungsmöglichkeiten mehr, denn das Problem ist da, es muss jetzt aus der Welt geräumt werden, nehmen wir doch die alten Mittel und dann, und da muss man aber erst eine forensische Analyse machen, wo jetzt genau die Stellschrauben sind, mit Wünschen kommt man da nicht weiter und das ist ja Thema in diesem Buch. Mein Vorschlag ist, dieses Kapitel, warum Gesellschaften scheitern, da stecken ein paar Pointen drin. Warum das jetzt zwingend in dem Buch drinstehen muss, unklar. Er kommt noch mal auf die Ostereinseln zu sprechen, wir kennen das, Brechmann hat es aufgedröselt. Er hat noch zwei weitere Erklärungen, bevor er dann zu eigener anschließt, mit einer kleinen Pointe. Denn entweder scheitern Nationen, wenn sie es nicht schaffen, möglichst viele Menschen Chancen zu geben, ihr Leben zu verwirklichen. Oder, also das wäre die Idee von Daron Ashimoglu und James Robinson, oder das Gegenteil, Staaten scheitern daran, dass sie zu wenig Menschen Möglichkeiten geben. Also entweder zu viel oder zu wenig, das ist ein Paradox, wie er sagt. Scheitern kann man kaum vermeiden in diesem Bild. Er macht einen dritten Punkt von Joseph Tainter, den ich sehr gut finde. Jede Problemlösung, also Staaten finden soziale Probleme vor, sie werden adressiert, sie finden Lösungen, diese Lösungen verursachen die nächsten Probleme. Und irgendwann gerät der Staat an Kapazitätsgrenzen. Das ist ja die große Frage bei China. Wie weit kann man es eigentlich treiben? Wir stellen in Deutschland fest, wenn in Hamburg einmal ein G8-Treffen ist, dann sind da alle deutschen Polizisten. Wenn dann in Stuttgart ein Terroranschlag ist, dann brauchen die fünf Stunden, um da runterzufahren. Also da wäre einfach kein Großaufgebot möglich. Das heißt, die Grenzen des Staates sind ganz schön schnell erreicht. Hochwasser, ob wir jetzt wirklich jedem alles entschädigen können? Wir haben das jetzt im Ahrteil schon versucht. Selbst da bringt es nichts, weil das Geld muss ja auch verbaut werden. Es gibt aber gar keine Handwerker. Und jetzt heilt Bayern auf Bauen. Also das ist ja auch ein hanebüchiges Denken. Also Staaten können sich durchaus überfordern und daran scheitern. Er nennt dann viertens Einmischung von außen. Okay, also irgendwer macht einen Krieg oder sonstiges, übernimmt es ökonomisch, beutet aus. Das ganze Kapitel ist überhaupt nur erklärbar durch sein Fünftes. Staaten scheitern manchmal auch an narrativen Verengungen. Ein Faktor des Scheiterns ist falsche Narrative, wie zum Beispiel das Narrativ von der systemischen Rivalität zwischen dem guten Westen auf der einen Seite und dem bösen China, samt befreundeten Autokraten auf der anderen. Wenn ich jetzt Claude fragen würde, warum steht das Kapitel da drin, würde Claude mir sagen, nur um auf diese Poante hinaus zu laufen.
Möglich, aber dann kommen wir nochmal dazu.
Um zu sagen, an dieser narrativen Verengung können Staaten scheitern. Es ist auf Augenhöhe mit Krieg, ökonomische Ausbeutung, durch Überforderung. Jeder lebt einfach 100 Meter tiefe Grundwasserbrunnen, um seinen Rasen zu besehen. An dem Ende gibt es keinen Grundwasser mehr. Also auf der Augenhöhe sieht er das, würde ich sagen. Das ist die Poante dieses Kapitels. Narrative Verengung ist nicht einfach nur so, ja, ja, es ist blöd, da sollte man mal drüber reden. Das macht ganz schön vielen schlechte Laune, sondern das ist ein echter Grund für nationales Scheitern. Daran zerbrechen lokale Zivilisationen.
Wir werden ja nachher noch über Narrative Verengung mit Blick auf die Demokratie und diesen Begriff sprechen. Aber erstmal ist es ja also dann ein Kapitel, das vorbereitet, dass es also in engeren Sinne und auch im weiteren Sinne um Ideologiekritik gehen muss. Und er spricht dann von Derivationen. Und zwar sagt er, Derivate sind ausgeklügelte Ordnungssysteme, in denen Moral und Recht kodifiziert sind. Derivationen hingegen sind das, was Karl Marx als Ideologiebrand mag, der einseitige und verallgemeinernde Erzählung über das, was eine Nation, ein Volk, ein einander Glaube, eine Rasse, eine Klasse usw. sein sollen. Sie sollen etwas bilden, das sich, wie Krude auch immer, in Übereinstimmung mit Gefühlen befindet und damit nicht logische Beweisführungen liefern, die Autorität schaffen. Also Putin könnte morgen vor Berlin stehen, deswegen brauchen wir eine Wehrpflicht.
Er kannt ja schon mal vor Berlin.
Richtig. Gefühle sind da, Bedrohungsszenario, Glaube, alles ist da, wir die anderen. Und damit hat man also etwas produziert, das brandgefährlich ist, weil man genau diese Ideologie benötigt oder diese Derivationen benötigt, um auch etwas politisch in Gang zu setzen. Er schreibt dann noch, wie die Residuen, Individuen und Gemeinschaften zu irrationalem Handel treiben, so tun es die Derivationen mit den Gesellschaften und Staaten in der modernen. Eine Glanzschicht der Logik legt sich über dunkle Welterklärungen und macht stringent, was nirgendwo stringent ist. Und genauso entstehen starke politische Überzeugungen und irrationale Weltanschauungen. Und wir haben hier dieses Beispiel schon oft gebracht, und wir wollen es an dieser Stelle nochmal überstrapazieren. Zero Covid, Zero Putin, dass man sagt, es ist doch ganz logisch, es muss weg, das Virus muss weg, Putin muss weg.
Können nicht mit dem Virus leben.
Nein.
Oder mit Putin.
Und damit ist aber, hat man so eine Stringenz hergestellt, wo eigentlich keine Stringenz ist.
Ja, ich finde, begrifflich macht er das sehr schön an einzelnen Sätzen. Und wir dürfen jetzt nicht wieder vergessen, dass er das auf Augenhöhe mit, also diese Probleme, die wir jetzt hier beschreiben, die so, wie soll man sagen, etwas soft daherkommen, aber die sind auf Augenhöhe mit Krieg, ökonomischer Ausbeutung, zivilisatorischem Schaden, Zivilisationsbrüchen und so weiter. Wir haben es mit nichtlogischen Verhaltensmustern aus archaischen Gesellschaften zu tun, die noch bleiben. Er nennt sie Affekt, Wunsch, Sehnsucht, Angst, Wahn. Ja, ein sehr schönes Fünftgespann. Und ich hätte jetzt noch diese Pointe reingeschrieben, wenn ich das redigiert hätte. Bei Derivaten und Derivationen denkt niemand an irgendeinen marxistischen ideologienahen Grundbegriff. Sondern diesen Begriff kennen wir noch von 2008, als es eine ganz große Aufklärung gab, warum ist Lehman jetzt pleite gegangen? Und dann sagt man, die hatten so einen Finanzkonstrukt, einen Versicherungsbetrag für Aktien. Ach nee, ich meine nicht Aktien, sondern Aktienmoleküle, also irgendwelche Sachen, die zusammengebunden wurden aus verschiedenen Sachen, die man nicht mal durchschaut hat. Also da fanden so Verbriefungswege statt. Man hat nicht einfach nur Rohstoff oder Anleihen, sondern man hat die so miteinander verklüngelt und so rezeptmäßig zusammengebrüht.
Man hat es eigentlich mit einem Geschenkpapier versehen, so dass es immer noch so wirkte, als müsste das ein AAA-Rating bekommen, was da eigentlich schon als Schrott bewertet hätten werden müssen.
Und der Grundbegriff für diesen Schrott war Derivate, Derivatehandel. Also wir haben einen ökonomischen, echten Bruch in der Entwicklung gehabt mit allen Folgen, die wir bis heute haben, bis zum Wohnungskrieg da stattfindet, weil das mit diesen Derivaten nicht funktioniert hat. Und so wie man in der Finanzwirtschaft so verbriefungs-, man rührt einfach irgendwas zusammen und gibt dem ein Label, so ist das hier auch. Man hat irgendwo so eine Approximation an die Wirklichkeit. Also wir hatten doch mal Überinflation und dann ging es ganz schlecht. Und dann war so ein Krieg und dann stand der Russe vor Berlin. Und hat dann eine Fahne gehisst. Der Amerikaner hat dann eine Fahne gehisst, auf dem Reichstag und der Russe hat ganz Ostdeutschland erobert. Und das Derivat davon ist, also Putin ist nicht zu trauen. Das ist genauso eine kognitive Verbriefung, die auch einfach aufgeblasen ist und ins Nichts zergehen kann. Wie ich ja schon sagte, wenn Trump die Wahl gewinnt und am ersten Tag einen Friedensvertrag mit Putin macht, ist das alles Geschichte. Also ist das ganze Derivat Putin der Böse und so weiter? Nein, der globale Süden atmet dann auf, weil jetzt wieder Perspektive ist. Amerika hat einen Präsidenten, der ein Friedenspräsident ist. Er hat Kriege beendet. Das ist das, was die Republikaner wollen, die Wähler. So, und die Europäer stehen dann da und denken, oh Gott, unser Derivat ist nichts wert.
Und deshalb erleben wir ja auch dann das, was er beschreibt. Also neben so Holzschnittartigen Feindbildungen, sagt er, gibt es die Nullpunktsetzung. Und das ist ganz wichtig. Wir hatten das jetzt auch, weil man es nochmal so schön mit diesen beiden schrecklichen Krisen verbinden kann, nämlich Krieg und Corona, dass jetzt gesagt wurde, ja, also Aufarbeitung wäre schon gut, aber ist jetzt auch, wir sind da, wir haben ja gar nicht die Gelegenheit bekommen, hat dann Alena Büchse gesagt, man hat uns die Gelegenheit genommen, dann war schon der Krieg. Also wir machen jetzt einfach wieder bei Null weiter.
Ja, also nicht nur das, Nullpunktsetzung meinte er ja auch, am 22. Februar hat Putin die Ukraine angegriffen. Das ist der Nullpunkt, die Vorgeschichte zählt nicht. Wenn irgendwer kommt und sagt, Putin hat sich bedroht gefühlt, da gibt es Sicherheitsinteressen, nein, der Nullpunkt ist der 22. Februar. 7. Oktober, am 7. Oktober explodierte der Nahe Osten wegen der Hamas. Ja, das fand in einem Vakuum statt. Wer behauptet, das fand nicht in einem Vakuum statt, und sei es der UN-Generalsekretär Guterres, ist ein Antisemit. Also diese harten, deklaratorischen, die Diskussion steuernden archimädischen Nullpunktsetzungen sind gefährlich.
Er schreibt, der österreichische Philosoph Paul Watzlawick bemerkte dazu treffend, dass in Konflikten sich jeder stets nur als Reagierender, nie als Agierender sieht. Die Kette der Ereignisse wird so zerlegt, dass immer der andere angefangen hat und ich nur mit Recht darauf antworte. Tatsächlich aber ist die Schuldfrage nur selten leicht und in gewünschter Eindeutigkeit zu beantworten. Die Einseitigkeit der Darstellung beginnt schon bei der Rekonstruktion der Ereignisse. Jeder wird das aus Freundschaften, Beziehungen oder kleineren Streits kennen. Wer hat denn eigentlich angefangen? Und dann gibt es immer jemanden, der sich an noch was Längeres erinnert. Das ist immer für mich sehr gut, weil ich ja ein Gedächtnis habe, das sehr, sehr verlässlich ist und ich weiß in der Regel immer noch mal, was drei Jahre davor geschehen ist.
Für dich gibt es keinen Nullpunkt.
Es gibt keinen Nullpunkt, das ist für die anderen schwierig.
Das ist diese kleine giftige, in allen Diskussionen, immer so eine Portion Poison dabei.
Dass man noch mal sagen kann, ja, 1999 war das aber noch so und so. Naja, aber diese Nullpunktsetzung wird die ganze Zeit vorgenommen. Und man fragt sich ja auch, welche Irrlogik wir dann da die ganze Zeit erleben mit diesem Nullpunkt. Also man kann, und man sollte auch gewisse Ereignisse niemals ausblenden, wie zum Beispiel den 7. Oktober. Aber ich kann ja jetzt nicht alles Regierungshandeln von Netanyahu immer nur als schlichte Antwort auf den 7. Oktober lesen. Dann frage ich mich, wann hört man dann einmal auf, darauf zu antworten? Wird man irgendwann noch mal einen neuen Nullpunkt setzen können? Oder, nee, wir sollten eigentlich mal ganz von diesen Nullpunkten wegkommen, sondern eher diese Dynamik in den Ereignissen sehen. Und das Reagieren auch bedeutet, dass man häufig auch agiert.
Ja, und was bei dieser Nullpunkt- Setzungsargumentation vielleicht noch mal hätte deutlicher, dass wir diesen Grundbegriff gar nicht hatten, der Nullpunkt. Also er macht das jetzt hier, er nennt das Nullpunkt-Setzung. Weil wir haben eigentlich einen Grundbegriff, den wir aber vermeiden, um uns in die Irre zu führen, um die Lüge aufzubauen. Es gäbe einen Nullpunkt. Weil eigentlich sprechen wir im extremsten Maße von einer historischen Zäsur. Und die Zäsur ist immer ein Wandel. Da gibt es einen Zustand davor, die etwas gewandelt hat. Also irgendwas brach auf und die Zäsur lädt geradezu ein, Forensystem nachzugehen. Was führte zu dieser Zäsur? Warum brach es auf? Und der Nullpunkt wendet sich genau dagegen, dieser Zäsur nochmal nachzugehen.
Und das verbindet ja ganz viele verrückte Lager. Also das ist ja ganz interessant, dass wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Baerbock auf der Bühne angesprochen wird, wie jetzt die Haltung Deutschlands ist mit Waffenlieferungen für Israel, dann antwortet sie ja nicht direkt auf die Frage, sondern sie geht erst zum siebten Oktober zurück und schildert nochmal einige Details von damals, eine Vergewaltigung oder so etwas. Und wir sehen zum Beispiel bei Greta Thunberg, bevor jetzt der Ostkonflikt so aufflammte, hat sie sich ja häufig auch zum Krieg in der Ukraine geäußert und verband das dann immer mit der Formulierung Putins unprovozierter Angriffskrieg. Also um noch mal deutlich zu machen, auch hier gibt es einen Nullpunkt. Es gab nie irgendwas davor. Es ist dann geschehen und es gab nie irgendeine Bewegung davor, wo man sagen kann, naja, vielleicht war diese NATO-Entscheidung doch die falsche. Und um das nochmal hier deutlich zu machen, nicht, dass uns hier Leute falsch verstehen, es gibt keinen Anlass, der einen Krieg rechtfertigt, einen Terroranschlag rechtfertigt oder sonst was. Wir müssen das hier deutlich unterstreichen. Nur kann man nicht dann, wenn man sich wirklich Gedanken macht über die Konstellation darüber hinweggehen, dass es auch eine Geschichte für alles gibt. Und eine Geschichte meint nicht Rechtfertigung, sondern eine Geschichte meint, also eine historische Perspektive einzunehmen, meint, ein Gesamtbild entstehen zu lassen, was mit einer Nullpunktsetzung schlichtweg unmöglich ist. Es ist nicht die Rechtfertigung dafür. Und das ist natürlich auch ein gewisses Problem, dass jetzt gerade, kann man das mit Putin sehr gut sehen, dass es natürlich irgendwelche Putin-Anhänger gibt, die jetzt nur so tun, dass die drehen es einfach um. Die setzen den Nullpunkt woanders und sagen 1997 hat die NATO und deshalb.
Oder wie Putin selbst im Jahr 713.
Oder geht noch weiter zurück. Und Ähnliches finden wir natürlich auch bei manchen, nicht bei allen, aber bei manchen palästinensischen Aktivisten, dass die sagen, ja, das ist unser Nullpunkt als Israel, die es uns gemacht hat.
An dieser Stelle will ich aber markieren, ich bin ein bisschen unzufrieden mit diesem Begriff Nullpunktsetzung. Ich bin auch unzufrieden immer noch mit diesem Begriff Cursor.
Ja.
Aus dem letzten Buch, den du ja so toll fandest. Aber die Nullpunktsetzung braucht so wie Zäsur. Das braucht so eine eigene Buchstabenfolge, die man nicht so aus Verlegenheit gewinnt, sondern da ist ein Grundbegriff von Nöten. Und ja, so wie du schon sagtest, man muss nicht jeden Widerspruch immer ernst nehmen. Aber wenn der UN-Generalsekretär, die Afrikanische Union oder wer auch immer als Akteur auftritt und sagt, wir haben hier einen anderen Fokus, dann muss man das einfach einpreisen und ernst nehmen und sich darüber verständigen und kann es dann nicht mit einer eigenen Nullpunktsetzung wegbügeln. Er schreibt danach, das finde ich wirklich witzig auch, Geschichtsschreibung. Also wenn wir schon den Nullpunkt nicht durchgesetzt kriegen, brauchen wir zumindest eine Vorgeschichte, die in unserem Sinne uns erklärt, warum wir die einzig wahren Guten und so weiter sind. Geschichtsschreibung ist Re-Enactment. Das ist richtig gut. Es ist die Vergegenwärtigung und man spielt es noch mal nach. Bei uns in Jena gab es ja 1806 den großen Kampf mit Napoleon und das sind ja solche Ereignisse wie auch in Amerika diese ganzen Civil War Auseinandersetzungen, wo auf einzelnen Feldern das noch mal nachgespielt wird. So und genau so ist das zu denken. Wenn in Steinmeiers Sonntagsreden Bilder aufgespannt werden, hat das mit der Geschichte nichts zu tun. Es ist Vergegenwärtigung über Reenactment. Man spielt es noch mal durch, aber man spielt sein eigenes Ding einfach durch. So wie man es sehen will. Da gibt es einen Dramaturgen, da gibt es einen Regisseur, da gibt es einen Kostümbildner, da kümmert sich jemand ums Licht. Einen Historiker gibt es da nicht. Also Geschichtsschreibung als Reenactment ist sehr gut. Und hier ist auch die historische Expertise in Universitäten findet in der öffentlichen Diskussion nirgendwo ihren Platz. Also mir fällt kein Beispiel ein, wo öffentlich über historische Sachen diskutiert wird, die irgendwas mit dem, was Historiker machen, zu tun haben. Es gibt vielleicht so einzelne Versuche von Unternehmen, die es heute schon nicht mehr gibt, bei denen aber die sozusagen ökonomisch Hinterbliebenen noch mal anstrengen, die Rolle des Unternehmens im Holocaust zu hinterfragen. Aber solange Bahlsen noch Kekse verkauft, kann das allenfalls, weil es der Zeitgeist verlangt, auf Seite 170 mal kurz thematisiert werden in der Chronik des Unternehmens.
Wir sind uns auch wohl bewusst, das sei Vergangenheit, bla bla bla.
Aber das wird dann so krass in die gegenwärtigen Aufregungen eingebettet. Das hat einfach mit Geschichte nichts zu tun. Also das fand ich sehr gut. Und wenn das jetzt Reenactment ist, also ein Spiel, was bedeutet es, wenn wir trotzdem so viel über Geschichtskram reden und sei es nur die Geschichte von gestern? Also wir gucken Nachrichten darüber, was gestern passiert ist. Und jetzt haben wir es viel mit Kriegen zu tun. Er sagt hier in diesem Kapitel dann, cognitive warfare, also geistige Kriegsführung, die Kriegsführung in den Köpfen der Rezipienten, die zu überzeugen sind, dass der Krieg ein guter Krieg ist, weil sie ansonsten große Leere Vietnam, Krieg wird an Heimatfront verloren, weil es dann nicht geht. Er erklärt uns jetzt, es gibt verschiedene Kriegsschauplätze, Wasser, Land, Luft, Internet, neuerdings Weltraum und das kollektive Bewusstsein. Ja, also so wie ja vorher schon, die narrativen Verengungen auf Augenhöhe mit zivilisatorischen Brüchen und dann Ursachen, holt er hier Kriegsschauplätze, da wo der Krieg wirklich gekämpft wird. Also auch das kollektive Bewusstsein ist hier auf Augenhöhe mit dem Kriegsschauplatz vor Ort. Da würde ich sagen, richtig so, es werden nur sehr wenige akzeptieren, dass es so ist, aber so ist es.
Ja und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum wir zum Beispiel keine toten Soldaten im Fernsehen sehen.
Zum Beispiel.
Wir sehen nicht, was dort eigentlich passiert und das bedeutet, dass ich mir diese Bilder zwar besorgen kann im Internet, aber es heißt, dass ganz viele Menschen, die nicht bei TikTok sind, diese Bilder nicht zu sehen bekommen, die also einer Kriegsführung ausgesetzt sind, einer kognitiven, die dafür sorgt, dass man das eigentliche, was im Krieg passiert, nämlich dass Männer sich gegenseitig erschießen, nicht sichtbar ist und dann ist damit die Einstellung zu dem Krieg und zu Waffenlieferungen eine ganz andere, als wenn man sie sehen würde. Und wir haben ja jetzt mit diesem Begriff kognitive Kriegsführung ein, der von der NATO so verwendet wird.
Was dann eben dazu führt, wenn wir heute über einen neuen Kalten Krieg reden, ist alles daran falsch. Die Idee von einem neuen, also unternehmen wir uns am alten, nein, am Sorten, kalter Krieg, nö, also das ist ein heißer Krieg, der an unseren Köpfen stattfindet.
Ja.
So, also es ist einfach eine sehr schöne Rampe für dann den Umschwung hier im Buch.
Und es ist auch keine systemische Rivalität auf die Wirtschaftssysteme bezogen. Zwar...
Genau...
.fuscht der Staat da immer noch ein bisschen mit in China. Also es ist ein Staatskapitalismus eher, aber wir entwickeln uns auch, zumindest die USA, mehr in diese Richtung. Es stehen sich Kapitalismen gegenüber.
Genau, es sind ökonomische Logiken, die sich gar nicht so sehr unterscheiden. Nur während wir die französische Autoindustrie einfach platt machen, wie Patrick in seinem Buch Kampf der Nation geschrieben hat, ja, wir haben es gelesen, ist das halt bei China immer gleich auch semantisch auf einer anderen Ebene. Denn wir teilen mit denen einfach nicht das gleiche politische Koordinatensystem. Aber ja gut, was solls. Also wir haben es in den Diskussionen, die wir heute führen, um einen neuen kalten Krieg, also systemische Rivalität mit China, hier mit einer Öffentlichkeit zu tun, in deren Köpfen dieser Krieg ausgefochten wird, die sich selber in Identitätskrise und in innenpolitischer Unsicherheit befindet. Das war zum kalten Krieg anders. Da war völlig klar, der Klimawandel kommt jetzt nicht in die Quere. Wir können aufpowern, soweit wir wollen. Wir erobern alles und überwinden am Ende mit unserem System, dass, ich habe letztens so einen interessanten Spruch gehört, ich weiß gar nicht, der ist Publizist, der ist wahrscheinlich schon breitgetreten, aber ich habe ihn zuerst gehört, das erste Mal gehört, da hieß es, mit dem Mauerfall hat das richtige System verloren.
Ja, das steht ja auch im Buch.
Ah, das ist aus dem Buch, genau. Ich habe es irgendwo auch, ich habe es, ich habe es so als künstliche Erinnerung.
Das richtige System hat verloren und das falsche hat, aber das falsche hat gewonnen. Genau. Also das ist Jean Le Carre.
Ah ja, das finde ich sehr gut, das ist wirklich sehr gut, weil diese Wertung, das richtige und das falsche, dieser zweite Teil dieses Spruchs, der ist halt so wichtig. Es gibt auch einen Gewinner, aber war es die richtige Seite? Und so ist das hier auch wieder. Wir sind uns selber gerade unsicher. Und das Buch kommt ja aus dieser Leute-Fühlen, dass es nicht richtig ist, also buchstäbe ich es mal aus. Diese Unsicherheit, also dieses Buch wird hier sehr reflexiv. Es findet in dieser Gesellschaft statt, die es beschreibt, also das kann man hier richtig fühlen.
Die Feinde aus westlicher Sicht sind nicht weniger geworden dadurch, dass sie nun fast allesamt Kapitalisten sind, sondern mehr. Denn die Sache war ja, als man diese kommunistischen Staaten hatte, musste man zwar aufpassen, dass die nicht jetzt sich in Westdeutschland ausbreiten und dort plötzlich die Leute auch Lust haben auf den Kommunismus. Das war ja die große Sorge immer von Kissinger, als zum Beispiel Brandt in Berlin war. Na, nicht, dass der doch noch den Sozialismus jetzt den Westdeutschen bringt. Solche Fantasien hatte er ja da und da ist man ja dann auch immer eingeschritten, wenn sich irgendwo was Linkes bildet. Man hatte auch linke Bewegungen in Italien zum Beispiel bekämpft und hat dann gesagt, dann nehmen wir lieber den Faschismus, bevor Linke sich durchsetzen. Dies ist ja heute nicht mehr der Fall, sondern was ist eigentlich mit diesem Satz da gemeint? Nun, wenn alle kapitalistisch agieren, dann wirtschaften sie auch viel erfolgreicher, als das die kommunistischen oder vermeintlich kommunistischen Länder getan haben. Das heißt, die Konkurrenz ist besonders groß und diese Konkurrenz schürt Feindschaft, die dann notfalls auch militärisch ausgetragen werden muss.
Genau und da kann man richtig dieses Bild zusammenbauen. Er schreibt es ja auch vorher im Buch schon. Die Kränkung liegt so ein bisschen daran, dass wir jetzt feststellen, wir müssen für unsere Werte eintreten, denn wenn wir einfach nur sagen, werdet mal kapitalistisch, dann infizieren wir euch mit in sich guten Werten und dann ist die Demokratie automatisch im Schlepptau. Und jetzt stellt man fest, nee, ist sie nicht. Und vielleicht sind wir auch gar nicht so demokratisch, aber diesen ganzen Teamkomplex könnte man ja auch mal so groß aufziehen, wenn man jetzt diese Europäische Union und so. Alle sagen, die Europawahl ist so wichtig, aber diese Frage, wie demokratisch geht es dazu, wird dann wieder ausgeblendet.
Und der geht ja dann auf eine große Studie ein von Ivan Krastev unter anderem. Und Ivan Krastev ist ja auch jemand, der jetzt als einer steht, der für die liberale Demokratie plädiert und ja dann noch viel eingeladen wird, um zu zeigen, wo es dann hapert. Und da gibt es eine Studie, die ist länderübergreifend durchgeführt worden, was denn eigentlich die Menschen erstrebenswert finden, welches System. Und dann blicken sie so nach Westen und sagen, ja, die haben es ja schon gut, aber mit dieser liberalen Demokratie, damit schwächen die sich doch selbst. Das heißt, es entsteht, schreibt Precht, nach dem Ende der statischen Unipolarität, der Vereinigten Staaten, eine äußerst flexible und dynamische multipolare Weltordnung. Staaten agieren daran eher wie Unternehmen, die ihre Geschäftspartnerschaften rein strategisch und nützlich eingehen, ganz gleich, ob man nun weltanschaulich auf einer Linie liegt. Also damit sagt er nochmal klar, diese Idee, die da vertreten wird von, wir haben da eigentlich einen ideologischen Kampf, stimmt so nicht. Aber dann gibt es diese Studie und die besagt, es geht in Zukunft definitiv nicht um die unrealistisch verkürzende Frage, wie hältst du es mit den USA oder mit China. Für den überwiegenden Teil der Welt hat das alte Muster von der systemischen Rivalität längst ausgedient. Statt vor einer Konfrontation von Machtblöcken steht die Welt entsprechend der multipolaren Weltordnung vor multipolaren Konflikten und es gibt eigentlich nicht das Interesse, diese Aufteilung mitzuvollziehen. Viele Menschen befürworten, dass ihre Länder in Sicherheitsfragen verstärkt mit dem von den USA geführten westlichen Block zusammenarbeiten, aber sie bevorzugen die wirtschaftliche Kooperation mit China. Alles in allem wollen die Menschen außerhalb des Westens weder eine zu enge politische Ausrichtung an China, noch an Europa und den USA. Das ist vielleicht am deutlichsten, wenn es um Fragen von Krieg und Frieden geht. Die meisten Menschen in den nicht-westlichen Ländern wollen, dass Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine so schnell wie möglich endet, auch wenn das bedeutet, dass Kiev Gebete abtreten muss. Der Wert, den die Menschen dem westlichen Lebensstandard und dessen Werten zusprechen, übersetzt sich nicht in einen Glauben in das politische Projekt Europa oder in die Widerstandsfähigkeit liberaler Gesellschaften. Viele Menschen außerhalb des Westens zweifeln daran, dass die EU oder die liberalen Gesellschaften überhaupt in der Breite überleben werden. Und das ist der Befund von Krastev und den anderen. Das heißt, diese Entweder-oder-Polarität, die jetzt gerade produziert wird, deckt sich nicht mit dem, was die meisten Menschen auf der Welt wollen oder wie sie es sehen.
Also diese Studie ist ganz interessant und da würde ich aber nochmal dazu betonen, dass zum Beispiel in China die Leute das so akzeptieren, die ganze Zeit beobachtet und überwacht zu werden und so. Das hat ja viel damit zu tun, dass man da so eine neutrale Instanz sieht, während selber auch über die Eigenkind-Politik dieser Egoismus so krass graziert dort. Lieber ein handelnden Staat, der dafür sorgt, dass ich nicht übervorteilt werde als diese westliche Freiheit. Und jetzt ist aber das Problem in unseren westlichen Ländern und halb Europas davon infiziert, dass man sich nicht von seinem Nachbar übervorteilt sieht, sondern vom Staat. Also die meisten AfD-Wähler und so weiter wünschen sich nicht so einen hammerharten Staat, auch wenn es immer so aussieht, sondern sie wünschen sich eigentlich weniger Staat. Sie vertrauen ihrem Nachbar mehr als ihrem Staat.
Auch bei den Konservativen. Noch mal dieses Triel, Laschet sagt in seinem Abschlussstatement, ich will sie nicht gängeln. Das ist das Versprechen der Konservativen. Und das ist fundamental anders deshalb auch in China. Und hier noch mal, ich rechtfertige dieses Überwachungssystem nicht, würde mich mit Händen und Füßen dagegen wehren. Ich zahle ja sogar noch Bar, damit ich nicht überwacht werde. Aber die Erfahrung der Chinesen vor Ort ist eine, die durchdrängt ist mit Korruption. Das heißt, jemand macht irgendwas, wird aufgeschrieben, dafür wird verpetzt. Der andere macht dasselbe, ist aber ein Genosse, wird nicht verpetzt. Das heißt, die ganze Zeit hat diese Korruption Ungerechtigkeit strukturell manifestiert. Jetzt kommt Stephans KI, die guckt neutral darauf, sagt, wer ist bei Rot über die Ampel gegangen. Ist mir egal, welche Identität der hat, welche Parteimitgliedschaft, wird gemeldet. Und diese Neutralität, die diese holistische Überwachung hat, bringt mehr Gerechtigkeit als früher das korrupte System.
Das ist einer der großen Erfolge von Qi, als Bürgermeister in Shanghai, jeden zweiten Funktionär hinter Gittern gebracht zu haben. Aufgrund von Korruption, also da einfach aufzuräumen. Also da sind unter dieser Proante, die immer gemacht wird, noch so ein paar Strukturen, die man sich mal anschauen müsste. Was ich sehr überraschend fand, als er dann darüber schreibt, diesen systemischen Wettstreit, passt das denn so ins Bild? Nein, es passt nicht ins Bild. Er kommt auf die offizielle Zweiteilung der Menschenrechte zu sprechen, die mir so nicht bewusst war.
Mir auch nicht.
Also wir haben nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg eine politische Menschenrechtskonvention, die sofort weltweit unterschrieben wird. Freiheiten, Würde, wie auch immer, mach was du willst, der Staat wird dich nicht töten, einsperren oder wie auch immer. Dann kommt es aber zu einer Bewegung, dass relativ spät, nämlich 1966 erst, ein zweiter Pakt auch für soziale Freiheitsrechte, der Staat hat Versorgungspflichten und so weiter und so fort. Wenn wir jetzt also sagen, China hält sich nicht an die Menschenrechte, müssen wir hier eine Rechtsaufklärung folgen. Amerika hat lediglich den Internationalen Pakt ratifiziert, diesen ersten. China nur den Sozialpakt. Also die Chinesen können mit gleicher Inbrunst behaupten, wir haben doch die Menschenrechtskonvention unterschrieben, ihr aber nicht. Zum Beispiel diese ganzen ILO-Fragen. International Labor Organization. Wie gehen wir denn um mit Zwangsarbeit, Kinderarbeit, Überstunden, Urlaubsrechten, Recht auf Feierabend und so weiter und so fort. Ist ja eigentlich alles geregelt. Amerika so, Recht auf Gewerkschaft steht da drin und das schreiben wir nicht. Also es gibt ganz viele grundlegende Menschenrechtskonvention, die Amerika einfach nicht unterschrieben hat. Von dieser ILO-Konvention weiß ich, dass das das Gesetz ist, das am allerlängsten im Kongress zur Unterschrift bereitliegt, ohne jemals auf die Tagesordnung hochgeholt zu werden. Also dieser Vorwurf, die halten sich ja nicht an die Menschenrechte. Doch, doch, doch. Also in China ist es der Partei ganz wichtig, sozialen Frieden über einen Aufstiegsversprechen herzustellen. Dem ordnen sie alles unter und die Menschen verlangen geradezu, dass Freiheitsrechte eingetauscht werden gegen Aufstiegsversprechen, gegen politische ökonomische Perspektive und so weiter und so fort. Dagegen kann man gar nicht anargumentieren. Insbesondere nicht, wenn in Deutschland nicht mal diskutiert werden kann, dass wir in politisch, innerhalb unserer Gesetzgebung, innerhalb unserer, wir haben ein Regierungsmandat, wir wollen mal an eurer Heizung etwas politisch regeln. Klappt nicht. Und dann mit der Idee, die Außenministerin fährt nach China, nennt den Chef dort ein Diktator und sagt jetzt aber mal Menschenrechte. Also es versteht sich von selber. Es braucht gar keine weitere Argumentation.
Ich könnte höchstens sagen, Frau Baerbock, was machen Sie eigentlich mit den Heizungen? Da stimmt irgendwas nicht. Haben Sie das gar nicht im Griff?
Genau. Einfach die Rückfrage. Wie gehen Sie denn mit Ihren Einwohnern um? Sie diktieren denen jetzt die Heizung? Also irgendwie so. Also dieses Buch läuft dann, in dem es einfach nur noch so ein Dach nennt, auf so eine Zwangsläufigkeit in der eigenen Argumentation hinaus. Weshalb ich halt denke, das Thema ist viel, viel größer, als jetzt zu sagen, ich habe da mal eine Essay geschrieben. Eigentlich bräuchte das jetzt so eine große, große, große Aufarbeitung, an der auch ein Frank-Walter nicht mehr vorbeikommt, wenn der nächste Anlass ist, eine Sonntagsrede zu halten.
Was ja dann interessant ist, wenn wir zu Kapitel 7 springen, dann ist es ja so, dass er jetzt sagt, wir haben dieses verengte Narrativ, wir haben diese Derivationen. Die führen dazu, dass neue Feindbilder entstanden sind. Und dann wird von systemischer Rivalität gesprochen. Woher kommt denn eigentlich dieses Denken in solchen, ja, sehr manichäischen Strukturen? Naja, das ist doch etwas, was wir von den Neokons kennen, also jenen Leuten, die zum Beispiel sehr stark George W. Bush beraten haben. Also diese Neokons haben ja in verschiedenen Thinktanks enormen Einfluss ausgeübt, unter anderem auch Irving Kristall. Man muss aber sagen, diese Neokons, die gehen von einem Weltbild aus, das eigentlich eines ist, der strukturellen Realisten, wo sie sagen, ja, Amerika muss weiterhin Stärke zeigen. Und das schaffen wir, indem wir Militärstationen da und dort haben und diese und jene klein halten. Das möchte ich ja mal hier unterstreichen, weil Mersheimer natürlich auch in gewisser Weise zu diesen Leuten gehört. Mersheimer ist ja jemand, der sagt, ja, mit der Ukraine und dem Auskonflikt macht sich jetzt Amerika so lang, die sollen sich mal auf China konzentrieren. Also Mersheimer ist ja jetzt nicht eine Friedenstaube, um das mal durchzumachen. Und das verbindet eigentlich dann ein Irving Kristall mit einem Mersheimer und auch einem Kissinger, dass man doch von so einer systemischen Rivalität ausgeht, nur dann die Bewertung der Lage anders ist. Und das ist ja auch dann das, was einen Gysi und einen Herfried Münkler verbindet und trennt. Beide wollen von Interessen reden. Gysi würde aber jetzt das deutsche oder europäische Interesse wahrscheinlich weiter weg von NATO-transatlantischen Verbindungen sehen, während Herfried Münkler eher dazu tendiert zu sagen, es ist in unserem Interesse, ein festes transatlantisches Band zu haben. Und jetzt sind es aber diese Neokonservativen, die ja eigentlich Rechte sind, die sagen, wenn Krieg sein muss, dann muss der halt sein. Und genau das haben wir mit George W. Bush erlebt. Dadurch aber, und das finde ich wirklich jetzt toll hergeleitet, wäre nochmal einen ganz eigenen Aufsatz, glaube ich, so an sich wert, um es so ganz detailliert mal nachzuzeichnen, ist Folgendes gelungen. Wir haben ja gemerkt, als der Krieg gegen die Ukraine begann, dass man plötzlich die NATO-Falken, die rechten Politiker der CDU, gemeinsam mit linksliberalen Podcasts dann Slavoj Ukraini rufen hörte. Und man sich so dachte, ach, ich dachte, die sind sich irgendwie feindlich. Dann war Jan Fleischhauer, hatte mal so einen Tweet, in dem er sagt, ja, früher fand ich die ja alle blöd, aber jetzt, das war dann im Zuge des Krieges, jetzt finde ich auch Posts von Friedemann Karich gut und so was, kamen dann da. Und naja, die Sache ist das, was Precht dann hier sehr gut beschreibt. Man hat es geschafft, diese neokonservative, schrägstrich realistische Perspektive von Kristall und Kissinger zu verbinden mit einem Moralismus, der bis hineinreicht in das Woke-Lager, wo man sagt, ja, aber wir müssen ja auch decolonize Ukraine und so weiter betreiben. Und hat damit ein Paket geschnürt, dass sich dann jetzt westliche Werte, liberale Demokratie nennt, dass man in Anschlag bringen kann gegen die, gegen die Autoritären. Und so haben sich eigentlich diese neokonservativen Stiftungen eine mediale Dominanz errungen, mit Hilfe auch eines großen linksliberalen Presse- und Think-Tank-Spektrums, weil nun plötzlich alle sich unterhaken müssen, um gegen die Feinde der liberalen Demokratie zu kämpfen. Und diese Verquickung war ja, wir sind alt genug, um das zu wissen, bei George Bushs Irakkrieg noch nicht da. Da war das noch klar, dass man gegen diesen Krieg ist. Jetzt hat sich aber so eine Dynamik ergeben, dass plötzlich alle von Vogue bis Brogue für Aufrüstung und systemische Rivalität aussprechen. Und das ist schon sehr gut beobachtet.
Was jetzt dazu führt, dass dieser Untertitel Plädoyer für eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik eigentlich wirklich nicht passt? Denn Werte, schreibt er ja, was soll das sein? Also Werte hat man nicht. Man hat vielleicht gerade mal eine Diskussion am Laufen, die man ein bisschen strukturieren möchte. Also nimmt man sich mal ganz punktuell und vergisst auch sofort wieder, was der eigene Wert war. Man nimmt sich einfach mal so ein Wert. Also Werte strukturieren gar nichts. Sie rechtfertigen höchstens, warum man jetzt den nächsten Satz formuliert, aber keine Lebensfragen. Er sagt ja ganz deutlich, wenn man wirklich, also wenn man das Plädoyer ernst nimmt, Plädoyer für eine Werte geleitete Politik, sagen wir mal, nehmen wir mal außen raus, Plädoyer für eine Werte geleitete Politik, schreibt er, die Krux ist der größte Feind, den man folgerichtig zu bekämpfen hätte mit einer Werte geleiteten Politik, wäre der eigene Lebensstil. Und nicht die Chinesen. Wir sind in dieser klimapolitischen Verantwortung, dass bei uns auch die Ärmsten ein Lebensstil leben, der sich global nicht verwirklichen lässt. Und damit schließen wir die meisten Lebensräume von 90 Prozent der Menschen einfach aus. Die dürfen sich nicht verwirklichen, weil dann wäre es vorbei mit der Welt. Also das ist zum Teil Werte. Die Frage ist dann, was bleibt beim Thema Außenpolitik? Wofür kann man ein Plädoyer machen? Er schreibt hier ganz deutlich, Wertegeleiter der Außenpolitik darf eins nicht sein, das Gegenteil von Diplomatie, was sie jetzt gerade ist. Wir brauchen eine Verständigung auf den Minimalkonsens, das ist so seine Arbeitsthese mit dem Argument, Toleranz oder Katastrophe. Toleranz oder Katastrophe. Also das Jahrhundert der Toleranz, sehr guter Titel. Plädoyer für eine Wertegeleiter der Außenpolitik. Plädoyer für Toleranz oder Katastrophe. Werte sind hier schon aus dem Bild geschoben. Also wer jetzt noch eine Wertediskussion führt, muss sich selbst zu seinem größten Feind erklären. Das ist sozusagen die Pointe in diesem Buch.
Anders, ja, weil das natürlich der Begriff ist, den jetzt Baerbock so prägt, aber es könnte ja jetzt für Leute, die gar nicht wissen, was Precht so in den letzten Monaten geäußert hat, irgendwie als sei er jetzt vielleicht auch, als hätte er ein Buch geschrieben, das Baerbock beauftragt hat. Und das ist ja genau nicht der Fall. Deswegen hätte ich auch eher von diesem Begriff Abstand genommen. Also er sagt ja, dass wir nicht mehr von westlichen Werten reden sollten. Und das ist ja erst schon mal sehr richtig. Denn wenn man, und der bringt ja ja sehr gute Begründung, vielleicht gehen wir noch ganz schnell durch, er sagt, also sobald man von westlichen Werten redet, sagt man, das sind dann die Werte des Westens. Dann sind das aber auch nur seine Werte. Und der Osten hat vielleicht andere Werte. Also von daher nicht sinnvoll. Dann muss man auch sehen, dass wenn man von westlichen Werten redet, man Doppelstandards aufmacht. Er sagt zum Beispiel, wer russische Athleten wegen des russischen Angriffs auf die Ukraine für internationale Wettbewerbe sperren lassen will, kann nur dann glaubwürdig argumentieren, wenn er beim US-amerikanischen Überfall auf den Irak 2003 den Ausschuss von US-Sportlern von internationalen Sportveranstaltungen gefordert hat. Das war ja ein bisschen das, was ich auch sagen wollte, dass man da sehr vorsichtig sein sollte, jetzt irgendwas laufend zu canzeln. Und dann wurde ich darauf hingewiesen, ja, weil man hat doch gegen die israelische Sängerin nicht demonstriert, sondern dagegen, dass Israel teilnehmen musste. Ich finde, dass ja sowieso man solchen Ausschuss nicht praktizieren sollte. Und deswegen wäre ich auch dafür, dass man Russland am ESC teilnehmen lässt. Deshalb, um eine andere Seite nicht nur Russlands zu zeigen, sondern auch um den Russen eine andere Seite zu zeigen. Also ich halte es für sehr falsch, solche Kanäle zuzumachen. Aber das ist noch mal ein anderes Thema. Dann sagt er, wenn man von westlichen Werten redet, dann kommt man in so eine Überlegenheitsbehauptung. Das sollte man unterlassen. Wenn man von westlichen Werten redet, dann ruft das Trotz und Widerstand hervor. Und dann wird das so zurückgespiegelt an einen. Und dann sieht man plötzlich seine eigene Macht dort. Und er sagt also hier ganz klar, westliche Werte, das ist das Falsche, aber eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik dennoch. Und Werte meint ja jetzt bei ihm eigentlich, dass man sich auf den Universalismus verständigen kann, sich aber klar machen muss, und das ist ja dann in diesem Kapitel 12, dass man nicht mit Eile und Ungeduld kommen kann, schon gar nicht, wenn man ein Land ist, dass diese Menschenrechte auch noch nicht allzu lange hoch hält. Und er zeigt ja dann auf, dass gerade bei Grüne und CDU so ein merkwürdiges Sendungsbewusstsein sich herausgebildet hat. Er schreibt, Vertreter der Grünen halten oft für bare Münze, was interessegeleitet formuliert wird. Also man spricht von Werten, aber eigentlich ist es interessegeleitet. Wohingegen Außenpolitiker der Union im Regelfall sehr genau wissen, aus welchem Interesse heraus sie sprechen. Dies dürfte nicht zuletzt für den Satz gelten, den die CDU-CSU-Fraktion im Februar 2024 auf ihrer Homepage schrieb. In ihrem Abwehrkampf verteidigen die Ukrainer somit auch westliche Werte, wie die Wahrung der Menschenrechte, Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit. Und weiter sagt er dann noch, dass so ein Toleranzparadox besteht, wenn zum Beispiel von dieser Erfolgsgeschichte der liberalen Demokratie gesprochen wird. Zur Erfolgsgeschichte der liberalen Demokratien gehört, dass sie über die zweieinhalb Jahrhunderte ihres Bestehens nach und nach immer toleranter wurden. Staaten, die ursprünglich nur für privilegierte weiße Männer gedacht waren, entwickelten sich in allen westlichen Industriegesellschaften mehr und mehr zu offenen pluralistischen Gesellschaften. Das heißt, das ist also eine schrittweise Entwicklung und deswegen muss man also diese Werte hochhalten, muss aber auch sich darüber im Klaren werden, dass die, so sehr man das auch sich wünscht, nicht von heute auf morgen zu realisieren sind. Und da sind wir natürlich jetzt bei so einer ganz heiklen Frage, wie weit kann man denn Menschenrechtsverletzungen akzeptieren? Also man ist ja auch unglücklich über diese Merkel-Haltung zu sagen, ja Menschenrechte müssen wir auch mal ansprechen, aber dann ist auch mehr folgt daraus auch nicht. Es ist ganz heikel und er kann es auch in dem Sinne für uns nicht klar beantworten, denn zu sagen Eile und Ungeduld sind keine guten Helfer stimmt, aber man kann auch verstehen, wenn man sagt, naja die Leute sind ja jetzt von Menschenrechtsverletzungen betroffen und da können wir nicht sagen, warte 20 Jahren wird es bestimmt besser.
Ich möchte zum Ende anschließen, was ich am Anfang aufwarf. Zum einen die Frage, ist es ein philosophisches Buch? Haben wir es hier mit Denksport zu tun, der noch mal darauf hinweist, dass wir es hier nicht mit einem mathematischen Problem zu tun haben, sondern mit Herausforderungen sozialer Krisen, die zu bewältigen sind, in einem Diskursverfahren. Und die Ergebnisse müssten dann immer wieder überprüft werden, ob sie am Ende passen. So und jetzt lese ich was vor. Er macht es so wichtig, es ist ihm so wichtig, dass er sogar zweimal dasselbe schreibt, einmal in eigenen Worten. Und dann referiert er noch mal und wir fragen uns, während wir das hören. Stimmt es? Haben wir es hier wirklich mit erstens Philosophie zu tun und zweitens mit uneindeutigen Antworten, die immer eines Diskurses bedürfen oder ist eins plus eins einfach zwei? Also ich lese. Nur solange ein Land wie Deutschland, dessen Wohlstand zu einem beträchtlichen Teil auf dem Handel mit China beruht, weiterhin eine prosperierende Industrienation bleibt, was ohne den großen wirtschaftlichen Austausch mit China wohl unmöglich ist. Nur solange wird es in China überhaupt ernst genommen und kann mit seinen Mitteln zur Verständigung beitragen. Jetzt zitiert er Frank Sieren, ein Chinakennner. Nur wenn wir wirtschaftlich stark sind, ergattern wir noch einen Platz an dem Tisch, an dem die neue Weltordnung ausgehandelt wird. Früher hat uns dem Westen dieser Tisch gehört und wir haben entschieden, wer dort einen Platz bekommt und wann was sagen darf. Doch diese Zeiten sind nun vorbei. Das sind für mich eins plus eins sind zwei Sätze. Insbesondere, wenn er dann anfügt, nur über diese ökonomische Dimension, einen ökonomischen Austausch, bei dem Handelsbilanzen klar und für beide Seiten transparent sind. Wir gehen hier in eine gemeinsame Richtung. Nur dann finden wir überhaupt einen konfliktpräventiven Umgang mit China. Das bedeutet, wir dürfen uns nicht länger in einer systemischen Herausforderung sehen, in einer Auseinandersetzung, in einem Konflikt bis hin zum schießenden Krieg, sondern nur als, Zitat, Schicksalsgenossen. Für mich ist das politisches 1 plus 1 ist 2. Und dann, um da nochmal eine Handlungsorientierung für uns reinzubringen, macht er sehr schöne Sinnsprüche am Schluss, Zitat. Warum den Historikern späterer Zeiten überlassen, was man schon jetzt überschauen kann? Wenn wir doch jetzt wissen, dass 1 plus 1 2 ist, warum überlegen wir noch, ob es 3, 4 oder 7,8 sein könnte? Warum jetzt noch eine Philosophie ist im Grunde die Frage. Und dann sein zweiter Sinnspruch. Das Mindeste, was ich abschließend sagen können will, ist, dass der Satz, nachher ist man immer schlauer, nachher nicht gesagt werden kann, weil man schon vorher schlauer war.
Ja, das ist eine wunderbare Formulierung.
Das ist keine Philosophie. Das ist Politik, die sich zurecht den Anspruch nimmt, zu sagen, Leute, hört mal kurz auf zu diskutieren. Eins plus eins ist zwei.
Ja, ich kann dem nur zustimmen. Also die Werte müssen selbst beachtet werden. Nicht-militärische Prävention von Konflikten und Kriegen sind sinnvoll. Kritik muss über die internationalen Institutionen, die gestärkt gehören, artikuliert werden. Uno beispielsweise. Man braucht eine realistische Prioritätensetzung. Das muss aber auch im Einklang mit den Menschenrechten sein. Inwieweit dann Eile und Geduld doch manchmal erforderlich ist, da wird es schon wieder heikel. Er stellt die Fragen. Ist das Spiel, das zu immer mehr Waffen führt, nicht längst durchschaut? Diese sich nicht all dies vermeiden, weil es dabei gar nicht um Gut und Böse geht, sondern um mitunter kontraire Interessen, die auch auf anderen Wege verhandelt werden könnten. Und gibt es nicht ein Menschheitsinteresse, das viel schwerer wiegt als jene Interessen, die derzeit die Rüstungsspirale sich höher und höher winden lassen? Die Antwort auf all das lautet, ja, das ist richtig. Es sind rhetorische Fragen und man kann sie so beantworten. Nur sehe ich nicht, dass dauerhaft diese Multipolarität akzeptiert wird. Also ist Europa bereit, Souveränität abzugeben, an internationale Institutionen zu delegieren? Sind die USA dazu bereit? Nein. Konzernstrukturen brauchen diese unipolare Weltordnung vielleicht? Doch, darüber reden wir nachher mal. Aber ich glaube, dass die Staaten sich in diesem Konkurrenzkampf gegenüberstehen und der zur Not auch dann militärisch ausgetragen wird. Auch wenn es gut ist. Ich glaube, dass es kurzfristig dann ganz hohe Verluste bedeutet und sehr viel Geld bedeutet. Das ist ein Paradigma, das sehr schwer zu durchbrechen ist, weshalb die Realisten natürlich fast immer darauf verweisen können, dass sie mal wieder Recht hatten. Das ist aber nicht etwas, was sich Precht angreiten kann, sondern das ist eher was, was uns etwas aussage über den Zustand der Welt. Ich glaube, was wir vor allem aus dem Buch mitnehmen können, ist eben diese Beobachtung aus der Distanz heraus. Diese Beobachtung meint dann, dass man, auch wenn diese Situation mitunter so fatal ist, nicht das Ganze noch damit anfüttert und diesen Prozess beschleunigt und verstärkt dadurch, dass man mit den entsprechenden Derivationen in den Talkshows sitzt oder sonst wo unterwegs ist und das immer wieder verkündet, dass das die systemische Rivalität ist. Und jetzt ist nun mal die Friedensdividende aufgebraucht und wir müssen auf eine neue Härte einsetzen. Und das ist etwas, was man daraus sehr mitnehmen kann. Also in meinen Augen ist das hier nach der vierten Gewalt quasi das zweite medienkritische Buch, das er hier geschrieben hat. Und ich könnte mir allerdings auch vorstellen, dass bei all dem, was das so Fatales mit sich bringt, mit dem idealen Gesamtkapitalisten Staat, dass man, würde man zumindest mal auf dieser Ebene diskutieren, wie Precht das hier tut und würde nicht mit den Werten kommen und sich sie gegenseitig auf internationaler Bühne um die Ohren schlagen, dann würde man wahrscheinlich mehr vernunftgeleitete Entscheidungen haben, als das jetzt der Fall ist. Das Jahrhundert der Toleranz heißt das neue Buch von Richard David Precht. Und er mischt sich ein in die Debatte um die wertegeleitete Außenpolitik, um die Geopolitik und um die Frage, wird es gehen, ob wir uns tatsächlich in einer systemischen Rivalität befinden zu den autoritären Staaten, vor allem Russland und China? Oder sind das nicht Ideologien, die den Diskurs so sehr prägen und kaputt machen, dass wir gar nicht mehr erkennen, was uns eigentlich als Menschen alle verbindet?
Ist es ein philosophisches Buch? Nein, es ist politisch. Ist es ausgleichend? Nein, es ist anklagend. Ist es ein Buch über die Toleranz? Ja, alternativ ist nur die Katastrophe. Ist es ein Plädoyer für Werte geleitete Außenpolitik? Nein, es ist ein Plädoyer für die Schicksalsgemeinschaft der ganzen Welt.
Die flämische Autorin Gaea Schoeters hat einen Roman geschrieben mit dem Titel Trophäe. Er ist bei Schollnay erschienen und ich bin ganz glücklich damit, denn der Protagonist Hunter White. Er heißt Hunter und er jagt gerne und er heißt mit Nachnamen White und er ist ein Weißer. Also natürlich wird hier mit dem Namen gespielt. Er arbeitet an der Börse. Er hat eine Frau, die irgendwo im Westen auf ihn wartet. Immer wieder mal spricht er mit ihr. Jetzt aber befindet er sich irgendwo in Afrika und ist auf Großwildjagd, denn er ist ein Trophäenjäger. Das heißt, er will große Tiere erlegen und dann diese ausstopfen lassen und nach Hause bringen lassen. Und das auch zur Freude seiner Frau. Und jetzt fehlt ihm noch ein Spitzmaul-Nashorn. Das ist gar nicht so einfach zu bekommen. Das hat er nun aber vor. Das möchte er jagen. Wir gehen jetzt mal so ein bisschen in den Kopf von diesem Hunter White hinein. Ich lese mal eine Passage vor. Lange bevor Gletscherstudien, Permafrostbohrungen und die Angst vor dem Klimawandel die Superreichen dazu angestiftet hatten, in Landebanen in Neuseeland und Bergressorts hoch über den Meeresspiegel zu investieren, hatte Hunter schon damit angefangen, unberührte Naturgebiete zu kaufen. Darauf trainiert, jede noch so kleine Marktschwankung zu erspüren, hatte er mit rund zwei Jahrzehnten Vorsprung begriffen, dass die Natur, wenn erst einmal alles vollgebaut wäre, zum neuen Gold würde. Die Währung der Zukunft. Je fester die Zivilisation die Welt im Griff hätte, desto wertvoller würde die Wildnis. Jetzt konnte das jedes Kind erkennen. Die Illusion des Abenteuers ist inzwischen auch auf dem Konsumentenmarkt ein florierendes Marktsegment geworden, während das wirkliche Ausbrechen aus der eigenen Welt immer mehr zum Privileg der wenigen auserwählten wird. Aber in der Zeit, in der Hunter seine ersten Ankäufe tätigte, war noch keine Rede vom Ökotourismus, Back to Nature, Aussteigen oder autarkem Leben. Paleo war noch eine Ära, kein Ernährungstrend. Während die Finanzwelt wie verrückt in das ultimativ Ungreifbare investierte, die Internetblase, kaufte er für einen Pappenstil Land, das niemand haben wollte. Heute besitzt er Schluchten auf Kreter, Steppe und Wüste in Kasachstan, einen Regenwaldkorridor in Costa Rica und ein paar Streifenteiger in Russland. Seine prophetischen Ankäufe haben ihn nicht nur steinreich gemacht, sie machten ihn auch glücklich. Nicht wegen des inzwischen stark gestiegenen Wertes, sondern schlicht und einfach, weil sie jetzt ihm gehören und deshalb unberührt bleiben werden. Denn was ihn antreibt, ist nicht die Spekulation, sondern die Erhaltung, die Welt vor der Zivilisation zu beschützen. Wir haben also hier mit einem eigenartigen Charakter zu tun, der dann auch folgend die macht, und das ist tatsächlich in Afrika bei der Großhylteak, dass er dann einen sehr großen Betrag bereit ist zu zahlen, ein paar Hunderttausend, um so einen Nashorn schießen zu können. Dann wird das alles so halb illegal eingefädelt. Aber natürlich sind die Staaten auch eigentlich dafür, dass das so geschieht. Sondern dann kommt halt Geld ins Land. Man darf also ein Tier töten, und dann fließt aber ein großer Batzen dieses gezahlten Geldes wiederum in die Wiederbeforstung, in den Naturschutz. Und das ist ja moralisch ein bisschen vergleichbar mit dem, was man so unter Kompensieren versteht. Man verpestet die Umwelt mit einem Pflug und zahlt aber ein bisschen was, dass wieder irgendwo noch ein Tümpel entsteht. Und jetzt ist es so, dass sie also diese Nashornjagd eher dann dort mit Eingeweihten und Vertrauten betreiben will. Er arbeitet da sehr lange zusammen schon mit jemandem, der da auch ein Geschäft draus gemacht hat. Und nun ist es aber so, dass Wilderer sich breit gemacht haben und jetzt auch fangen, dieses Nashorn ihm vor der Nase weg zu jagen. Mit hohem Tempo nehmen sie die Verfolgung auf. Wie lange sie laufen, ist schwer zu sagen. Mit jedem Schritt wird Hanthas Angst größer. Sein Nashorn darf nicht in die Hände von Wilderern fallen. Sie müssen es retten um jeden Preis. Schon bald, heute Abend, wird Hanthas ihnen auslachen. Wie so retten, um es dann selbst zu erschießen, das ist doch Pläm Pläm. Vergeblich wird er dem Jungen zu erklären versuchen, dass Jagen das Gegenteil von Wildern ist. Und auch wenn viele Wilderer gute Jäger sind, dann doch wieder an Hanthas festgefahrener afrikanischer Logik abzuprallen. Tod ist Tod, was natürlich völliger Schwachsinn ist. Jedes Kind weiß, dass kein Schuss dem anderen gleicht. Auf solchen Regeln beruht die Weltordnung. Wenn Ranger Wilderer erschießen, ist das, wie Van Heeren gerade gesagt hat, erlaubte Notwehr. Wenn Wilderer auf Ranger schießen, ist das Mord. Das heißt, hier gibt es eine kategoriale Unterscheidung, die wir so ein bisschen aus dem Buch kennen, das wir eben von Precht besprochen haben. Und wir merken schon, moralisch stimmt da doch einiges nicht. Und was ist das überhaupt für ein Typ, der seinen Lebensinhalt darin sieht, dass er solche merkwürdigen Trophäen nach Hause bringen muss und die sich für seinen Megaloft ausstopfen lässt. Und wir sehen dann, wie er da existenziell sich spürt, wie er mitfiebert, wie er ganz bei der Natur ist, seinen Körper in einer Weise wahrnimmt, wie er das sonst nicht tut. Und nun ist es aber so, dass diese Wilderer ihm das Nashorn erschießen. Er hat also jetzt diesen Deal gemacht und hat aber jetzt gar nichts davon. Aber er sieht dann da Indigene rumlaufen, die ziemlich im Einklang mit der Natur zu leben scheinen, aber doch nicht so ganz, also schon auch von der Moderne erfasst wurden. Und es ist dann so, eine unangenehme Anspannung überfällt Hunter. Seine Nackenhaare stellen sich auf die Jagd, die in den letzten Stunden wie eine fremde Fantasie gewirkt hat, wie eine Erinnerung an einen halbvergessenen Traum, nimmt plötzlich Gestalt an. Genau wie bei der Versteigerung, bei der er allerdings über einen Strohmann seine Jagdlizenz für das Nashorn gekauft hat, merkt er, wie sein Körper reagiert. Der Herzmuskel zieht sich zusammen, das Blut pocht in den Adern, Sauerstoff jagt durch sein Leib. Er, Hunter, wird jagen. Aber sein Verstand, der jetzt normalerweise von freudiger Erwartung erfüllt werden sollte und von der Aufgeregtheit, die er seit seiner Kindheit kennt, zögert, als er den Jungen betrachtet. Will er wirklich einen Menschen jagen? Und wir lassen es an dieser Stelle mal offen, wie finster dieses Buch noch wird und was ist, wenn man eigentlich diese Kompensationslogik, die ich eben für die Tiere ausgeführt habe, dann auch noch bereit ist, auf Menschen zu übertragen. Also wir reden viel über Kolonialismus und so. Das hier ist wirklich ein sehr, sehr gutes Buch darüber. Es ist ein sehr gutes Buch über das westliche Selbstverständnis. Es ist ein gutes Buch über Afrika als Kontinent, von dem wir immer nur als Afrika so häufig sprechen. Die Autorin war selbst auch nie dort, aber sie hat, glaube ich, das, was an Ideologie in westlichen Köpfen über Afrika da ist, hier wunderbar literarisch dekonstruiert und das mit einer sehr, sehr beeindruckenden Sprache.
Ich dachte, die Pointe ist einfach, ich habe einen Nashorn erobert, ökonomisch, in dem ich seinen Lebensraum aufgekauft habe, und das jetzt als Trophäe in meinem Entitlement ökonomischem Repertoire.
Nein.
Aber nein, es muss wieder um die Jagd gehen.
Es wird sehr, sehr tödlich.
Gilda Sahebi hat ein Buch über Rassismus geschrieben, wie wir uns Rassismus beibringen. Sie kommt uns immer mal unter, weil sie in Fernsehdiskussionen oder schreibend für die Taz oder keine Ahnung. Und sie war wohl vor zwei Jahren auch Politik Journalistin des Jahres im Medienmagazin. Also dieser Dunstkreis. Ich habe sie in einer Land-Sendung gesehen. Hab ja deswegen gesagt, ich bringe das Buch mit und ich schlage das Buch auf. Und worum geht es? Um eine Land-Sendung. Sie sitzt also nach dem 7. Oktober. Da frage ich mich auch wieder, wie schnell werden diese Bücher geschrieben? Wenn ich mir den Verlagen rede, ist das immer so ein... Ja, dann geben Sie ihm im Oktober das Manuskript an, damit wir es dann im März publizieren. Und der 7. Oktober und heute, also das scheint ja alles in dieser Zeit, in der meine Texte immer so ruhig rumliegen irgendwo, schreiben die hier die ganze Zeit. Wahrscheinlich. Jedenfalls, es gab den 7. Oktober und danach Auseinandersetzungen in deutschen Debatten. Unter anderem bei Lanz. Die Bild-Zeitung greift dann die Sendung auf, in der sie zu Gast war und schreibt, klar bei Lanz, Journalistin nennt Merz rassistisch. Und dann schreibt sie dahinter, besonders gefiel mir der Untertitel, schlimmster Vorwurf. So, es geht also nicht nur darum, dass sie, also das aus der Diskussion herausgelesen wurde, dass sie Merz einen Rassisten nennen, sondern auch, dass die Bild dazu sagt, das ist aber ein schlimmer Vorwurf. Der schlimmste Vorwurf. Und sie sagt dann nur locker, ich habe natürlich nicht Merz als Rassisten bezeichnet, sondern die Debatte. Ja, so, und das ist natürlich, also jetzt ist sozusagen die Einflugsschneise gefunden in dieses Buch. Wo kommen die Denkmuster her? Nicht nur Merzes, sondern eben auch die der Bild-Zeitung. Dass man da zum einen solche Beobachtungen macht, das ist aber ein Rassismus-Vorwurf. Und dann auch diese, das ist aber ganz schön schlimm, Konnotation. Dem geht sie nun nach und was dann auch bedeutet, sie sagt dann auch, beim drüber nachdenken ist mir auch mein eigener Rassismus untergekommen und so weiter. Da will ich kurz markieren, ja, weil Sprache einfach diskriminiert. Das ist ihre Aufgabe. Die Frage, welche Wertungen wir dann an die Diskriminierung hängen, die da dran drinstecken, das ist dann Forensik und Debatte. Und da will ich sagen, sind wir auch bei Precht in so einem Metier, wo man auf jeden Fall diskutieren muss und nicht einfach 1 plus 1 ist 2. Merz ist ein Rassist, weil er das und das sagte.
Kannst du das nochmal präzisieren, inwieweit die Sprache diskriminieren muss?
Wenn ich von einem Tisch spreche, dann nur aus einem Grund, weil ich den Tisch in der Kommunikation unterscheiden möchte, von allem anderen. Nicht nur vom Stuhl, nicht nur vom Haus, sondern von allem einfach. Ich markiere einen Tisch. Ich habe also mit dem Wort Tisch und mit der Verwendung der Sprache eine Unterscheidung. In die Kommunikation eingeführt, von der ich hoffe, dass sie sich kognitiv verehrt. Wir also im Anschluss an meine Kommunikation anders denken. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt, wie in dem nächsten Buch, das wir lesen, und sagt, das ist aber schlecht, dass Sprache diskriminiert, dann würde ich sagen, ja, das ist aber ihre Funktion. Wie sie diskriminiert, das muss man dann, was unterscheiden wird. Da kann man dann darüber diskutieren, aber dass die Sprache diskriminiert, ja, ja, da muss man einfach, das muss man dann einfreißen. Sie führt dieses Buch über die Denkmuster, die heute wirken, über zwei Ebenen. Zum einen fragt sie sich, was hat das ursprünglich mit der Geschichte zu tun, also wo kommt der narrative Korridor her, das hat ja Precht auch so aufgedröselt. Geschichte spielt eine Rolle. Und dann, warum es ist heute wichtig, darüber zu reden, weil es nicht beim Gerede bleibt. Also wenn Merz einen rassistischen Argument macht, wenn die Sprache menschenverachtend diskriminiert, statt einfach nur informativ zu diskriminieren. Wenn also nicht einfach nur eine Information, sondern auch eine inspirative Argumentation weitergegeben wird, latent, dass es hier um nicht gleichwertiges Menschsein geht oder wie auch immer, dann haben wir es mit einer Problemstellung zu tun, dass dieses Gerede in einem bestimmten Verhältnis zu Gewalt steht. Physischer und emotionaler. Daraus gewinnt dieses Buch seine Wichtigkeit und sie markiert das zu Beginn. Es geht also um die Schwelle zur Gewaltausübung, um die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass aus einem Gerede Gewalt wird. Und damit, und das ist nun mal zwangsläufig, aber es ist bis hier gut argumentiert, transferiert sie die Hürde sehr weit nach unten mit, das ist aber rassistisch und das sollten wir jetzt auch so markieren. Also wenn man dann sagt, da kann man doch mal drüber weggehen, das ist doch nicht so schlimm. Nein, genau darum geht es, dass dieses Verhältnis zur Gewalt unklar ist, dass es auch nicht nur um den Sprecher geht, sondern um die Kommunikation. Es hört ja jemand zu, welche Schlüsse zieht der dann daraus und so weiter und so fort. Also bis dahin sehr gut argumentiert, also macht sie auch einen weiteren, aber sehr gut. Ich gehe mal punktuell auf ein paar Sachen ein. Geschichtlich beginnt sie im Jahr 1871. Es ist also die deutsche Geschichte als nationale Geschichte, in der wir uns so identitätsfindungsmäßig immer noch positiv aus Bismarck beziehen und sagen, aber der hat doch die Rente erfunden oder wie auch immer. Also um diesen historischen Kontext geht es. Und damals wurden also die Konzepte von Nation und Volk etabliert. Sie spielten im deutschen Kaiserreich eine prägende Rolle. Sie haben uns geprägt. Sie zitiert dann verschiedene Sachen. Ernst Hasse zum Beispiel, 1903, steht im Reichstag. Das einzige, was im Fluss der tausendjährigen Entwicklung Bestand hat, ist das Volk. Das Volk ist auch das einzige, was weitere Wandlungen überdauern wird. Also so wird dann im Reichstag gesprochen. Dass so eine Sprache irgendwo hinführt, wissen wir. Wir können es historisch einfach nachlesen. Sie muss es uns nicht verplausibilisieren. Sie konzentriert sich also auf diesen Begriff des Volk. Die semantische Verwendung Volk. Man hätte ja auch andere Begriffe nutzen können. Warum wird hier auf diese Art diskriminiert? Warum wird die Unterscheidung von Volk und dann andere Völker, Nicht-Völker, Menschen und Barbaren und so weiter. Also in die Richtung muss man dann denken. Und dann macht sie einen Sprung zum CDU-Parteivorsitzenden Friedrich Merz wieder. Januar 2023. Er sitzt also in der Fernsehsendung und redet von kleinen Pashas. Übrigens wieder bei Lanz. Und antwortet dann später auf Kritik, die ihm vorgehalten wird, mit dem Zitat, er habe dem Volk aufs Maul geschaut und eine Beobachtung wiedergegeben. Also hier spielt auch das Volk überbandene wieder eine Rolle. In diesem Sinne, wie Lothar die Bibel übersetzt hat, da kommt ja dieser Spruch her. Also es ist zum einen so ein etablierter Spruch. Man hat halt dem Volk aufs Maul geschaut und dann eine Beobachtung wiedergegeben. Und was meint der mit Volk, fragt sie, na höchstwahrscheinlich keine Arabestämmigen oder andere migrationsmigrantischen Menschen. Denn diese gehören ja dann irgendwie nicht zu dieser Gemeinschaft dazu, weil die hätten ja nicht eine Stimmung, die man ablesen kann, wenn man dem Volk aufs Maul schaut, wo man sagt, ja die kleinen Paschas, also die haben damit schon mal ausgegrenzt. So, sie macht diesen Bogenschlag zu Horst Seehofer, der ja auch jüngst in dem Kontext historisch den See aufzieht, gesagt hat, er sei in einer Koalition mit dem Volk. Und gleichzeitig sagt er auch, Migration ist die Mutter aller Probleme. Also hier ist ein Volksbegriff, der eine latente Sinnstruktur mitbringt, die den Rassismus einfach nur in ein anderes Gewand der Kommunikation höhlt, aber im Grunde die Ernsthasse, das Einzige, was im Fluss des tausendjährigen Entwicklungen bestand hat, ist unser Volk. Das finde ich schon mal, das sind ganz gute Bogenschläge. Also ich ziehe die jetzt viel straffer aus dieser Empirie, die sie macht als sie selber. Sie schreibt das halt so hin und dann weg. Es versteht sich im Grunde auch von selbst. Warum jetzt heute immer noch das Volk? Weil wir natürlich den Rassebegriff aussortiert haben. Also wir kommen hier auch wieder mit Zitaten aus den Jahren, von denen wir dann wissen, ja klar, dann später haben wir die ausgetauscht. Also wir reden heute nicht mehr von Rasse, aber wir adaptieren doch diese Idee in der Rasse. Also der Begriff wird ausgetauscht, aber der diskriminierende Charakter bleibt. Der ist konstant. So, also wir haben jetzt schon Volk, Nation, beides alte Begriffe. Dann kommt die Rasse damit rein. Wurde immer Synonym verwendet. Jetzt Rasse nicht mehr. Wir haben es aussortiert, auch schon allein weil das so ein biologistischer Begriff ist, der aus diesen Gründen einfach, wir haben uns ja vorhin auch mit einem biologistischen Begriff rumgeschlagen gesagt, den brauchen wir aber aus den und den Gründen. Die Denkmuster bleiben also, aber die Begriffe wandeln sich. Wir haben es ja also mit einer Stabilität in der Diskriminierung zu tun, die einfach nur überdeckt wird, aber die bleibt und dann sagt sie ausdrücklich, also ich lese mal den Satz vor, der dann darauf hinausläuft, da aber das Denkmuster, dass der Unterscheidung von Menschen nach Rasse unterliegt, nicht verschwunden ist, entwickelte sich in Deutschland mit der Zeit ein Konzept, das viel besser und freundlicher klang, jetzt überlegen wir kurz, die Kultur. Also, ob wir Rasse oder Kultur sagen, bei manchen Politikern ist es im Grunde nur, aus Verlegenheit hat man den Begriff ausgetauscht, der Rest ist geblieben. Und sie nimmt hier ausdrücklich die politische und die mediale, sowie Precht ja auch schon, in einen Kontext. Das finde ich sehr wichtig und da ist sie auch ganz deutlich. Also, wir haben heute Minderheiten in der Bevölkerung, den Menschenfeindlichen gegenüber kommuniziert wird, über die gesprochen wird, mit denen nicht gesprochen wird, wie auch immer man das jetzt einbetten will, wo die Probleme sind. Es sind Ideologien, die darunter liegen, Politiker und Medienschaffende haben oder nutzen gerne bestehende rassistische Denkmuster, egal in welchen Begriffen. Und hier hat sie jetzt einen sehr schönen Begriff, den kann man auch in Diskussionen benutzen. Wenn heute gefragt wird, gehört der Islam zu Deutschland, dann werden dieselben Diskussionen wie vor 100 Jahren im Reichstag einfach aufgegriffen, aber auf einer Umgehungsstraße. Sie nennt es Umgehungsstraße. Das finde ich sehr gut. Wir haben Flutmetaphorik und so weiter. Christoph Heusgen. Ich möchte kurz über Christoph Heusgen referieren, denn er ist ja bei uns auch präsent. Wir haben sein Buch gelesen. Er ist immer mal wieder als sehr wichtiger Wortspender zugegen. Sie steht also im Fernsehen und erklärt, der Zusammenhang spielt ja gar keine Rolle, also der Kontext, sondern wir Deutschland profitieren auch heute noch sehr davon, dass Deutschland weltweit einen guten Ruf hat. Wir engagieren uns im sogenannten globalen Süden. Wir sind zweitgrößter Geber von Entwicklungshilfe, zweitgrößter Geber des UN-Systems. Wir haben keine große kolonialistische Vergangenheit. Sie kontert mit Ausführung historischer Art zum Thema Deutschland zwischen ab 1984, 1884, 1885 in Togo, Kamerun, Deutsch, Südwestafrika, Deutsch-Ostafrika und Deutsch-Neuguinéer. Schutzgebiete wurden damals ausgerufen. 1899 gab es noch Südseegebiete Kiauchou und Deutsch-Samoa. 1683, also ihr bricht sie kurz aus ihrem eigenen enger gefassten historischen Begriff aus, aber 1683 besaß Brandenburg, die Kolonie Großfriedrichsburg, am Golf von Guinéa, heute Ghana. Die brandenburgische afrikanische Kompanie hat damals eine Rolle gespielt. Deutschland hat sich, wenn auch mit weniger Gebieten, trotzdem am transnationalen Sklavenhandel beteiligt. Also jetzt im Fernsehen zu stehen und zu sagen, wir werden so und so beachtet, weil wir keine bedeutende kolonialistische Geschichte haben. Nein, stimmt einfach nicht. Hier steht einfach die Geschichte, dem Gerede im Wege, und es wird einfach nicht reflektiert. Man muss halt immer dazu sagen, das Problem hier ist nicht, dass Christoph Häuskind vielleicht auch in seiner Rolle mal ein Geschichtsbuch nicht gelesen hat, sondern er redet in einer offiziellen Funktion zu einem Publikum, das sehr wohl anders darüber informiert ist. Und die denken sich dann auch ihren Teil. Also in der Richtung muss man das problematisieren. Gut, Rassismus ist nicht extremistisch, ist eine ihrer Zwischenüberschriften. Das ist ganz interessant, weil sie hier auch nochmal diesen Bogen spannt. Wir nutzen Rassismus immer als den schlimmsten Vorwurf. Und so, wie ich ja auch schon sagte, ich habe sie da in dieser Sendung gesehen und dachte mir, das ist aber eine sehr geruhsame Argumentation. Ja, der Rassismusvorwurf kann auch einfach mal eine Rassismusanmerkung sein, die einfach darüber informiert, dass man hier mit einer gewissen Semantik, gerade anderen Leuten vor den Kopf stößt, ohne es zu merken. Also dieses Buch befasst sich die ganze Zeit latent mit dieser Fragestellung, wie kriegen wir es denn eigentlich mal in die Leute rein? Nicht so sehr, um denen einen Vorwurf zu machen, um denen Geschichtsvergessenheit vorzuwerfen, sondern um ein besseres Gelingen auf dem Weg, wie ich jetzt sagen würde, zur globalen Schicksalsgemeinschaft zu führen. Denn Deutschland ist ein sehr wichtiges Land. Und da muss man einfach sagen, es geht hier darum, Katastrophen zu verhindern, Verständigung zu erwirken usw. Da kann man nicht einfach so und so damit vorgehen, sondern da sollte man sensibel auf Widersprüche und Widerstände reagieren, um dann einfach auch anders zu kommunizieren. Und sei es nur, um eine politische Kommunikation zu beschleunigen und sie nicht durch was auch immer dann an Hürden plötzlich im Raume stehen, wenn da solche Sachen gerade auf internationalem Parkett und so weiter. Sie geht auf die Staatsbürgerdebatte zu sprechen. Das hat sie auch jetzt noch mal gemacht, als sie da dem CSU-Mann einfach sagte, na ja, wenn Sie sagen, wir sollten ruhig auch mal strafrechtlich Zugriff auf die Staatsbürgerschaft nehmen. Also wenn jemand erst spät in seinem Leben eine deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft errungen hat, dann immer nur unter Vorbehalt, dass er sich hier auch artig verhält, so als ob wir Deutsche ausweisen, statt ins Gefängnis zu stecken, wenn da irgendwas ist und so. Es war auch jede die Frage, dieser Messerstecher war ja in Afghanen, in Mannheim. So, im Micky Beisenherz Podcast ist dann Armin Laschet zu Gast. Wird dann gefragt, ja, sollten wir den jetzt ausweisen? Warum sollten wir für den noch irgendwas bezahlen im Sinne von hier Gefängnis und so? Und Laschet dann so, ja, das ist mir eigentlich egal. Und ich denke mir so, wie, das ist dir eigentlich egal. Also wir haben doch jetzt, wir können doch nicht den Kontext ausblenden, dass so ein Typ, der in Deutschland Polizisten ersticht, droht in Afghanistan als Volksheld empfangen zu werden. Dass die Taliban einfach sagen, seht mal hier, die sind nicht mal in der Lage, ihre Gewaltprobleme vor Ort, sondern die schicken die noch zu uns. Und die kommen dann mit diesem Märtyrer-Label, sie haben dort vor Ort den Deutschen erstochen. Völliges Ausblenden von allem, also es ist wirklich erstaunlich. Meine Freundin hatte mir dann zwischendurch einen Text geschickt, weil sie wusste, dass ich hier an diesem Buch rumlasse. Deswegen bringe ich das nur mal ein, weil ich es wirklich interessant finde. Also am 25. Oktober 2021, während dieser ganzen Corona-Gestresse, kam ein Buch von Michel Ender mit dem Titel Der opportunistische Relativismus über eine Kultur des feigen Wegduckens, des alternativlosen Aussitzens und des sprachlosen Unterordnens zu diesen rassistischen Fragestellungen. Und da würde ich sagen, klingt sehr interessant, wäre auch so hautigen Zeug für uns. Aber dieser Gilda Sahebis Weg zu Sachen, wie wir uns Rassismus beibringen, dass das eigentlich, wir mal davon ausgehen, dass das undurchdacht und nicht mit Absicht passiert, dass hier nie jemand jemanden provozieren will.
Diese Latenz.
Genau, und dass wir deswegen so auch einfach die Derivation, hier liegt Rassismus vor, der uns vor funktionale Hürden stellt. Dass das vielleicht der bessere Weg ist. Also deswegen, es gibt ganz viele Rassismus-Bücher oder Bücher über Rassismus. Und ich würde sagen, hier haben wir es mit einem guten zu tun. Ein Punkt, der wirklich sehr wichtig ist. Wir haben den 7. Oktober. Steinmeier hält große Reden. Zum Beispiel, alle Menschen mit palästinensischen und arabischen Wurzeln in Deutschland werden von ihm angesprochen. Sie mögen sich doch mal von der Hamas nicht instrumentalisieren lassen. Sprechen sie für sich selbst, teilen sie dem Terror eine klare Absage. Da steckt dieser latente Rassismus drin, im Sinne von ihr, die Schicksalsgemeinschaft. Sie kontert das auch funktional, aber sie macht es auch mit einer etwas, finde ich, sehr zukräftigen, sehr verkürzten Frage, nämlich Anders Breivik erschießt auf dieser Insel Utoya 70 junge Sozialdemokraten. Wer hat uns deutsche Christen aufgerufen, uns davon zu distanzieren? Niemand. Weil sich jeder lächerlich machen würde. Warum macht sich Steinmeier nicht lächerlich, wenn er sowas macht? Ist doch bescheuert. Aber Habecks Video, dieses siebenminütige Video, wo dann alle schrieben, das ist der eigentliche Kanzler, während Scholz schweigt, Habeck und so. Ich habe dieses Video nie gesehen, aber hier der Wortlaut. In Auszügen. Die hier lebenden Muslime haben Anspruch auf Schutz vor rechtsextremer Gewalt. Zu Recht, sagt Habeck. Sie müssten sich, Zitat, klipp und klar von Antisemitismus distanzieren, um nicht ihren eigenen Anspruch auf Toleranz zu unterlaufen. Zitat Ende.
Also er knüpft das an eine Voraussetzung. Und das ist natürlich unmöglich.
Und sie fragt dann hier wieder, also man könnte das jetzt unendlich lange, aber sie macht ja das Buch, das ist ja nur eine Illustration für das Problem.
Also er knüpft die, die bekommen, sie können nur die Rechte genießen, unter der Bedingung das.
Genau, sie sich klipp und klar von Antisemitismus distanzieren. Jetzt ihre Frage, die ich natürlich super sympathisch finde, weil sie einfach auf das erste Level des Pragmatismus nach unten transferiert. Wo soll das Bekenntnis abgelegt werden? Per Instagram-Story? Also so wie Habeck auch.
Zum Beispiel.
Und muss man das dann immer parat haben, wenn man seinen Ausweis vorzeigt und die feststellen, ah, hier ist einer, der ein Bekenntnis noch ablegen muss? Und dann zeigt man das Video. Also wie sieht es pragmatisch aus?
Und ich finde ja schön, dass wir als Deutsche nicht-Muslimen von dieser Bekenntnispflicht offenbar befreit sind. Also für uns sind die Gesetze auf jeden Fall so da, wie sie gemeint sind. Wir müssen uns nicht nochmal bekennen. Aber wenn ich jetzt Muslim bin, dann muss ich nochmal ein Insta-Video aufnehmen.
Ich habe recht. Große Derivation, wir und die anderen. Wir sind befreit. Die anderen. Ach, die haben auch einen deutschen Pass? Der deutsche Pass ist nur etwas wert, wenn sie es mit einem Bekenntnis, das immer vorzeigbar ist, wie der Lichtbild, wie das Lichtbild, gehört dazu. Das ist wirklich sehr gut. Medien und Migration, nur ein ganz kurzes Ding. Sechs Seiten, wo ich mir denke, dann doch lieber ganz raus, weil es sich selbst versteht. Das hier, die Medien beim Thema Migration. Wie sie sagt, steigt Bügelhalter, der Politiker sind. Sie hat natürlich einen Kapitel über die Grünen. Rassismus bei progressiven Kräften. Mit der einfachen Frage, die Grünen befassen sich jetzt mit dem ein oder anderen Problem und argumentieren das auch. Sie fragt dann, warum machen wir nicht Parteien, die sich für Autos einsetzen, für alle Autounfälle verantwortlich? Also hier die Autos reinzubringen, finde ich schon so einen heimlichen Humor. Aber ja, warum kümmert sich Ricarda Lange gerade darum, dass die Grenzen geschützt werden vor illegalen Migranten? Weil wenn sie dann hier sind, könnten sie ja in zehn Jahren, das war ja auch die Zeit im Mannheim, einen Polizisten erstächen. Diese Bogenschläge sind genau diese Bogenschläge zwischen sie setzen sich für Autos ein, also 3000 Verkehrstote, erklären sie mir das jetzt mal. Also es ist sehr gut. Und jetzt kommt diese große Parante, die ist doch sehr aufschlussreich für uns alle. Zum einen sagt sie, für, Zitat, kleine Paschas, Horden, Sexmob, Ghettos, slawische Flut, Mehmetz, Ungeziefer, brauche ich keine AfD. Da habe ich einen deutschen Diskurs, auch ohne AfD. Also dieses, dafür brauche ich keine AfD. So, jetzt ist aber eine AfD da, und ihre Wähler auch. Und ich lese mal vor. Was also ist mit den 15-20% der Bevölkerung, die sich eine Diktatur wünschen, Ausländer hassen und die AfD wählen? Um deren Belange muss sich der Staat selbstverständlich genauso kümmern, wie um die aller Menschen. Nur eben nicht um ihre rassistischen Belange. Die wird der Staat nicht lösen können. Und wenn er sich auf den Kopf stellt, wenn der Staat alle Grenzen schließt, Menschen mit doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft den deutschen Pass wegnimmt, an Grenzen schießt, Sozialleistungen für Geflüchtete streicht, nichts davon wird diese Menschen, wird die AfD und deren Kernanhängerschaft besänftigen, in Anführungszeichen. Sie werden immer einen Schritt weiter gehen wollen. Also, was ist der Ausweg für die demokratischen Parteien, wie wir so schön sagen, aus diesem Strudel, wir bekämpfen rechtsradikale Parteien mit rechtsradikaler Politik und werden dadurch selber rechtsradikal. Wie ist der Ausweg? Man markiert klar rassistische und nicht rassistische Anliegen, kümmert sich um die richtigen Anliegen, und wenn jemand mit einem rassistischen Belang kommt, dann sagt man ihm, wir wollen uns nicht lieber um dein richtiges Anliegen kümmern, statt um dein rassistisches. Zack!
Sehr klar und sehr einleuchtend.
Ich stelle mir das ein bisschen vor, man hat eine Wahl, es werden Programme geschrieben, Wahlprogramme. Man hat Pflichtkapitel zur Rente, zur Wirtschaftspolitik, zur Bildung. Das sind unsere Treibpflichten. Und man schreibt einfach einen Kapitel zum Rassismus. Um mal eine klare Unterscheidung zu machen zwischen Politik und Rassismus. Denn die Bildungspolitik jetzt zu unterlaufen die ganze Zeit mit, ah, da hat jemand ein rassistisches Anliegen, ja, dann machen wir auf jeden Fall in Kindergarten Deutschkurse, damit die in der Grundschule einen reinen deutschen Unterricht machen können. Das ist rassistisch, also das ist einfach bescheuert. Deswegen das einfach aussatieren aus der Bildungspolitik. Ja, man spricht in der Schule Deutsch, aber das muss man nicht im Programm schreiben, das ist halt einfach mal so. Weil man hat eine Lehrerin und die kann eine Sprache und dann spricht sie mit den Kindern Deutsch. Und Kinder, die Nachholbedarf beim Thema Deutsch haben, betrifft auch deutsche Kinder, lernen halt vorher, die werden vorher diagnostiziert und getestet und dann findet halt eine ganz normale bis hin zu therapeutische Aufarbeitung des Deutschdefizits statt. Fertig. Bei einem Kind, egal woher, wenn es kognitiv im richtigen Entwicklungsstadium ist, ein halbes Jahr, fertig. Dann ist das Problem erledigt, man muss es halt organisieren. Aber da die ganze Zeit so einen Rassismus mitschleifen zu lassen, in jedem einzelnen Themengebiet.
Ja, da dachte ich jetzt, als ich die Wahlprogramme las, der Parteien, eigentlich wäre nur ehrlich, die hätten so eine, hätten noch ein weiteres Kapitel. Das bieten wir in puncto Rassismus an.
Ja, genau.
Aber dann wirklich schreiben sie, ja, also wir sind auch gegen zu viele, die nicht weiß sind. Und wir wollen es nicht ganz so übertreiben wie die AfD, aber ein bisschen sehen wir das auch so. Also man müsste so, das ist unser Angebot für die rassistischen Ressentiments, wie man irgendwie was hinschreibt für die Leute, die eine Klimatransformation wollen. Und das wäre in gewisser Weise ehrlich, ja.
Also nicht dieses FDP-Programm, wir machen für euch rassistische Politik, damit es nicht die Falschen tun. Es gibt richtigen und falschen Rassismus. Das ist doch totaler Quatsch. Also nennen sich dieses, also Gilda Sahebis scheint mir die primäre Ansprechpartnerin für diese Fragen, wie soll ich nun mal im Parteiprogramm schreiben, zu sein. Sehr gut, Spu.
Wir kommen zu dem Buch, unter Beobachtung, die Bestimmungen der liberalen Demokratie von Philipp Manow erschienen im Surkamp-Verlag. Dieses Buch ist von einem Politikwissenschaftler. Und ich möchte damit beginnen, dass ich dich frage.
Prüfungsrelevant, oder?
Ja, ob du ein Demokrat bist.
Natürlich.
Und bist du auch ein liberaler Demokrat?
Ja.
Ah, da wird es aber jetzt schon schwierig. Jaja, denn was soll denn eigentlich so eine liberale Demokratie sein? Precht verwendet das auch die ganze Zeit in seinem Buch, Liberale Demokratie? Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass du den Begriff liberale Demokratie in den 70er und auch in den 80er Jahren noch nicht verwendet hättest.
Also in den 70ern auf gar keinen Fall.
Aber auch wenn du älter gewesen wärst, hättest du den nicht verwendet. Er wurde nämlich nicht verwendet. Also man wird Stellen finden, wo schon mal jemand von der liberalen Demokratie spricht.
Ist damit einfach so freie Demokratie gemeint, dass man ein freiheitliches Leben will?
Das ist die große Frage, die sich Philip Manow stellt. Und ich hatte ja eben gesagt, dass ich eine Nachricht bekam von jemandem via Instagram, der sagte, ja wenn du jetzt für die Schuldenbremse plädierst, weil man sonst damit, wenn man sie abschafft, die Aufrüstung finanzieren könnte, dann hast du Angst vor der Demokratie. Und dann würde ich jetzt zurückgeben, genau, ich habe Angst vor der Demokratie, wie ihr alle Angst vor der Demokratie habt, nur auf anderen Ebenen.
Also.
Ich will es, nein, lass mich das erst mal ausführen. Die Schuldenbremse ist in die Verfassung geschrieben, um die Demokratie einzuengen. Dafür ist sie da. So. Jetzt sind wir gerade, also ich gehe jetzt mal von meiner Argumentation nochmal zurück, ich sage jetzt mal, wir beide sind dafür, wir schaffen die Schuldenbremse ab, um endlich die Kommunen zu entlasten und viele andere Dinge zu ermöglichen.
Klingt gut.
Damit wir das der Demokratie, dem demokratischen Willen wieder zurückgeben, was da verfassungsrechtlich eingeschnürt wurde. Jetzt könnte ich ja mal folgendes Szenario ausmalen. Die AfD steht davor, die absolute Mehrheit zu haben. Die Schuldenbremse ist noch in der Verfassung. Die Schuldenbremse verhindert, dass die AfD ihr Programm Remigration umsetzen kann, weil Remigration natürlich ein sehr teures Projekt sein wird. Sind wir dann noch für eine Abschaffung der Schuldenbremse? Natürlich nicht. Dann würden wir sagen, oh Gott sei Dank gibt es noch die Schuldenbremse, dass die das jetzt gerade nicht machen. Und das ist jetzt ein sehr konstruiertes Beispiel, Gäbi.
Sehr konstruiert.
Jetzt kommen wir aber zu den Beispielen aus der Realität. Wenn wir uns ansehen, woher dieser Begriff liberale Demokratie kommt, dann hängt er ganz eng damit zusammen, kann uns Manu ganz empirisch nachweisen, so wie du es eigentlich vorerst immer, dass dieser Eng damit zusammenhängt, dass man die Rolle der Verfassungsgerichte extrem aufgeladen hat. Beziehungsweise viele Länder haben erst ein wirksames Verfassungsgericht in den 80er, 90er Nuller Jahren bekommen. Das heißt, mit dem Verfassungsgericht kommt also überhaupt das Gerede von der liberalen Demokratie in Umlauf. Und man fragt sich, gibt es ja noch eine andere Demokratie? Ja, und man könnte jetzt also unterscheiden zwischen der liberalen Demokratie, die mit Verfassungsgerichten ganz stark operiert, wo sehr viel festgeschrieben ist, und mit der elektoralen Demokratie, wo also durch die Wahl, die Parteien sind in einem Konkurrenzweltnis zueinander, dann eine Mehrheit sich ergibt. Und diese Mehrheit hat aber dann auch wahnsinnig viele Möglichkeiten. Während wir ja jetzt gerade auf der Ebene Schuldenbremse sehen, die sind zwar gewählt, aber die Schuldenbremse hält sie jetzt von vielem ab.
So macht das ja die Schweiz zum Beispiel. Die hat gar nicht so einen Verfassungsregthof, sondern die fragt dann, warum wird das Volk so punktuell elektoral?
Wenn man das will, also grundsätzlich ist diese elektorale Demokratie, die gewesen, die wir hatten. Diese Aufwertung der Verfassungsgerichte ist eine Geschichte, die in den letzten 40 Jahren passiert. Und jetzt zeichnet Manu nach, dass also das Gerede von der liberalen Demokratie eines ist, das erst mit dem Ende der 80er, Anfang 90er Jahre entsteht. Sobald man aber sagt, ich bin ein liberaler Demokrat, hat man auch schon Feinde produziert. Und zwar will er Folgendes sagen. Hat es eigentlich vor, sagen wir 1990, Feinde der liberalen Demokratie gegeben? Die Frage mag überraschen oder irritieren und vielleicht meine Antwort auf sie noch mehr. Denn wie ich im Folgenden argumentieren möchte, sollte die Antwort lauten, nein, die hat es nicht gegeben. Und er bezieht sich da auf einen Essay aus den Nullerjahren. Der hatte den Titel, gab es vor dem ausgehenden 19. Jahrhundert perverse? Nee, gab es nicht, weil diese Diskussion, um was es sexuell pervers ist, erst dann in Gang gesetzt wurde. Das heißt, Perversion wurde damit erfunden, indem man festgelegt hat, was normal ist. Liberale Demokratien produzieren ihre Feinde, indem, sobald man die Demokratie koppelt an den Begriff liberal, sagt, ja, also ich meine die verfassungsrechtliche Demokratie mit besonderem Minderheitenschutz, mit diesem und jenem und mit den starken Institutionen. Und das produziert, so die These von Manu, natürlich Feinde, die sich nicht daran halten. Und das führt ihn dann zu den bösen Buben. Erstmal macht er die Historie nochmal und zeigt uns, in den 80er Jahren waren es interessanterweise die Konservativen in Frankreich, die versuchten, das Verfassungsgericht zu stärken, um die sozialistische Regierung von Mitterrand einzuschränken. Wenn sich alle so sehr auf die Verfassung berufen und jetzt sich darüber beklagen, dass Erdogan diese Verfassung beschneidet bzw. die Verfassungsgerichte anders besetzt bzw. deren Handlungsbefugnisse einschränkt, dann muss man sich auch darüber im Klaren sein, dass diese Verfassung, die jetzt bekämpft wird von Erdogan, schon immer meinte, dass Kurden nicht zu dieser Demokratie gehören und auch andere Parteien nicht dazugehören. Jetzt ist Erdogan auch kein Anhänger bekanntlich der Kurden. Aber wir sehen, dass also in dieser verfassungsrechtlichen Konstitution der Demokratie ganz viel im Argen liegt. Und wir hatten ja in dem Podcast diesen Clip von Christoph Möllers, der sagte, was ich an der AfD dann doch bewundernswert finde, ist, dass sie noch so an das Politische glaubt, dass sie glaubt, mit Politik was ändern zu können. Und ich sagte dann auch ja, es sind alle so defensiv. Und das liegt daran, dass die liberale Demokratie sehr stark darauf angelegt ist, Institutionen aufzubauen, die so fest sind, dass also durch Wählerwillen nicht mehr viel verändert werden kann. Und Leute wie Erdogan und Orban, deren Politik man nicht gut heißt, und das tut Manu natürlich auch nicht, agieren eigentlich aus der Idee heraus, dass sie nicht in dieser Weise davon beschränkt werden wollen. Beziehungsweise bauen sie das dann nach ihren Maßgaben wieder um. Aber das bedeutet natürlich, dass diese liberale Demokratiekonstruktion mit den Verfassungsgerichten eigentlich eine Angst ist vor der Wahl, vor dem demokratischen Willen. Und deswegen versucht man, diesen demokratischen Willen zu minimieren. Eigentlich ein Konzept, auf dem auch das der Schuldenbremse beruht. Insofern ist also diese Geschichte der liberalen Demokratie auch eine Geschichte der Beschneidung des demokratischen Willens. Und wenn wir ehrlich sind, haben wir in den letzten Jahren fast alle Wahlen immer nur so debattiert, dass wir hofften, dass die Wähler nicht was Falsches machen. Also wir haben selbst, wenn wir uns ehrlich befragen, eine Angst vor den Wählern entwickelt.
Ja, aber wir lehnen ja auch mit Gründen direkte Demokratie ab.
Das schon, aber wir haben auch ganz viele Institutionen so aufgebaut, inklusive EZB, die dafür sorgen, dass man dort politisch keinen Zugriff mehr hat. Und das sehen wir mal positiv, wenn dadurch in Orban gestoppt wird. Wir sehen es aber dann negativ, wenn wir sagen, wir hätten gerade gerne Geld für eine Transformation.
Ja, das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant im Kontext einer Diskussion, die ich gestern gehört habe. Denn Prechts dritter Grund, warum Staaten scheitern, und das hat er ja noch referiert aus der Literatur, Staaten können sich überfordern. Man hat irgendein Problem, man löst es, man hat ein Folgeproblem, man hat dafür keine Lösung, man baut eine neue Institution, alles wird komplizierter, alles wird teurer usw. Gestern war Paul Kirchhoff, der ehemalige Verfassungsrichter, der von Schröder damals als der Professor von Heidelberg diffamiert wurde usw., weil da so juristische Expertise im Raum steht, mit denen die CDU das Wahlvolk bedroht usw. 2005. Der war im Einspruch-Podcast von der FAZ, wo die juristischen Diskussionen führen, und hat dort die Idee vorgeschlagen, da der Europäische Gerichtshof in seiner Erfolgsgeschichte immer stärker zu werden, beschränkt werden muss, sollten jetzt die Staats- und Regierungschefs über den Europäischen Rat, der nicht auf Augenhöhe mit den Ministerräten und mit dem Parlament und so im Vertrag von Maastricht geregelt ist, der wie eine Verfassung funktioniert, auch wenn er nicht so heißt, dass diese Staats- und Regierungschefs eine Veto-Instanz schaffen, mit der sie den EUGH nochmal überflügeln können. Weil der EUGH ja die nationalstaatliche Richtersprechung überflügelt. Und da habe ich so gedacht, Leute, als Jurist findet man juristische Lösungen. Aber im Gesamtkontext ist das nicht klug.
Sehr gut.
Da nochmal so eine Instanz reinzubauen. Also das sind diese Überforderungen, die dann da stattfinden.
Es ist eine Machterweiterung für alles Verfassungsgerichtliche. Also das Juristische wird damit aber gleichzeitig politisiert. Das geht ja dann auch mit dazu.
Das war die exakt falsche Idee aus dem, was ich so herbeigefühlt habe, als ich das gehört habe.
Und entsteht aus einer Skepsis darüber, wie eigentlich Wähler abstimmen könnten. Samuel Huntington, der auch bei Precht vorkommt, der hat mal geschrieben, Theoretiker unterscheiden zwischen rationalistischen, utopischen und idealistischen Demokratiedefinitionen auf der einen und empirischen, institutionellen und prozeduralen Definitionen auf der anderen Seite und kam zu dem Schluss, dass nur Letztere über die analytische Präzision und die empirische Bezugspunkte verfügten, die das Konzept zu einem brauchbaren machten. Jetzt sagt Manow, Huntingtons eigene Definition im 20. Jahrhundert könne ein politisches Regime dann als demokratisch gelten, wenn die zentrale kollektiven Entscheidungsträger durch faire, ehrliche und regelmäßige Wahlen bestimmt werden, bei denen die Kandidaten frei um Stimmen konkurrieren und bei denen praktisch die gesamte erwachsene Bevölkerung wahlberechtigt ist. War deswegen auch unübersehbar schumpeterianisch, also Disruption durch Wahl, mit seiner Betonung des dynamischen Moments periodischer Wahlen. Heute ist das vollkommen anders. Jetzt sieht er sich die modernen Demokratie-Theoretiker an und vor allem sieht er sich zum Beispiel das VDEM-Projekt an und andere Projekte, die jetzt genaue Kriterien entwickelt haben. Messkriterien, mit denen man messen kann, ob wir es mit einer liberalen Demokratie zu tun haben. Und hier erscheint, schreibt Manu, Demokratie als ein in sich ruhendes, institutionalisierter Regeln und Verfahren, das also umso demokratischer gelten kann, je liberaler es ist. Wahlen wird offensichtlich keine sonderlich herausgehobene Bedeutung mehr zu gemessen. Vielmehr kommt es auf eine möglichst umfassende institutionelle Einhegung des elektoralen Moments an. Effektive Einschränkungen der Exekutive werden zu einem Gütesiegel der liberalen Demokratie. Möglichst niemand soll so regieren können, wie eine Mehrheit es will. Man kann jetzt lange darüber diskutieren, und meine Haltung ist da auch sehr widersprüchlich. Beispiel Schuldenbremse, inwieweit diese Einhegung des elektoralen Moments gut ist. Nur, dass da mit ein großes Problem einhergeht, sollte deutlich sein. Und er zeigt dann sehr gut auf, dass wir es eigentlich nicht mit einer Krise der Demokratie zu tun haben, sondern das liberale Projekt scheitert eigentlich immer wieder an sich selbst. Also dieses liberale Demokratiekritik, weil es diese ganzen Feinde produziert. Und weil es selbst die Demokratiedefinition vollkommen verschoben hat, indem jetzt neue Normen zum absoluten Standard erhoben werden, die früher nicht da sind. Was mir an diesem Buch fehlt, ist, dass er nicht darauf eingeht, inwieweit es dann doch verfassungsrechtlich einen Minderheitenschutz so garantiert geben müsste, dass keine Regierung, egal wer sie ist, ob Orban oder sonst wer, darauf mehr zugreifen kann. Denn natürlich ist es so, dass sich progressive Strömungen auf das Verfassungsgericht stützen, um zum Beispiel LGBT-Rechte weiterhin abzusichern, vor einem politischen Zugriff, der zwar demokratisch legitimiert ist, aber natürlich man aus der Geschichte auch weiß, dass also solche Art der Demokratie auch ins Totalitäre führen kann. Wir haben jedenfalls einen Punkt jetzt, wo Manu so weit ist zu fragen, wer schützt eigentlich die Politik vor dem Recht? Und das ist eine ganz heikle Diskussion. Und ich glaube, die wird viel zu wenig geführt. Und der geht jetzt hier, und das ist das Schöne, so provokant damit um, dass er sagt, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal mit Orban oder mit Erdogan, was die gemacht haben. Und im Prinzip agieren die nicht undemokratisch. Die sind ja gewählt, also Orban ist gewählt. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, aber der manipuliert auch so, aber der an sich ist ja schon gewählt. Und das bedeutet aber dann letztendlich, dass man auch damit leben müsste. Er bringt auch den Brexit, also vielleicht mal da etwas zu. Er zitiert dann die Zeit. Was tun, wenn die falschen gewinnen, fragt die Zeit. Er sagt, was tun, wenn die Populisten aus Unverständnis, ach so, dass jetzt Giovanni di Lorenzo, aus Unverständnis und Unzufriedenheit vieles zum Einsturz bringen, was über Jahrzehnte an gutem und bewahrenswerten aufgebaut wurde. Jetzt Mano, den Rat. Man könne ja noch juristisch korrigieren, was hier elektoral aus den Gleisen gesprungen ist. Denn der das Referendum sei schließlich lediglich eine Befragung, sein Ergebnis bindet die Regierung nicht, wird man als symptomatisch verstehen müssen. Auf dem Weg zur nachträglichen Korrektur des großen Kollektivirthums hält die Redaktion einen weiteren guten Rat parat. Dem britischen Volk müsse eine Gelegenheit zur tätigen Reue gegeben werden. Er sagt, wir müssen anerkennen, dass das eine Mehrheitsentscheidung war.
In Großbritannien bereut das auch bis heute keiner. Da gibt es diese Art von Reue, die man dann noch hofft.
Ja, und dann kann man sagen, vielleicht gefällt uns die Demokratie doch gar nicht so gut, wie wir uns die ganze Zeit weis gemacht haben. Jedenfalls würden wir sonst nicht laufend mit diesen Verfassungsgerichten ankommen. Er sagt, um das noch gerade zu zitieren, in Bezug auf Orban, die Empörung, die Orbans Satz von der illiberalen Demokratie auslöst, so hat er ja seine Demokratie bezeichnet, speist sich vornehmlich daraus, dass sich hier jemand eine zentrale Kategorie der Fremdbeobachtung aneignete und umwertete. Das Beispiel veranschaulicht, wie das Doing Political Things with Words sich nicht nur auf die politischen Akteure beschränkt, sondern die politischen Beobachter mit einschließt und wie beider Wortgebrauch im Wechselspiel steht. Dabei scheint es niemand als sonderlich problematisch wahrzunehmen, wie sehr Beobachtungssprache und politische Sprache deckungsgleich geworden sind. Es besteht anscheinend kein Bedürfnis mehr nach einer inkongruenten Perspektive, Niklas Luhmann, der Sozialwissenschaften, mit deren Hilfe die Gesellschaft tatsächlich etwas über sich selber und die Genese ihrer Konflikte lernen könnte, was sie nicht bereits vorher wusste. In Gesellschaften, in denen mittlerweile mehr als die Hälfte der entsprechenden Alterskohorten eine Universität besucht, dosen politische Identifikationsangebote im Gewande soziologischer Interpretationsangebote auf Nachfrage. Dabei gerät jedoch das, was mit dem Anspruch der Gesellschaftsanalyse auftritt, der neuen akademischen Mittelschicht, oft nur zur Projektbeschreibung. Und das ist also etwas, das in den Politikwissenschaften gerade wohl viel passiert. Also wir hatten gerade ein Buch über Kritik an den Demokratie-Theorien, die alle nicht mit der Wirklichkeit übereinstimmen. Hier geht es darum, dass diese neuen Messverfahren, dieser Positivismus, den es da jetzt gibt in der Politologie, dazu führt, dass man zum einen Feinde hat, dass diese Feinde sich auch schon diese Kategorien angeeignet haben, um Selbstbeschreibungen vorzunehmen. Und dass man eigentlich von der Politikwissenschaft auch nur ein Identifikationsangebot haben möchte, um ein besseres Selbstvertretnis zu bekommen. Und um sich dann auf die Schultern zu klopfen, dass man ja selbst wahnsinnig demokratisch ist. Er bringt das dann auch am Beispiel der Türkei vielleicht das noch ganz kurz, weil er dann auch aufzeigt, wie also Erdogan natürlich das für sich nutzt. Aber dass diese Verfassung eine doch sehr ambivalente Geschichte hat. Und die ist ja nicht einfach so liberal-demokratisch und jetzt kommt Erdogan, sondern auch in der Verfassung war ja schon was eingeschrieben, politische Ideologie und so weiter. Und wir sehen also im Allgemeinen an diesen extremen Fällen, dass es eine Justizialisierung politischer Konflikte gibt. Und wir dann aber zugleich eine Politisierung der Justiz erleben. Und all das führt dann damit, dass man nur noch von Schwellenwerten redet.
Also wann ist es noch, wann nicht mehr. Man hat auch sehr dafür gesorgt, dass man nachträgliche Erzählungen stark gemacht hat. Da sind wir eigentlich wieder bei den Derivationen, die... Pointing re-enactment. Ja, die Lanze uns zeigt, nämlich die Geschichtsschreibung der liberalen Demokratie möchte sich in die monumentalistische Historiografie der Menschenrechte einschreiben. Nachdem die Menschheit in der ersten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts in den Abgrund geschaut habe, so diese Erzählung, habe sie sich dazu entschlossen, politische Herrschaft an die Menschenrechte zu binden, sie auf ihren Schutz zu verpflichten. Und mit dieser Erzählung verbindet sich dann auch das sehr einseitige Geschichtsnarrativ vom Europa der Diktaturen, so als seien in der ersten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts ausnahmslos alle europäischen Demokratien gescheitert. Und das hätten sie aus eigener schmerzvoller Geschichte gelernt, warum man die Demokratie vor sich selber schützen müsse. Und dieser Lernerfolg verkörpere sich in der expansiven Sanktionierung der eigenen rechtlichen Grundlage. Das Credo lautet nun, die liberale Demokratie definiere sich durch den systematischen Bezug ihres Handelns auf diese Rechte, durch ihre Verteidigung und unterscheide sich genau in dieser Hinsicht von der nur elektoralen Demokratie. Und dabei sagt er, na ja, der Osten Europas hat eine völlig andere Geschichte. Und dem kann man damit nicht kommen. Und er sagt auch, dass mittlerweile viele Politologen dabei sind, diese Rede von der liberalen Demokratie immer weiter zurückzudatieren. Zum Teil auf das Jahr 1850, wo man sagt, selbst da hatten wir schon die liberale Demokratie. Und auch dieser Diskurs, dass man Demokratie und Menschenrecht zusammen verbindet, kann er einfach nachweisen an Debatten zum Beispiel in dem Deutschen Bundestag. Hier, ich zeig dir das mal kurz, diese Ausprägung. Wann beginnt man im Deutschen Bundestag von Menschenrechten zu reden? Nun, das ist mal so Ende der 50er Jahre. Und dann geht das wieder runter. Und dann nimmt das aber wieder stärker zu. Das heißt, man kann diese Dinge gar nicht ableiten von dem, was hier unter Liberaldemokratie verstanden wird. Und das führt eigentlich dann dazu, dass man sagen muss, die Demokratie wird unter Beobachtung gestellt. Und diese Beobachtung produziert aber selbst eine gewisse Form von Demokratie und Demokratieverständnis. Und damit steht die Wahl eigentlich immer unter so einem Kontrollvorbehalt. Und er kommt dann zu dem Schluss. Die Proliferation der Werte führt zur Proliferation der Feinde dieser Werte. Und damit sind wir an einem Punkt, bei dem Manu uns auch wieder, wie eigentlich Selk, schon verabschiedet und sagt, jetzt lebt mal damit. Seid nur nicht so verliebt in eure liberale Demokratie, denn ihr wollt den Wählerwillen auch gern beschneiden, wenn es euch hilft. Und in anderen Punkten seid ihr dann aber doch wieder für mehr Wählerwillen, wenn es jetzt gerade passt. Und wenn wir uns mal kritisch befragen, dann ist das so.
Also, da du den Selk jetzt nochmal reinbringst, ich würde ja sagen, du hast ja sechs Bücher abgefeiert, eine Abklärung im Sinne von, ich zeige euch, dass die Demokratie-Theorie dämmert, und zwar im Gleichschritt mit der Demokratie. Hier haben wir es ja mit einem Buch zu tun, das nicht dämmert. Also, die Theorie in diesem Buch scheint mir nicht sehr dämmend zu sein, sondern die zeigt uns, wie die Demokratie dämmert. Aber die Theorie scheint ja auf Augenhöhe mit dem Moment zu sein. Die sollte das Selk wieder ausklammern und sagen, es gibt durchaus Autoren, ich habe gerade nachgeguckt, er ist Professor in Siegen, scheint mir ein guter Ort zu sein, um Politikwissenschaft zu studieren. Da macht man um ganz schön viel Nonsens einen Bogen und klärt mal die richtigen Fragen.
Man muss hinzufügen, die Samano argumentiert, auch wenn er das da nicht transparent macht, Schmittianisch. Und er sagt natürlich, ja, Verfassungsgericht usw. alles gut und schön, aber das ist jetzt, weil man die Macht hat als Liberaldemokraten, das alles so festzuzurren, macht man das. Nicht aus irgendeinem Herren anliegen, sondern um die Macht zu haben und die Macht auch möglicherweise darüber zu behalten.
Auf Augenhöhe mit der Realität?
Sind wir auf Augenhöhe mit der Realität? Müssen uns selbst befragen, haben wir Angst vor dem Wählerwillen? Wir stellen uns ja jetzt gerade auch die Frage in Bezug auf den Osten. Sollte man noch mal schnell was in die Landesverfassung reinschreiben, bevor die AfD da was abräumen kann? Das sind alles Überlegungen, bei denen man sagen muss, ja, man hat offenbar auch Angst vor der Demokratie. Insofern ist ein bloßes Abfeiern von liberaler Demokratie eher nicht angebracht. Also ich würde dieses Buch tatsächlich als eine gute Grundlage für alle weiteren Diskussionen empfehlen.
Es gab kürzlich eine SWR2-Forum-Diskussion zum Thema Umgang mit der AfD. Sollte man sie verbieten, ja oder nein. Unter anderem Prantl, ehemals Süddeutscher oder vielleicht immer noch, aber auch Jurist mit anderen. Ganz großer Streit darüber, wie man das jetzt macht. Also ist jetzt die wehrhafte Demokratie wehrhaft, weil sie auch juristische Wege geht und so? Erst durch so eine Aufklärung, wie er sie jetzt dargeboten hat, oder du durch deinen Referat, wird mir klar, dieses ganze Gespräch kann man runterdampfen auf, dann lösen wir es elektoral oder juristisch. Und wenn dann Prantl sagt, naja, aber die wehrhafte Demokratie, und wir sagen, aber die Demokratie ist der Wählerwille, nein, da gibt es eine rote Linie. Wenn wir es über ein Parteienverbot regeln, dann haben wir es nicht elektoral geregelt. Kann man machen, kann auch inbegriffen sein, die Demokratie ist halt wehrhaft, aber diese Linie ist dann trotzdem überschritten. Deshalb ja auch das Verfassungsgericht sich so rote Linien ausgedacht hat, wie diese Potenzialität. Das gab es ja vorher gar nicht im Gesetz. Sondern, ne, die NPD ist nicht wichtig genug. Und jetzt, ja, die AfD ist zu wichtig. Wir können nicht so elektoral den Leuten vor den Kopf stoßen. Also sie sind ja in Teufelsküche gekommen, in Praxis, mit genau solchen undeskutierten Fragen. Sehr gut, es ist ein bisschen wie Francis Fukuyama sagt, es ist ein ganz schmaler Grad zwischen Checks and Balances und Vitocracy. Am Ende stehen sich alle nur noch auf den Füßen. In Amerika natürlich besonders interessant. Esra Klein hat jetzt in seinem jüngsten Podcast die Frage aufgeworfen mit seinem Diskussionspartner, ob man das denn noch eingehegt kriegt in Amerika. Jetzt wo immer nicht der nächste Präsident, sondern das überlebende Demokratie gewählt wird. Und er beginnt das Gespräch, und da hab ich auch gedacht, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, mit Auszügen aus George Washingtons Amtsübergabe-Rede. Also er verlässt das Präsidentenamt, der erste Präsident, und er formuliert wortwörtlich, was heute die Herausforderung ist. Dass sich unversöhnliche zwei Blöcke gegenüberstehen, die immer mit diesem 50 plus X einander rangeln und dem anderen keine Luft zum Atmen mehr lassen wollen. Und das ist im Grunde die Situation. Also fand ich irgendwie, manche Leute, die mal über Sachen nachdenken, weil sie sie aus Praxis erfahren haben und dann projizieren, sind ganz schön nah dran, komme was wolle. Und sei es 250 Jahre Entwicklungsgeschichte, technischer Fortschritt, was auch immer, bringt alles nichts. Am Ende sind es immer diese gleichen Fragen. Das Berlin Summit hat eine Declaration hervorgebracht, unterschrieben von, also die Liste ist offen, wir können uns auch noch eintragen. Wir stehen dann mit Danny Rodrik, keine Ahnung, wer das ist, Branko Milanovic, Mariana Mazzucato, also macht mich natürlich wieder lächerlich, weil ich ihre Werke nicht kenne, aber du bist da großer Fan.
Adam Tooth, ich bin natürlich bei sie gut großer Fan, aber die Bücher sind schon lesenswert. Das Kapital des Staates ist schon ein sehr wichtiges Buch.
Gut, sowas gilt ja auch für Adam Tooth, Thomas Piketty, Jens Südekom, Isabel Weber, Mark Blythe, Maja Göpel und so weiter und so fort. Die haben also eine Deklaration unterschrieben, die im Wortlaut ungefähr so, und da muss man sich zum muntern machen, muntern, sonst geht das nicht. Die liberale Demokratie, oder plural, also die liberalen Demokratien sehen sich heute mit einer Welle des Misstrauens der Bevölkerung in ihrer Fähigkeit konfrontiert, der Mehrheit ihrer Bürger zu dienen und die zahlreichen Krisen zu lösen, die blablabla unsere Zukunft, blablabla Welt, gefährlicher populistischer Politik und so. Wut wird ausgenutzt, wir haben einen Klimawandel vor den Augen, Ursachen für den Unmut der Menschen soll jetzt an der Wurzel gepackt werden. Also es ist im Grunde der Mindestnonsens, auf dem man sich so einigen kann von eigentlich sehr klugen Leuten.
Ja, als ich das las, dachte ich, das klingt wie eine Deklaration von allen Staatsoberhäuptern, was für die Verbesserung aller möglichen Dinge zu tun. Aber da niemand irgendein Eingeständnis machen wollte, musste man es so vage formulieren. Und hier ist es aber so, dass keine Staatsoberhäupter, sondern Ökonomen und andere Wissenschaftler miteinander da sitzen. Die könnten ja über die Stränge schlagen, wäre ja gar kein Problem, die müssen das nicht morgen ihrem Wähler verklickern.
Also ich reihe nur mal substantiv voneinander. Kontrollverlust, Lebensunterhalt, Gefühl, Machtlosigkeit, Schock, Globalisierung, technologischer Wandel, Jahrzehnte lang, Globalisierung, Vertrauen, Selbstregulierung, Märkte, Austerität, bla bla bla. Das war allerdings nur die Präampel, jetzt kommt ja erst die Liste.
Mit Manu könnten wir auch sagen, naja, ihr wollt die Schuldenbremse abschaffen, das ist aber nicht liberal demokratisch.
Ja, also ich gehe mal die Liste pro Listenpunkt einfach nur im Schlagwort. Zu viel wirtschaftliche Effizienz, neue Industrien müssen gefördert werden, Schutz der Schwachen, Vererbung und Finanzmarktautomatismen ein bisschen abschöpfen, Anreize zur Reduzierung von Kohlenstoffemissionen, selbstzerstörerische Maßnahmen vermeiden, also auf der Ebene. Ich habe mir dann gedacht, okay, das ist ein wichtiges Dokument, denn es sind unsere Lieblingsautoren, ich bringe es mit in den Salon, aber ich frage mich, geht das nicht auch besser? Ich frage also Claude, fasse mir das Programm zusammen, hat er gemacht, übersetze es mir auf Deutsch, hat er gemacht, habe ich gerade gelesen. So, siehst du Wege, um die Ziele, die im Text formuliert werden, zu erreichen? War mein Problem. Es gibt sicherlich Ansätze und Maßnahmen, nur ich habe ihm nicht gesagt, denkt mal klüger, sondern nur ziel. Also auf dieser Basis, ja ja, Industriepolitik neu ausrichten, Globalisierung fairer gestalten, Ungleichheit bekämpfen, effektive Klimapolitik, Innovationspolitik, Stärkung von multiliteralen Kooperationen und mehr Bürgerbeteiligung. Ja, das ist eine schöne Übersetzung der Liste von einer Sprache in die nächste Bullshit-Sprache. Nenne mir Gründe, warum diese Wege in der Politik nicht gegangen werden. Jetzt wird es also langsam interessant. Es gibt verschiedene Gründe, warum diese Wege in der Politik oft nicht konsequent beschritten werden. Erstens, kurzfristiges Denken. Er formuliert das dann immer aus. Ich bleibe mal bei der… Zweitens, Interessen, Konflikte. Drittens, ideologische Differenzen. Viertens, Komplexität und Unsicherheit. Fünftens, internationale Koordination. Es wird also kompliziert. Sechstens, Finanzierungsfragen. Zu wenig Geld. Siebtens, politische Kulturen. Können wir jetzt fragen, kann man da nicht was drehen? Das ist doch alles nur Semantik. Und achtens, Dreckheit des Systems. So, mein nächster Punkt. Nenne mir eine konkrete politische Maßnahme, die zu mehr Vertrauen bei den Wählern führen würde.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Das ist ja das Ziel dieses Textes. Vertrauen der Wähler. Inhaltlich waren die ja völlig offen. Denen ging es ja um das Misstrauen in diesen liberalen Demokratien, das Ausbeuten der Wut. So, jetzt Claude's Antwort. Eine konkrete politische Maßnahme, die das Vertrauen der Wähler stärken könnte, wäre eine signifikante Investition in bezahlbaren Wohnraum.
Wirklich?
Ich lese weiter. Gekoppelt mit einer Reform des Mietrechts. Hier ein möglicher Ansatz. Das war der Wortlaut. Also, es sind sechs Punkte in der Liste. Ich trage verkürzt vor. Ein mehrjähriges Programm zum Bau neuer Sozialwohnungen. Und preisgedämpfte Mietwohnungen mit Mitteln des Bundeshaushalts, die dann ihrerseits Anreize für private Investoren schaffen. Zweitens. Soziale Wohnraumförderung. Fördermittel für den sozialen Wohnenbau werden deutlich aufgestockt. Gleichzeitig werden die Einkommensgrenzen für den Bezug solcher Wohnungen moderat angehoben. Okay, Mietpreisbremse. Die Mietpreisbremse wird verschärft, konsequent angewandt. Mieterschutz. Der Kündigungsschutz für Mieter wird verbessert. Eigenbedarfskündigungen werden enger gefasst. Bei Sanierung und Umwandlung in Eigentumswohnungen gibt es einen Schutz vor Verdrängung. Baulandmobilisierung. Bund, Länder und Kommunen aktivieren vermehrt eigene Grundstücke für bezahlbaren Wohnraum und wir machen eine Grundsteuerreform oder wir ermutigen zu einer Grundsteuerreform, sagt er, um hier Anreize für Baulandbereitstellung. Transparenz und Beteiligung. Die Vergabe von Fördermitteln und Bauaufträgen wäre Erfolg Transparenz. Bei größeren Projekten werden die Bürger frühzeitig informiert und einbezogen. Okay, diese Maßnahmen würden zeigen, dass die Politik die Sorgen der Menschen vor steigenden Mieten und Wohnraumknappheit ernst nimmt und aktiv gegensteuert. Es verbindet sozialen Ausgleich mit der Schaffung neuen Wohnraums ohne einseitig in Eigentumsrechte einzugreifen. Das wäre ein starkes Signal, dass die Politik handelt und zwar im Sinne Lebensverhältnisse der Menschen konkret verbessern. Das wäre eine Grundlage, um verlorenes Vertrauen zurückzugewinnen. Da denke ich mir, das ist klug. Dass wir hier vorher über Wohnraum gesprochen haben im Podcast, weiß Claude nicht. Es ist einfach nur, nennen wir ein Thema, bei dem und so weiter kommt Wohnraum. So, warum hast du dir das Wohnen herausgesucht und kein anderes Thema? Das habe ich dann gefragt. Liste. Erstens, breite Betroffenheit, zweitens, also Schicksalsgemeinschaft, zweitens, soziale Präsenz. Wir wollen ja, drittens, Sichtbarkeit. Der Staat würde wieder sichtbar als handelnder Akteur, der sich für das mithält. Viertens, Symbolkraft und jetzt fünftens, Machbarkeit. Anders als manche anderen Herausforderungen, etwa der Klimawandel, lässt sich die Wohnungsfrage primär auf nationaler Ebene angehen. Erfolge sind nicht zwingend von komplexen internationalen Verhandlungen abhängig. Das erleichtert ein beherztes Handeln. Ja, schreibt Claude. Mit welchem Widerstand der Vermieter denn? Ich habe jetzt mal gedacht, ich lasse es bei ganz kurzen Promts, aber versuche ein bisschen Signalworte unterzubringen. Also ich habe dann Claude gefragt, mit welchem Widerstand der Vermietenden Klasse wäre denn zu rechnen? So, mit erheblichem Widerstand, Eingriff ins Eigentum, Renditeverluste, Bürokratie und Kosten, Gefährdung privater Kleinvermieter, Ruf nach Ausgleich, Effekte für die Wirtschaft und so weiter, Zweckentfremdung und wie könnten die Betroffenen, frage ich dann, die sich von der Politik im Stich gelassen fühlen und die Vermieter, in deren Rechte hier eingegriffen würde, ins gleiche Boot geholt werden? Da wieder so eine Liste gemacht. Sozialer Zusammenhalt als gemeinsames Ziel, langfristige Planungssicherheit, Kooperation, statt Konfrontation positive Anreize und so weiter. Ich frage ihn dann, mit besonderem Fokus auf die ökonomische Überlastung der Mieter und dem Gewinnstreben der Vermieter, wie sollte man den politischen Diskurs inhaltlich so gestalten, dass beide Seiten von den Veränderungen profitieren? Nenne mir konkrete Argumente in Diskussionen mit den Vermietern. Claude hat das dann richtig verstanden, hat mir immer so Punkte gemacht, die am Ende mit einem Zitat im Wortlaut die Diskussion gestalten können, ich lese also immer nur die Zitate am Ende vor. Nur ein Mieter, der langfristig in seiner Wohnung bleiben kann, ist für Sie als Vermieter ein verlässlicher Partner. Das ist nicht schlecht. Wenn Sie als Vermieter bezahlbare Miete anbieten, profitieren Sie im Gegenzug von öffentlicher Förderung, die Ihre Rendite langfristig sichert. Diese Verknüpfung, also hier geht es darum, Geld zu mobilisieren, der Staat fördert die besonders, und zwar auch langfristig, die eine ordentliche Miete anbieten. Das war mal so in der Wohngemeinnützigkeit. Steuerersparnis, aber dafür Sicherheit für die Vermieter. Das behalten wir besonders im Hinterkopf, denn wir wollen jetzt gleich koppeln mit politischen Aussagen von gestern. Drittens, mit einer Politik des Interessensausgleichs zwischen Mietern und Vermietern gewinnen sie mehr Planungssicherheit für ihre Immobiliengeschäfte. So, jetzt hat er viertens. Demografie und Wettbewerbsfähigkeit. Ich lese mal in Länge vor, was er hier geschrieben hat. In manchen Regionen werden aufgrund des demografischen Wandels perspektivisch Leerstände drohen. Bezahlbare attraktive Wohnungen sind hier von Vorteil, um jüngere Mieter anzuziehen. Das sichert die Zukunftsfähigkeit des Immobilienbestands. Auch Unternehmen siedeln sich eher an, wo ihre Beschäftigten gut und bezahlbar wohnen können. Das Argument, mit einem ausgewogenen Mietniveau investieren sie als Vermieter auch in die Zukunft ihres Standorts. Das ist natürlich ein super wichtiger Punkt. Das wird ja in Frankfurt gerade versucht. Große Frankfurter Bogen. Alle Kommunen, die in S-Bahn 30 Minuten Reichweite zum Hauptbahnhof erreichbar sind, werden gezielt gefördert. Was natürlich dazu führt, dass auch Unternehmen dann sagen, naja, dann gehe ich natürlich nach Eschborn. Da finde ich schon so eine Industrielandschaft, so ein bisschen diese neue Technik- und Finanzwelt-Sache. Und wenn da noch mehr junge Leute wohnen, ist ja viel attraktiver als in Frankfurt, wo die alten Leute hier in den Wohnungen und so durch diese Trägheit da im System. Außerdem, indem sie als Vermieter bezahlbaren Wohnraum bieten, zeigen sie gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Das Engagement findet öffentliche Anerkennung. Ich finde, die haben schon genug öffentliche Anerkennung und Termine der Politik, aber kann man natürlich noch mal eine Feierstunde für die machen. Und eine soziale Wohnungspolitik wartet benachteiligte Quartiere auf und damit langfristig auch ihre dortige Immobilie. Ich habe dann gedacht, ok, wenn wir jetzt beim Thema Wohnen sind, gebe ich Claude einen Transkript von unserem ganzen Podcast. Hab dann dazu geschrieben, in diesem Transkript wird auch über das Wohnen und die Wohnenpolitik, Wohnbaupolitik, gesprochen. Beziehe dich auf den Text und schreibe mir konkrete Talking Points für Diskussionen auf. Das war für mich nochmal, kriegt er die richtigen Zahlen raus. Ja, dann Punkt eins, der Wohnungsbau befindet sich im freien Fall. Investitionen der Wohnungsbauunternehmen sind um 50 Prozent eingebrochen. Es droht ein Abgleiten in abgebaute Kapazitäten mit maximal 200.000 gebauten Wohnungen pro Jahr. Also hat er richtig verstanden. 9,5 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland leben derzeit in überbelegten Wohnungen. In nur drei Jahren ist diese Zahl um eine Million gestiegen. Also hat er auch richtig gesehen. Dann in Hamburg sind die Projektbeginne der Wohnungsbauunternehmen um 80 Prozent zurückgegangen. Er hat also ganz am Ende diese kleine Proante nochmal auf Platz drei hochgeholt, um da einfach die Wichtigkeit zu betonen. Der Wohnungsbau ist extrem wichtig für die Beschäftigten und Steuereinnahmen. Er generiert 6,5 Millionen Arbeitsplätze direkt und indirekt sowie 140 Milliarden Steuern. Das sind 17 Prozent des Steueraufkommens. Also das ist eine Art von Zusammenfassung, die ist wirklich beeindruckend. Ich muss sagen, er hat genau den Punkt uns rausgesucht. Punkt 5. Die Bauministerin Geivitz sieht den Staaten nicht in der Pflicht, in private Mietverhältnisse einzugreifen, selbst wenn Gesetze gebrochen werden. Das ist eine Bankrotterklärung für den Mieterschutz. Also, ja, klar, versteht ihr wirklich, worum es geht, ne? Sechstens, in den Ballungsräumen...
Ich bin sehr beeindruckt, Stefan.
In den Ballungsräumen ist der Neubau um den Faktor 20 niedriger als der Bedarf. Auf eine freie Wohnung kommen teils 400 Bewerber. Das hatte ich ja so als Gaudi immer reingebracht, die Zahl. Familien suchen jahrelang erfolglos nach bezahlbaren größeren Wohnungen. Siebtens, auch das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, die hohen Baukosten von 5000 Euro des Quadratmeter erfordern riesige Subventionen von 2900 Euro Subvention pro Quadratmeter. Also auch die Zahl hat ordentlich gut rausgefunden. Also ich kann mir wirklich einfach mal so einen ganzen Wohnungsbautag reinschmeißen und sagen, gib mir jetzt mal die Talking Points von Havik oder sowas. Also wirklich erstaunlich, wie weit man dann doch kommt, auch für so Podcast-Produktion. Achtens, wir brauchen eine massive Offensive für den Wohnungsbau und bezahlbare Mieten. Ein weiter so führt zu dramatischen Versorgungsengpässen. Die Politik muss dringend umsteuern und den Wohnen höchste Priorität geben. So, und jetzt kommt die Pointe. Ich habe dann Claude gesagt, schreibe mir auf Grundlage dieser Zahlen, die Claude gerade aus dem Transkript ausgesucht hat, fünf Argumente, die Politik und Eigentümer sofort überzeugen, jetzt zu handeln. Ich lese vor. Und das ist jetzt, finde ich, dann die bessere Berlin Declaration und so weiter für. Und darum geht es, Vertrauen wieder zurück in die Politik. Also, er macht mir fünf Punkte. Wohnraummangel als soziale Zeitbombe. Mit 9,5 Millionen Menschen in überlegten Wohnungen und 1 Million Zuwachs, in nur drei Jahren steuern wir auf eine soziale Katastrophe zu. Fehlender bezahlbarer Wohnraum führt zu Deprivation, Krankheit und Perspektivlosigkeit, ein Nährboden für die gesellschaftlichen Spannungen und politische Radikalisierung. Hier muss die Politik gegensteuern, um den sozialen Frieden zu sichern. Zweitens, Wohnungsbau als Konjunkturmotor. 6,5 Millionen Arbeitsplätze und 140 Milliarden Euro Steuereinnahmen hängen am Wohnungsbau. Ein Einbruch um 50 Prozent wie aktuell beschädigt die gesamte Volkswirtschaft nachhaltig. Mit jedem nicht gebauten Wohnraum gehen Arbeitsplätze, Kaufkraft und Steuereinnahmen verloren. Eine Offensive für den Wohnungsbau hilft, Wirtschaftskrisen abzufedern. Drittens, staatliche Verantwortung für Mieterschutz. Wenn selbst bei Gesetzesverstößen der Staat nicht in private Mietverhältnisse eingreift, ist der Mieterschutz nur Makulatur. Bezahlbarer Wohnraum ist Teil der Daseinsvorsorge und Staatsziel. Die Politik darf sich hier nicht aus der Verantwortung delen. Es braucht effektive Kontrollen und Sanktionen bei Missbrauch. Viertens, Rendite mit Verantwortung. Wohnraum darf nicht zur reinen Spekulationsmasse verkommen. Der extreme Mangel mit Faktor 20 unter Neubaubedarf ermöglicht exorbitante Renditen auf Kosten der Mieter. Statt Wohnungen leer stehen zu lassen oder Luxussanierung zu investieren, müssen Eigentümer in bezahlbaren Wohnraum investieren. Dafür braucht es Anreize und klare Vorgaben. Also sagt da keiner, dass es billig wird. Fünftens, heute nicht bauen kostet die Zukunft. Das ist ja Werbespruch, da kannst du direkt aufs Plakat drucken. Beim Finanzministerium mal wieder so ein 15 Jahre irgendwas. 15 Jahre weggucken beim Wohnungsmarkt. Heute nicht bauen kostet die Zukunft. Um die heutigen Baukosten von 5000 Euro pro Quadratmeter auf bezahlbares Niveau zu subventionieren, bräuchte es 2900 Euro Förderung. Das übersteigt kurzfristig alle Budgets, verschärft aber nur die Mangelspirale. Auch hier wieder ein Wort, das ich nicht kannte. Wenn wir heute nicht bauen, explodieren die Kosten künftig noch mehr. Daher müssen jetzt alle Hebel in Bewegung für maximal Neubau, auch mit unkonventionellen Maßnahmen, fehlt irgendwie ein Verb, alle Hebel gedingst werden, sonst drohen düstere Wohnungsmärkte auf Jahrzehnte. Das ist meine Deklaration. So, und das ist jetzt, Stefan sitzt in seinem Büro, ist unzufrieden mit dem, was da so herbeifabuliert wird und lässt sich innerhalb von zehn Minuten so was herbeiprompten. Ich war ja nur verantwortlich für die kleinen Promps. Mit Absicht kurz, den Rest hat ja Claude selber gemacht. Und jetzt, das schicktest du mir gestern, ein Tweet von Clara Geivitz. Die neue Wohngemeinnützigkeit kommt. Davon profitieren alle. Wir entlasten soziale Wohnungsunternehmen, die günstige Mieten haben. Den Mieterinnen und Mietern geben wir die Sicherheit, dass ihre Miete dauerhaft bezahlbar bleibt. Sie bezieht sich auf einen Tweet ihres Ministeriums. Die Naziri tweetet, der Original-Tweet des Ministeriums lautet, Die Wohngemeinnützigkeit ist wieder da. Soziale Unternehmen, Vereine und Stiftungen können künftig vergünstigten Wohnraum bereitstellen und dabei von umfassenden Steuererleichterungen profitieren. Das ist im Grunde das, was mir Claude gesagt hat. Ich habe dafür kein Bauministerium gebraucht. Ich habe dafür auch nicht 15 Jahre gebraucht. Ich musste dafür nicht in ein Amt gewählt werden für diese Expertise. Ich habe keinen wissenschaftlichen Dienst im Bundestag beauftragt. Ich habe gar nichts gemacht. Ich habe Claude nicht mal ein Thema gegeben. Ich habe Claude einfach nur gesagt, die kümmern sich hier um sozialen Zusammenhalt, gib mir mal ein Thema, gib mir Talking Points, mach mir ein politisches Programm, fertig. Das ist Game-Changer.
Stefan, du siehst mich begeistert. Es ist sehr beeindruckend und ich muss sagen, dass ich auch diese Deklaration da gelesen hatte und dachte, ja, aber da steht ja genau nichts drin, außer dass man hier und da was tun müsste und man bleibt nur im nebulösen fabulieren. Und hier hat man es dann ganz konkret gemacht. Und man kann es auch nur mit einer Sache, die man konkret macht, überhaupt ja was bewegen, weil sonst kannst du den Text auch einfach sein lassen.
Genau.
Also wir können uns jetzt auch gleich mal auf die Straße stellen und sagen, wir müssen mal was fürs Klima tun. Da ist auch kein Mitgeholfen. Also das war völliger Unsinn, so ein Kram. Insofern, ja, die KI könnte uns also intelligenter machen. Könnte. Könnte. Wir gehen nach Schnellroder zu den ganz Rechten, nämlich zu den Leuten, die KRA groß gemacht haben, ihnen unterstützen. Götz Kubitschek, der Verleger und Hans Dampf in allen rechten Gassen, hat einen Text geschrieben mit dem Titel KRA Europa und ein deutscher Standpunkt. Erschienen ist er auf diesem Schnellroder Blog. Und er fragt sich, was steckt denn eigentlich dahinter, dass man den KRA jetzt so abserviert? Es ist, sagt er, der Kampf um die geostrategische Ausrichtung Europas. Vor allem der Teile Europas, die aufgrund Geschichte, ökonomischen Bedingungen und geografischer Lage ein gutes Auskommen mit Russland brauchen und eingehen würden, wäre es ihnen gestattet. Der Ausschluss der gesamten AfD-Delegation aus der ID-Fraktion im EU-Parlament erfolgte auf Betreiben Marine Le Penz und ist eine Entscheidung für ein transatlantisches und gegen ein mitteleuropäisches Europakonzept. Das ist also die Konfliktlinie, die Kubitschek da ausmacht. Und ich halte ihn für einen intelligenten Strategen. Und ich glaube, dass er recht hat mit seiner Einschätzung, warum jetzt gerade Krah auch von seiner eigenen Partei so angegriffen wird. Und er bringt Beispiele. Es gab die CPAC-Konferenz. Die wurde dieses Jahr in Budapest auf Einladung von Viktor Orban ausgerichtet. Das ist so eine der Konferenzen, die wichtigste Konferenz, wo sich all die Rechten treffen. Man kann jetzt aber an dieser Konferenz was beobachten. Wer von Maximilian Krah spricht, schreibt Kubitschek, darf von dieser Konferenz nicht schweigen, denn Frankreich und Deutschland waren nicht eingeladen. Wie kann das sein?
Frankreich und Deutschland.
Ja, nicht eingeladen. Dann heißt es hier, die CPAC vertritt pro-amerikanische, antirussische, antichinesische Position. Sie vertritt den Anspruch der einzigen Weltmacht und arbeitet an der Einbindung Europas und Südamerikas in einen Machtblock gegen jene aufstrebende Blöcke, die eine multipolare Weltordnung nicht nur anstreben, sondern mit Sicherheit herbeiführen werden, Russland und China. In Europa– und das hat mich jetzt total verblüfft– in Europa ist Viktor Orbán's Ungarn der Knotenpunkt, von dem aus den konservativen, national bewussten Kräften Eigenständigkeit und Unabhängigkeit zwischen den Blöcken unmöglich gemacht werden soll. Und ich hatte ja– und du sicherlich auch– Orbán als den Russland-Versteher im Kopf, der auch deswegen immer mal wieder auf die Finger geklopft bekommt. Es ist aber keineswegs so, sagt zumindest Kubitschek, Orbán versammelt dort die Leute. Es waren Sprecher aus europäischen Ländern da, aber auch Rechte aus den USA, aus Israel. Dann Italien war natürlich vertreten mit Fratelli d'Italia. Gerd Wilders war dort. Und es gab nur einen einzigen Deutschen, der dort auftrat, und das war Hans-Georg Maaßen, der aber auch ja natürlich eher transatlantisch ist, wenn man überhaupt diese Kategorie bedienen will. Man kann es so sagen, schreibt Kubitschek, Orban versammelte in Budapest diejenigen konservativen Kräfte aus Europa, die in der kommenden Legislatur eine gemeinsame Fraktion bilden könnten, eine tatsächlich große, umfassende, mächtige Fraktion. Frankreichs Opposition wiederum würde sich beteiligen dürfen, wenn sie zuvor mit der AfD bräche. Das hat Le Pen nun getan. Also sein Blick auf diesen ganzen Konflikt ist ein geopolitischer. Wir haben ja schon mal das angesprochen, dass diese Melonisierung Europas stattfindet. Und man sieht, auf diesem Wege kann man also erfolgreich sein, bekommt die Konservativen auf seine Seite, kann viel mitreden. Auch dann in Washington wird man empfangen. Wie kommt man dorthin? Ja, mit der AfD gibt es da gar keinen Weg und schon gar nicht, wenn man wie Gra ist. Und das können wir jetzt gerade erleben. Das heißt also, diese Art der rechten Politik wird jetzt gerade abgestraft, während eine andere eine extreme Aufwertung erfährt. Nämlich die Meloni-Politik, bei der sich vielleicht auch Weidel anschließen würde. Er hat dann natürlich so Ideen, wie das eigentlich sein sollte. Also, dass man jetzt die deutschen Interessen stärkt. Und er sagt dann, man hat natürlich die Möglichkeit, dem Druck nachzugeben, zum deutschen Vertreter der US-Interessen zu werden, deutsche Interessen an die zweite Stelle zu setzen, den weiteren Abstieg akzeptieren. Und er wünscht sich natürlich von seinem, also von dem Graflügel in der AfD, dass sie also ihrer Linie treu bleiben. Und er nennt das dann, sagt dann, dass sie weiterhin Abstand nehmen von dem anti-deutschen Projekt. Und der anti-deutsche ist ja eigentlich ein Begriff aus dieser anti-deutschen linken Szene, die also sehr pro-israelisch und sehr pro-transatlantisch ist. Und er bringt jetzt diesen Begriff damit ins Spiel, was ein bisschen eigenartig ist, aber interessant durchaus. Jedenfalls ist er also der Auffassung, dass man sich sich gerade sehr gut über die Geopolitik erklären kann, warum es diese Spaltung im rechten Lager geht. Denn eigentlich würde man ja denken, naja, die Rechten haben doch die ganze Zeit gut zusammengehalten. Offenbar tut sich da einiges, weil man die Geopolitik fundamental anders beurteilt.
Ich bin mir da sehr unsicher. Ob man diese Geopolitik da so rein mobilisieren kann, ich verstehe sehr, dass der Kubitschik das wünscht, dass hinter diesem Handeln, das man da sieht, irgendeine Idee steckt, die man irgendwie in roten Pfaden bekommt. Aber Le Pen ist in ihrem Egoismus gefangen, auf nationaler Ebene die nächste Präsidentschaft zu stellen. Krah ist sowieso so ein egoistischer Sturkopf. Also der legt sich ja mit allen an, vor allem mit seiner Partei. Ich denke, nein, wir haben es hier mit einer Ansammlung singulärer Dummheiten zu tun. Und ja, man kann immer noch rote Pfäden darin sehen. Insbesondere, weil es ja etwas klügere Köpfe gibt, die auch strategisch, weil sie wissen, also weil das sozusagen, weil sie da so rein sozialisiert wurden, wie Orban, der seit Jahrzehnten diese Politik macht und ja auch totale Gesinnungswandel dahin legt, vom jungen Mann, zumindest ja bei Erdogan auch.
Nur, dass die AfD da gar nicht mehr eingeladen wird zu so einem Großkongress, ist ja schon bemerkenswert.
Ja, aber das ist so ein bisschen, wie die AfD halt den Sellner nicht einlädt. Man will mit diesen Leuten nicht gesehen werden. An denen hängt ein Stigma und dieses Stigma vergrößert sich umso mehr. Und ich kann es mir nur mit Dummheit erklären, dass der Kra in einem italienischen Interview den Franzosen nochmal erklärt. Das war geil, als wir euch beobachtet haben. Das war auch kein Verbrechen. Da war nicht einer dabei, der ein Verbrecher war.
Das war natürlich eine wahnsinnig blöde Aussage. Aber dass man gerade diese Spaltung erlebt der europäischen Rechte in jene, die quasi die Linie mit den Konservativen fortführen können in Bezug auf NATO, EU, transatlantische Verbindung und auf der anderen Seite die Anti-Transatlantiker hat und dass da jetzt gerade der Spalt sich vollzieht, ich glaube, das kann man nicht übersehen. Es wird noch andere Gründe geben als diese monokausale Begründung, die Kubitschek jetzt da heranzieht. Nur wir sehen ja, dass Meloni mit ihrem Flirten mit EU und NATO ja auch damit sichergestellt hat, dass sie nicht mehr kritisiert wird für das, was sie im eigenen Lande macht.
Ja, aber du musst halt auch überlegen, bei so außenpolitischen, warum willst du dich da so verheben? Dann doch lieber going with the flow, die NATO-Verteidigung regeln, dann lassen wir uns halt von der NATO die Verteidigung regeln, Hauptsache ich regiere Rom und so. Und so ist es bei Le Pen auch. Der Ereignishorizont ist, den man wahrnimmt, das ist Paris. Man will mit dieser Autokollonne durch Paris fahren und sagen, und hier kommt die französische Präsidentin. Das ist alles. Alles darüber hinaus. Es ist ja auch immer die Frage, wenn jetzt Kubitschek so darüber schreibt, hat er dann immer so einen Ansinn, dass er da jemanden aufklärt, aus der eigenen Milieu im Sinne von nochmal anders zu handeln. Glaubt irgendwer, irgendwer hat jetzt einen Einfluss auf Le Pen?
Also die, bzw. na, das ist jetzt, also das, dieser Text, den wir jetzt ja vorgetragen haben und bitte, wir, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht eine Empfehlung, Mensch, ein toller Text, sondern dies ist ein Text, den habe ich jetzt rausgezogen aus dem Inner Circle. Also dieser Text ist zwar für jeden zugänglich auf der Homepage, aber der ist natürlich nur verfasst für AfD-Mitglieder, damit die jetzt sagen, ah, also Alice Weidel könnte mein Feind sein. Also der versucht natürlich jetzt Politik für Krah zu machen über einen solchen Artikel.
Naja, der Krah wird auf jeden Fall europäischer Abgeordneter, und zwar über diesen Listenplatz 1. Und er wird gerade von allen verstoßen. Warum sollte man nicht, wenn man im Thüringer Wald oder wo auch immer da rumhängt, sagen, das wäre doch cool, wenn der sich von mir verstanden fühlte, wenn ich auf seinem Radar wäre.
Na die sind ja zusammen, also die nehmen ja auch Podcasts zusammen aus.
Naja, eben, also da einfach zu sagen, ich hätte schon gerne mal auch einen mächtigen Freund und nicht nur die Leute, mit denen ich ins Theater gehe oder so.
Bürgermeister von Pirnau oder so was.
Auf den kommen wir gleich zu sprechen. Also in deren Sicht ist es natürlich voll gut, dass wir in dieses Milieu mal reinschauen, wo man nicht versucht, noch Unbedarfte zu überzeugen, sondern für die schon überzeugt, noch mal die roten Linien zu machen, auch wenn es wie ich für eine hane Büchen ist. Apropos hane Büchen. Also ich mache es kurz angesichts der Zeit. Das Buch heißt Die Sprache des Kapitalismus. Und ich habe mir viel davon versprochen, von Simon, Sana und Daniel Ster, die ich beide nicht kenne. Aber ich nehme mal an, das sind so junge Leute, die irgendwie, keine Ahnung, kann man ja, kann man ja, kann jeder mal selber nachgucken, denn hier verspricht, also hier liegt ja das kleine Ding drin, dass hier so eine lexikalische Aufarbeitung von, ja was sind denn jetzt so die Idiome und Terme, also wo wird denn wie diskriminiert. Klar kriegen wir auch, aber bei den substanziellen Hinweisen, also heißt es dann hier zum Beispiel, es wird darüber debattiert, wo in unserer Sprache sexistische, rassistische, queerfeindliche und oder ableistische kurz diskriminierende Sichtweisen und Vorstellungen eingegraben sind. Wie vorhin schon gesagt, also diskriminieren wird sie immer. Die Frage ist nur, ja, sexistisch, rassistisch, queerfeindlich und oder ableistisch, dann in welchem Maße und mit welchen funktionalen Folgen, also wo verbaut man sich da Möglichkeiten und so weiter. Auf dieser Ebene wird das leider nicht verhandelt, sondern wir kriegen eine Aufklärung darüber, dass es wirkmächtige Mythen sind, die die Sprache in unseren Alltag einprogrammiert und einiges mehr. Bestehende Machtstrukturen werden verfestigt, Funktionen geschärft, wie auch immer. Wenn die Tagesschau von Preisexplosionen spricht, wird verschleiert, dass da jemand verdient. Inflation ist nicht einfach nur, es wird für alle teurer, sondern manche verdienen halt einfach mehr.
In diesem Rahmen und diese Pointe am Schluss, die ich jetzt einfach vorziehe, also wenn ich da kurz eine Nachfrage stellen darf, es ist also ein Buch, das sich anschaut, wie wird über Ökonomisches diskutiert, wie jetzt man darüber resonieren kann, wie wird über Migration diskutiert. Und jetzt wird hier geschaut, diese Begriffe sind keineswegs neutral, sondern sie sind oft nützliche Werkzeuge, um den Kapitalismus als Ideologie zu manifestieren.
Ich bin sicherlich zu kritisch für andere Leser, die jetzt sagen, hey, das ist doch voll interessant. Ich würde sagen, ich fände es gut oder hätte es gut gefunden, das war so meine Erwartung, dass ich Begriffe vorgelegt bekomme und dann eine Aufklärung darüber, wie sie mit dem Funktionieren des Kapitalismus im Zusammenhang stehen. Also wo mir, keine Ahnung, particularistische Interessen vorgegaukelt werden unter Gemeinwohlsemanthik oder sowas. Der Arbeitgeber ist das eigentlich derjenige, der die Arbeit gibt, der sie nimmt oder wie auch immer. Wer macht ihr wem Angebot?
Ja, das dachte ich jetzt, dass es darum geht.
Aber leider nicht. Sondern es ist dann mehr so ein ständiger wiederkehrender Hinweis darauf, dass er die Sprache des Kapitalismus diskriminiert. Dass sie also so verborgene Sachen und so weiter. Sie haben einen ganz kurzen Abschnitt zur Zeit. Den hebe ich nochmal heraus, weil wir Martin Hegelund gelesen haben. Hier heißt es also, die Zeit und die Aufteilung der Zeit, dass wir überhaupt von Freizeit sprechen, ist schon mal erwähnenswert. Denn von was ist diese Zeit eigentlich frei? Ach, von Arbeit. Also ist selbst die Freizeit von der Arbeit mitgeprägt und soll eigentlich auch genutzt werden, um sich für die Arbeit wieder vorzubereiten. Das ist sozusagen die Ruhezeit von der Arbeit. Damit überwölbt die Arbeit selbst die Freizeit. Und so sind natürlich richtige Hinweise. Und ganz am Ende kommt dann quasi diese Pointe. Zum einen reden sie davon, dass sie nur ein paar Hinweise gegeben haben in dem Buch, wie man denkt und wie man umdenken kann. Und sie nennen es aber selbst nur Trampelpfade, die sie machen. Wo ich denke, nee, der Kapitalismus rauscht schon so über Autobahnen, über das Land hinweg. Da muss man jetzt nicht sagen, wir haben mal ein paar Trampelpfade eingeschlagen, sondern dann will ich schon, dass dann auch mit einem Dampfwalz eine neue Straße gemacht wird, auf der wir dann neue Semantiken etablieren. Und ganz am Ende, als ich so dachte, okay, sie haben jetzt mehrfach geschrieben, dass sie auch Ulrike Herrmann ganz cool finden und ihr habt ja einen tollen Vorschlag gemacht, wie man so postkapitalistisch und so weiter, dass man so Kriegswirtschaft, nee, ist nicht, also wird nicht diskutiert, sondern so genannt immer wieder, dass das ja gut ist.
Ich bin gerade noch ein bisschen verwirrt wegen der Trampelpfade, denn es gibt ja in der Linguistik diese Trampelpfadtheorie, dass man also begründen kann, warum sich Sprache wandelt, auch deshalb, weil das einfach, man kann diesen großen, asphaltierten Weg gehen, da muss man aber diesen Umweg gehen. Und deswegen gehen Leute quer über die Wiese zum Eingang. Nee, hier wird nur der Begriff. Und deswegen fällt zum Beispiel der Genitiv weg. Und dann sagt man nicht mehr wegen des Stuhles, sondern wegen dem Stuhl.
Ja, kann sein, dass sie das mal gelesen hatten und deswegen den Trampelpfadbegriff holen. Also der kommt für mich ohne diesen ganzen. Das wäre auch nochmal interessant gewesen, wie man hier nochmal. Nun gut, am Ende jedenfalls, als ich so mehrfach den Hinweis der Autoren bekam, dass man ja den Kapitalismus eigentlich gerne überwinden möchte, aber es ja doch unrealistisch sei, deswegen mal lieber nur kleine Trampelpfade und Hinweise, wo vielleicht sich alte Mythen einschleppen. Ich also mir denke, Leute, wenn ihr den Kapitalismus überwinden wollt, sagt mir, was der Kapitalismus ist, damit ich weiß, was mich jenseits des Kapitalismus erwartet, nämlich irgendwas anderes davon oder so. Also man hat ja dann weder eine Aufklärung übers Diesseits, noch übers Jenseits, wenn jemand sagt, Kapitalismus überwinden.
Und Stefan will wissen, ob er sein iPhone behalten kann.
Ja, ich will einfach wissen, also haben wir da noch Geld oder muss ich nur mein Girokonto abgeben oder machen wir es dann ohne Gehalt, aber trotzdem arbeiten? Also wo sind jetzt die roten Linien und die grünen, die wir da so? So, während ich dann also denke, der Begriff Kapitalismus läuft hier völlig unbuchstabiert einfach mit in den Text. Und es geht dann nicht. Schreiben sie selber über andere Begriffe? Denn kaum jemand kann präzise definieren, was Wohlstand eigentlich bedeutet. Vielmehr steht der Begriff für einen diffusen Lebensstandard, der auf materieller, sozialer und privater Ebene angesiedelt ist. Häufig wird Wohlstand deswegen einfach mit Wirtschaftswachstum gleichgesetzt, was am Ende eine positive Wachstumsrate des Bruttoinlandsproduktes meint. Aus diesem Grund sind so viele politische Maßnahmen auch darauf ausgerichtet, das Wirtschaftswachstum zu maximieren. Auch viele ökonomischen Analysen stellen die Entwicklung des BIBs in den Mittelpunkt. Nur gibt es keinen wissenschaftlichen Beweis dafür, dass die Lebenszufriedenheit von Menschen in direkter Verbindung zu einem hohen BIB steht. Ich weiß, was Sie meinen. Und ich würde aber sagen, ne, wir haben ganz schön viele Aufklärungen darüber, dass ein bisschen mehr private Wirtschaftswachstum durchaus zu mehr Lebenszufriedenheit führt. Dass man dann darüber diskutieren kann, wo da irgendwo Haltelinien sind und irgendwann eine Boni-Diskussion nur noch. Wie viel Boni hat der? Da habe ich genauso viel. Also es nur noch so intrinsische oder innere Spiele gibt. Nur jemand, der so über Wohlstand redet, kann nicht über Kapitalismus schreiben. Also in deren Sicht leider ein Buch, das ich euch nicht empfehlen möchte, auch wenn es sehr einladend wahrscheinlich im Bücherregal irgendwo stehen könnte.
Wir bleiben beim Thema Kapitalismus. Stefan Kaufmann, der ein ganz grandioser Wirtschaftsjournalist ist, schreibt im Neuen Deutschland, dass wir diese Zeitenwende gerade erleben. Und wir uns doch fragen müssen, worin liegt der wirtschaftliche Ertrag des Neuen Kalten Krieges? Und dann sagt er, das kostet hunderte Milliarden. Allein die Aufrüstung. Es kostet hunderte Milliarden, wenn man dann alles neu strukturieren will, Lieferketten nicht mehr funktionieren, wenn man Blöcke bilden will.
Ja, warte, lass mich kurz eine kleine Pointe, die ich gestern nötig zufalle. Ich glaube, es war eher bei Moishef im Wirtschaftsbriefing. Borussia Dortmund lässt sich jetzt von Dings rein mit Teilsponsoren. Da denkt man so, okay, Dortmund kommt dann so mit dieser, wir wollen da auch ein Zeichen setzen, wir müssen uns verteidigen. Also so eine Campino-Aussage verknüpfen wir damit. Nur denke ich mir, was ist das eigentlich für ein Zeichen, wenn, und so referiere ich jetzt Moishef kennen, und das kann ich, also ich kann es mir gar nicht vorstellen, ich glaube ihm das jetzt einfach, dass der Rheinmetall-Chef beim Investors Call den Leuten sagt, sie haben ja alle gehört von diesen 100 Milliarden, 30 Prozent davon gehen an uns. Das sagt er einfach. Und jetzt klär du uns mal auf, wo der wirtschaftliche Mehrwert ist, wenn Rheinmetall 30 Milliarden überwiesen kriegt vom Finanzministerium.
Zunächst mal muss man festhalten, dass diese Investitionen in die militärische Aufrüstung der Ukraine zwar hoch sind. 70 Milliarden haben zum Beispiel die Amerikaner gegeben. Aber was wirklich teuer ist für Europa, sind eigentlich nicht die Waffen, die dahin exportiert werden, sondern ist einfach das, was an Einnahmen wegfällt. Hier heißt es dann Europas Direktinvestition in Russland. Die 2021 noch bei 250 Milliarden Euro lagen, sind geschrumpft und gefährdet. Einnahmen aus dem Export nach Russland sind um über 50 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr eingebrochen. Das heißt, das ist alles sehr viel teurer, als man das denkt, wenn man nur auf gelieferte Waffen blickt. Ein Prozentpunkt weniger Wachstum in der EU bedeutet einfach einen Verlust von 170 Milliarden Euro. Das muss man sich karbern. Also alles sehr teuer. Ist aber noch alles billig, verglichen damit, was man in Gang setzen müsste, wenn man China ausbremsen will. Aber interessanterweise findet ja das auch jetzt nach und nach statt. Und noch bemerkenswerter ist, die Ausbremsung Chinas? Ja. Noch bemerkenswerter ist, dass der Industrieverband BDI sagt, die sicherheitspolitische Lage lässt eine rein betriebswirtschaftliche Betrachtung zentraler Größen in der unternehmischen Beschaffung nicht mehr zu. Wie kann es also sein, dass also der BDI, also der Unternehmenvertritt, die in China ganz stark investiert sind, trotzdem sagt, das ist jetzt gerade der richtige Weg und wir können da nicht nur betriebswirtschaftlich draufblicken, das heißt wir können jetzt nicht nur über die Gewinne von Unternehmen nachdenken. Die eingeführten Zölle von Trump schon damals haben die US-Verbraucher und Unternehmen 180 Millionen Dollar gekostet, also extrem viel. Wenn man das so weitertreiben wird, dann reden wir von vielen, vielen Billionen, die das kosten. Wir haben jetzt, wenn diese Rüstungsziele auf 4% wie das manche wollen hochgehen, Ausgaben von 10 Billionen Dollar der G7-Staaten. Jetzt kann man über Erträge reden und dann stellt sich aber sehr schnell heraus, ja, diese Waffenexporte in Deutschland nehmen zwar zu, aber das sind ein paar Milliarden, das ist nichts, worauf man jetzt eine Wirtschaft aufbauen kann. Also das ist, da kann man nicht sagen, das ist es jetzt irgendwie. Und er zitiert dann den Ökonom Kostas Lapavitsas, der schreibt, statt formeller Imperien und territorialer Exklusivität benötigen die multinationalen Konzerne erstens einen institutionellen Rahmen, der es ihnen ermöglicht, den Weltmarkt auszudehnen und zu beherrschen. Und zweitens eine sichere Form von Weltgeld, um Verpflichtungen zu begleichen und die Wertproduktion global zu erhalten. Das heißt, die These hier ist, dass natürlich all das Geld, was da ausgegeben hat, nicht einen Ertrag bringt, in dem Sinne, wir exportieren Waffen und damit werden wir reich und so bereichern wir uns am Kriege. Das wäre so eine ganz plumpe Lesart, so ein Vulgär-Leninismus wäre das. Nein, worum es hier geht, ist also zu sagen, eine unipolare Weltordnung hat also für die Konzerne, die wir momentan haben, durchaus einen großen Vorteil, nämlich Weltgeld im Sinne von Dollar. Weltmarkt wird unipolar beherrscht. Precht hat uns gezeigt, wie der Westen die Regeln diktiert und das dann noch unter dem Deckmantel der Werte tut. Deswegen gibt es also auch von Seiten der Wirtschaft so eine Zusage, dass man das Ganze mitträgt und man rebelliert nicht. Hier heißt es dann, die reichsten Länder agieren als Banker der Welt. Zudem gewährleistet diese finanzielle Dominanz, dass die Finanzmärkte den Führungsmächten des Westens jeden Kredit gewähren. Das heißt, was jetzt kurz, wir sagen ja immer, die reagieren ja alle so kurzfristig. Eigentlich ist das schon eine sehr langfristige Strategie. Man kann damit durchaus auch ökonomisch rechtfertigen über so einen Umweg, warum das jetzt gerade Firmen wehtut, aber im Ganzen doch gewollt ist, wenn selbst BDI dahintersteht. Das heißt dann hier noch vorne, Stefan Kaufmann, vorbei sind damit die Zeiten des Neoliberalismus, von dem immer deutlicher wird, dass es sich bei ihm weniger um ein theoretisches oder praktisches Konzept handelte, sondern bloß um eine bestimmte Machtkonstellation auf dem Weltmarkt. Es war die Zeit, in der der Westen gesiegt hatte und seine Konzerne in der Lage waren, den gesamten Globus zu ihrem Vorteil zu nutzen. Das ändert sich, man möchte aber diese Änderung nicht. Und deswegen gibt es das sehr starke Bestreben, diese Blockbildung weiter herbeizuführen. Und damit sind wir natürlich an einem heiklen Punkt. Der sagt, der Bundesverband der deutschen Industrie drückt es so aus. Der Schutz des Völkerrechts gegenüber Russland sichert gleichzeitig die Grundlagen für internationale Wirtschaftsbeziehungen und ist daher prioritär für die Industrie in Europa. Also wir sehen hier nicht ein vulgär-lininistisches Bild von die Bereiche an sich am Kriege, aber man hat offenbar diese Einsicht, dass es gut wäre, wenn diese Blockbildung entsteht. Und so ist das ja auch mit den US-Zöllen, glaube ich, ganz gut sich zu verplausibilisieren. Wenn man bedenkt, dass das ja gerade viel Geld die Verbraucher und US-amerikanischen Unternehmen kostet, dann ist doch die Wette auf die Zukunft, die gemacht wurde, eine, die so aussieht, dass man sagt, es mag jetzt gerade ein bisschen teuer werden, aber wenn wir weiterhin unipolar in der globalen Wirtschaft agieren können, dann hat sich das im Ganzen gelohnt. Und diese Denkweise scheint, so wie Kaufmann hier in seinem sehr ausführlichen Artikel aufzeigt, sich gerade in den Köpfen festzusetzen.
Ja, diese Geopolitik scheint ein großes Thema zu sein. Ich finde es auch faszinierend, dass die Kriege, die früher immer Eroberungskriege waren, jetzt beuten wir hier aus, jetzt haben wir hier mehr, jetzt haben wir uns ausgebreitet bis ins letzte Jahrhundert hinein, jetzt einfach immer Kosten.
Die Kosten, genau.
Gar nichts zu gewinnen, den Kriegen.
Ja, außer einem Markt macht er in einer anderen Weise. Also klar, Rohstoff oder so gibt es auch noch ein bisschen. Wir haben das da auch mit Taiwan gehört, dass das wichtig ist, was Ressourcen anbelangt. Oder Neu-Caledonian hatten wir jetzt als Beispiel. Aber klar, es geht ganz viel um Märkte und auch um ein Dollar-System, ein Verschuldungssystem. Also so eine Multipolarität bringt ja zum Beispiel auch ganz viel ins Rutschen. Was jetzt Verschuldung anbelangt und auch Staatsanleihen. Also auch deutsche Staatsanleihen sind natürlich dann in ein ganz anderes Konzert eingebunden, wenn eine multipolare Welteordnung vorherrscht.
Der Krieg im Kleinen, Pirna. Ich hab gestern einen Leserhinweis bekommen auf die sächsische Zeitung sächsische.de. Ich hab natürlich kein Abo. Er hat es mir also zugeschickt. Vielen Dank. Ich hab grad versucht, nochmal den Namen rauszusuchen, aber in der Mail standen schon keine Stichworte mehr, weil er mir das per dm vorher hingewiesen hat und so. Und jetzt also ich danke dir ungenannt. So sieht die 100 Tage Bilanz von Pirnas Oberbürgermeister mit AfD Ticket aus. Tim Lochner ist für die AfD angetreten, ohne AfD-Mitglied zu sein, wie ich hier herauslese. Am 4. Juni sind die 100 Tage im Amt abgelaufen und man dachte sich, okay, schauen wir doch mal die 100 Tage Bilanz. Insbesondere, da er selber davon sprach, er stellt sich der 100 Tage Bilanz gerne. Er wurde also am 26. Februar, nachdem er am Dezember gewählt wurde, vereidigt. Und diese 100 Tage sind jetzt um. Man hat nachgefragt, wenn sie sich so drauf freuen, wollen sie selber eine Bilanz ziehen. Mache ich nach dem Wahltermin 9. Juni, wo man sich fragt, ah ja gut, dann war teilt die Europawahl ab, aber die 100 Tage sind ja trotzdem umgelaufen. Also hat sich die Sächsische hier gedacht, wir ziehen mal eine Bilanz. Ich habe leider keinen Autoren-Namen, aber es ist die Sächsische Zeitung. Eine der ersten Amtshandlungen, neue Friedensfahne. Auf dem Bürgermeisteramt wählte eine Fahne, der Mayor's for Peace, also der Bürgermeister für Frieden, die hat er runtergeholt, eine blaue mit weißer Taube hingehangen, um sich einfach aus diesem Mayor's for Peace, ich bin doch hier Einzelkämpfer, ich mache da jetzt hier AfD-Kram und so. Früher, diese Fahne, die da hing, war so eine andere. Er hat noch das Problem mit einer anderen Fahne, denn es gibt auch keine Regenbogen-Flage mehr, was bedeutet, dass der Tag gegen Homophobie und der CSD jetzt besondere Aufmerksamkeit erfuhr. Unter anderem haben sich in Köln Leute verabredet, mit Bussen dann nach Pürna zu fahren und zu sagen, so behalten wir uns mal dagegen. Sehr schöne Kontrapolitik, die er da selber provoziert. Also eine der ersten Ansammlungen, diese Fahne. Zweite Amtshandlung, die hier, neue Abfalleimer. Zwei neue Abfalleimer an den Bushaltestellen Breite Straße in Höhe des Friedensparks.
Also da wird am ganz großen Rad gedreht.
Die AfD in Pirna modelt alles um. Er hat die Mitglieder des CEO gegen rechts, des solidarisches Pirna und Pirna ist bunt. So vergräts natürlich, dass die schon bei seiner Vereidigung geschlossen den Saal verlassen haben. Im Stadtrat nehme ich mal an, heißt das dann dort. Er hat eine sehr kurze Antrittsrede gehalten und für kollegiales Ringen um gute Lösungen geworben. Er möchte zum Beispiel schwerpunktmäßig den jahrelangen Stillstand in Sachen Kulturstätten beenden. Aber außer, dass er das eine Antrittsrede ansagte, hier nichts erwähnenswertes.
Ja, bringt er uns dann wenigstens die D-Mark zurück oder so und Pirna.
Es gab einen geplanten Verkehrsversuch Gartenstraße. Das ist eine Einbahnstraße, in der Fahrradfahrer auch entgegengesetzt hätten fahren dürfen. Dieser Versuch wurde abgeblasen von ihm, denn man hätte Pkw-Stellplätze dafür streichen müssen. Das ist natürlich unvereinbar mit der eigenen hochtragenden Ideologie. Außerdem provozierte er mit Facebook-Kommentaren. Er hat diesen Quatsch mit diesen Flaggen, keine bunte Flagge mehr und jetzt auch nur noch die eigene Friedensflagge und so. Was bedeutete, dass die evangelische Kirchengemeinde auf dem Kirchturm, der wahrscheinlich ein bisschen höher ist als das Rathaus, ihrerseits jetzt Flaggenprotest machte, woraufhin er einen Facebook-Kommentar schrieb und das Hissen der Regenbogenfahne mit dem Hissen von Hagenkreuzfahnen im Dritten Reich vergliche? Was dann dazu führte, dass Bettina Böttinger, also die Fernsehfrau, und Karoline Kebekos darauf aufmerksam wurden, was natürlich dann so ein kleines Bürgermeisteramt in Pirna auch wieder dreifach heimzahlt. Also darüber kamen dann auch die Kölner auf die Idee, wir schicken da mal LGBTQ-Busse mit lauter Kölnern drin, die dann in Pirna mal Straßenfest machen. Nun ja, eine Toilette soll geöffnet werden, nachdem sie drei Jahre schon geschlossen war.
Aber es ist doch schön, dass man so Bürgermeister ist, aber eigentlich dann so der typische Facebook-Rentner ist, der nochmal irgendwie durch die Gegend pöbelt. Also dafür braucht man ja kein Amt.
Diese Toilette ist aber immer noch zu. Also er wollte da irgendwie, dass es im Friedenspark wieder eine Toilette gibt. Außerdem hat er seinen Büroleiter vorgestellt.
Hauptsache keine Gender-Toilette, ne?
Er hat seinen Büroleiter vorgestellt. Seine erste Personalie, Timo Backofen, der allerdings in Dresden für das Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht antritt, sich es also mit dem Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht verdorben hat, weil die natürlich nicht so einen AfD-Hand hat, der irgendwo irgendwas machen will. Und gleichzeitig denkt man sich da auch, du bist jetzt hier Büroleiter, willst aber eigentlich in den Dresdener Stadtrat. Also das ist ja völlig Banane. Was ist denn das für ein Quatsch? Und tja, letzter Punkt hier in dem Text. Die Fraktion Bündnis 90, die Grünen, SPD, CDU und Linke, CDU und Linke, Asiamerika, wurde verlangt im Osten. Hat gesagt, es wäre doch eigentlich ganz cool, wenn wir unsere Stadt, in unserer Stadt auch, beitragen mit Feierlichkeiten zu 75 Jahre Grundgesetz. Also der Stadtrat hat diesen Beschluss gemacht, den aber Lochner bisher nicht umsetzte. Denn das hieße ja eine Festrede halten. Kann ja nicht. Grundgesetz Festrede halten. Nun ist aber so, wenn der Stadtrat etwas beschließt, ist das bei Oberbürgermeistern, Landräten so, dann ist man da gebunden. Also dann muss man das machen. Man ist halt da in diesen Verwaltungsposten. Das ist kein politischer Posten, sondern Verwaltungsposten. Und jetzt gibt es da halt Streitereien, die erst mal so gelöst werden, dass am 23. Mai im Ratssaal im Rathaus ein großer Festakt fürs Grundgesetz stattfindet, veranstaltet von den restlichen Parteien. Und das einzige Verhalten von Lochner dazu war, dass er jetzt dem Stadtrat die Verwendung des Ratssaals verbietet. Und das muss jetzt irgendwie vor Gericht geklärt werden. Oder keine Ahnung, wie man das dann da macht. Das ist die große AfD, die irgendwer im Walde immer noch in roten Linien sieht, die irgendwas und so. Aber nee, das ist einfach dumm.
Ich mache es ganz schnell. Wir gehen noch einmal auf den afrikanischen Kontinent nach Südafrika. Dort gab es Wahlen mit einem überraschenden Ergebnis. Denn Cyril Ramaphosa, der ja auch ein paar Mal zitiert wird von Precht im Buch, ist abgerutscht von 57% auf 40%. Damit steht die ANC zum ersten Mal nicht alleine dann da. Was interessant ist, ist, dass auf 15% Jacob Zuma kam, der ja so als der Trump Südafrikas gilt. Da wird man sehen, in welche Richtung sich das bewegt. Oder ob man doch mit den Linken da zusammenarbeiten wird. Jedenfalls für uns ist nun interessant ein Artikel aus der Financial Times. Denn mir war schon aufgefallen, dass die Wahlbeteiligung nicht hoch ist. Dieser Artikel ist von Monika Maag. Dieser Artikel ist vor der Wahl erschienen. Aber jetzt zur Wahlbeteiligung will ich noch nachtragen. Es gab 42 Millionen Wahlberechtigte, 28 Millionen hatten sich aber nur registriert und 16 Millionen sind zur Wahl gegangen. Das heißt, knapp über ein Drittel hat gewählt. Monika Maag hat in der Financial Times nun darüber geschrieben, dass die jungen Menschen sich von der ANC abwenden und eigentlich auch von der Demokratie. Sie zitiert hier eine 28-Jährige, die ist bei der staatlichen Entwicklungsagentur angestellt und sagt, wählen ist einfach ein Schneeballsystem, das die Gewählten immer reicher macht. Das heißt hier, 30 Jahre nachdem Nelson Mandela's afrikanischer Nationalkongress mit dem Versprechen an die Macht kam, Millionen verarmter schwarzer Bürger zu helfen, gehörte ein Thema zu einer jungen Generation, so heißt die Frau, die so disillusioniert von der Demokratie ist, dass sich nur 40 Prozent als Wähler eingetragen haben. Also bei den Jungen ist es noch viel schlimmer. Als Zeichen ihrer Disillusionierung lehnten in einer Umfrage des Human Sciences Research Council einer südafrikanischen Denkfabrik fast 60 Prozent der Südafrikaner im Alter von 18 bis 24 Jahren die Vorstellung ab, dass die Demokratie immer das beste Regierungssystem sei.
Das ist nicht weit weg von den Zahlen in Deutschland, wenn man die jungen Leute so fragt.
Ein anderes Think Tank, da sagt die Direktorin, die Vorstellung, dass die Demokratie einer kleinen Gruppe von Eliten zugutekommt, hat sich in unserer Gesellschaft festgesetzt. Die unter 35-Jährigen heißt es dann weiter in dem Artikel, etwa ein Drittel der Wählerschaft könnten eine Post-ANC-Welt herbeiführen, wenn es den zunehmend selbstbewussten Oppositionsparteien gelingt, die jüngere Generation zu gewinnen. Diese Generation, die den Spitzennamen Born Free trägt, hat ihr ganzes Leben unter einer ANC-Regierung verbracht, die zunehmend von Korruptionsskandalen heimgesucht wird. Die Partei sorgte zunächst für einen Anstieg des Lebensstandards, aber ein wachsendes Wohlstandsgefälle hat Südafrika laut Weltbank zum ungleichsten Land der Welt gemacht. Zwei Jahrzehnte wirtschaftlicher Stagnation haben dazu geführt, dass die Hälfte der jungen Menschen arbeitslos ist, die überwiegende Mehrheit von ihnen schwarz. Wenn man also jetzt Fragen stellt, was ist passiert da, wie konnte das geschehen, dann brauchen wir noch nicht mal die KI zu fragen, sondern wir haben hier diese Zahlen. Reicht im Prinzip, kann den ganzen Artikel mal lesen, aber im Prinzip sind das die Fakten, die wir brauchen, um diese Demokratiedämmerung einordnen zu können. Und ja, wir schauen jetzt mal, wie die Europawahl ausgeht, welche Konstellationen sich da ergeben. Und dann sprechen wir bestimmt über das eine oder andere Ende des Monats.
Ja, wir sehen uns auf der Bühne bei denjenigen, die in die KS kommen. Ich rede dort über Emotionen und künstliche Emotionen. Artificial Intimacy wird es nicht, aber das finde ich eine gute Begriffssetzung von Eva, nicht von Eva Illou, sondern von Esther Perel, so heißt sie. Und am Ende des Monats gucken wir mal, was politisch stattfand. Bis dann. Bis dann.